PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND
RETIREMENT WILL COME TO ORDER
GOOD AFTERNOON IN RESPONSE TO
THE COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY
AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES. WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO TOUR THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE IN THE CAPITAL WITH ONE OF
OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY SENATOR
MORALE IS ATTENDING REMOTELY
TODAY SENATOR MEL MERRELL ARE
YOU. ON THE LINE. SENATOR
HURDLES ON THE LINE IN THE
PRESENT. THE NUMBER OF YOU HAVE
STAFF WITH YOU TODAY. I DO HAVE
OTHER KERRY IS HERE TODAY. IF
YOU WITH YOU IN THE ROOM OR IN
ANOTHER ROOM SHE'S IN ANOTHER
ROOM WOULD YOU LIKE ME
TOGETHER. YOU KNOW THAT'S
THAT'S FINE JUST WANTED TO KNOW
WERE THERE SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND CENTER MORALE AS A
REMINDER. PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I ASK THAT
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU USED TO
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO FUND MUTE.
PLEASE SELECT MUTE BEFORE YOU
BEGIN SPEAKING. R. I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
YOU WHEN YOU ARE DONE. IT'S
RECOGNIZED. PLEASE CAN IN ON
THE SCREEN. STATE YOUR NAME AND
THEN YOU ARE READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS. WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WE WILL
BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR
ALL INDIVIDUAL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT
NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS. 1-844-291-6364 IN THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE SIX EIGHT
SEVEN FOUR EIGHT THREE LET ME
REPEAT THAT. ONE EIGHT FOUR
FOUR TWO NINE ONE. THREE FOUR
YEAH THIS CALL IS. ONE SIX
EIGHT SEVEN FOUR EIGHT THREE
FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW THE TELECONFERENCES TO
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE IN
ORDER TO BE WET. WHEN WE MOVED
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU PROMPTED BY.
L. ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION PRESS THIS ONLY
ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR
AN OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A
LINE NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A
SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU RECEIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT
IN THE QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR
TO CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER AT
THAT TIME YOU WILL BE ON MUTED
AND YOU ARE NOW READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
PUT THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR. TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE TODAY. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY. AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR- HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS. IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. SO WE
HAVE TWENTY SEVEN BILLS OWNER
TODAY'S AGENDA- AND- WE WILL
BEGIN TODAY SINCE WE DO NOT
HAVE THE IT THE ABILITY TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM WE WILL
BEGIN AS A SUB COMMITTEE. AND
THEN WE WILL ESTABLISH A QUORUM
AS SOON AS IT IS PRESENT SO WE
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO VOTE ON ANY
BILLS UNTIL WE HAVE ESTABLISHED
THAT QUORUM. SO WE HAVE A FIRST
AUTHOR IS HERE TODAY. AND I'D
LIKE TO WELCOME- THIS ITEM
NUMBER ONE ON OUR AGENDA.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX EIGHTY FIVE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES WELCOME.
IT'S NICE TO SEE YOU TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. PLEASE
PROCEED THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS
TODAY I PRESENT TO YOU EIGHTY
SIX EIGHTY FIVE WHICH IS THE
COMMONSENSE MEASURE AIMED AT
PROTECTING OUR COMMUNITIES AND
LOWERING EXPOSURE TO COPE WITH
NINETEEN. SPECIFICALLY
EXPOSURES IN THE WORKPLACE.
WE'VE SEEN THE EFFECTS OF THE
PANDEMIC AND HOW IT HAS SHIFTED
OPERATIONS FOR EMPLOYERS AND
EMPLOYEES NATION WIDE. AT
TODAY'S HEARING SHOWS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS NO EXCEPTION.
THE LEGISLATURE HAS GONE ABOVE
AND BEYOND TO ENSURE OUR
EMPLOYEES ARE SAFE AND
PROTECTED UNFORTUNATELY NOT ALL
EMPLOYEES IN THE STATE HAVE
THAT LUXURY OR ACCOMMODATION.
EVERY DAY OUR CENTRAL WORKERS
ARE RISKING THEIR LIVES AND THE
LIVES OF THEIR LOVED ONES
WHENEVER THEY GO TO WORK TO
KEEP OUR STATE FUNCTIONING. IT
IS NO SURPRISE THAT COPE WITH
NINETEEN INFECTIONS AND DEATHS
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT THE
LATINO BLACK AND ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER COMMUNITIES.
COMMUNITIES A MAKE UP THE
MAJORITY OF OUR STATE LOW
WORKERS. DO EVERYTHING IN OUR
POWER AS A GOVERNING BODY TO
ENSURE OUR CENTRAL WORKERS ARE
PROTECTED. CURRENTLY EMPLOYERS
MUST REPORT FATALITIES AND
SERIOUS INCIDENTS. BUT IT IS
ONLY RECOMMENDED THAT EMPLOYERS
REPORT REPORT INFECTIONS. THERE
IS NO COMPREHENSIVE MANDATE TO
REPORT EXPOSURES IN CASE
PUBLICLY FOR TRACKING PURPOSES.
IF WE ARE SERIOUS ABOUT GETTING
THIS PANDEMIC UNDER CONTROL WE
MUST GET SERIOUS ABOUT CREATING
A COMPREHENSIVE REPORTING
FRAMEWORK THAT WILL ALLOW
WORKER PROTECTION AGENCIES
WORKERS THEMSELVES AND THE
PUBLIC TO COMBINE FORCES AND
MINIMIZE COLLECTIVE RISK. AB
SIX EIGHTY FIVE FOCUSES ON THE
BASIC STEPS EMPLOYERS MUST TAKE
TO CONTROL WORKSITE EXPOSURE OF
COBIT NINETEEN THIS INCLUDES.
IMMEDIATE NOTIFICATION TO
WORKERS AND UNIONS OF POSSIBLE
EXPOSURE TO AN INDIVIDUAL WITH
COBIT NINETEEN. NOTIFICATION TO
PUBLIC HEALTH AND WORKER SAFETY
AGENCIES OF THE EXPOSURE AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY TRACKING
EXPOSURES TO IDENTIFY HOT SPOTS.
PROTECTING OUR CENTRAL
WORKFORCE IS CRITICAL FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH AND TO THE RE
OPENING OF THE ECONOMY HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE IS MITCH STEIGER
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION AND
CAITLIN VEGA LEGAL DIRECTOR
WITH UFCW WORSE WESTERN STATES
COUNCIL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND BUT DIDN'T
LET ME BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO THE
WITNESSES- IF ESTABLISH SOME
TIME. LIMITS ON THE TESTIMONY
AND DUE TO THE CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF OUR
HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND THE CLEANING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE CHAIRS MAY
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY EACH SIDE WILL BE
PERMITTED AN EQUAL AMOUNT OF
TIME. TO BE DETERMINED BY THE
CHAIR ALL OTHERS WISHING TO
TESTIFY AFTER THE ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND THEIR POSITION
ON THE MEASURE SO WHAT WE WILL
BE DOING TODAY BECAUSE OF THE
LENGTH OF OUR AGE. IS THAT WE
WILL ESTABLISH A TIME LIMIT
FOR- THOSE IN SUPPORT THE
WITNESSES AND THOSE IN
OPPOSITION TO A TOTAL OF EIGHT
MINUTES. EIGHT MINUTES FOR
SUPPORT AND EIGHT MINUTES FOR
OPPOSITION- SO YOUR FIRST
WITNESS IS A MISTAKE OR MITCH
ARE YOU THERE. YES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BURR IS MUCH
TIGHTER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION. A CO SPONSOR
THIS BILL ALONG WITH UNITED
FOOD AND COMMERCIAL WORKERS AND
CALLS OF COURSE LIKE TO THANK
OUR AUTHORS AND MEMBER RAMPS
AND CO AUTHORS FOR ALL THE WORK
THAT THEY'VE DONE. WITH THE
CELL THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
AS MENTIONED BY THE AUTHOR THIS
IS AN INCREDIBLY HUGE PROBLEM
THAT WE'VE BEEN OUT THERE SINCE
THE START OF THIS PANDEMIC AND-
ENDEMIC HAS PROGRESSIVELY
BECOMING MORE AND MORE OBVIOUS
THAT. THIS IS ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY WE'RE SEEING
OUTBREAKS IN CERTAIN AREAS THAT
WORKERS ESSENTIALLY HAVE TO
RELY ON THE RUMOR MILL TO KNOW
IF THERE. IS AN OUTBREAK
STARTING AT THEIR WORK. AND
WHAT THAT SAYS DONE IS. A LOT
OF THEM A LOT OF THEM WITH.
WOULD COMPROMISE. IMMUNITY
ISSUES AND OTHER CONCERNS TO
JUST GO TO WORK AND HOPE THAT
NOTHING BAD IS HAPPENING AND
THEY JUST DON'T KNOW. AND ALL
THIS BILL REALLY DOES IS MAKE
SURE THAT EMPLOYERS WHEN THEY
ARE NOTIFIED. PUBLICATION OF
THE NINETEEN- EXPOSURE TO COVER
NINETEEN THAT THEY- NOTIFY THE
WORKERS THEY NOTIFY THE UNION
IN THE APPROPRIATE STATE
AGENCIES SO THAT. PEOPLE COULD
ACTIONS CAN BE TAKEN. AND
THAT'S GOING TO BE DIFFERENT
EACH CASE FOR WORKERS. THEY CAN
DO WITH THAT INFORMATION WHAT
THEY WELL THE STATE AGENCIES
WILL HOPEFULLY USE THAT TO.
PRIORITIZE RESOURCES TO MAKE
SURE THAT. WHERE CASES ARE
REALLY GETTING OUT OF CONTROL
THAT THEY PAY CLOSER ATTENTION.
AND ALSO JUST WANTED TO BRIEFLY
TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE
OPPONENTS CONCERNS. AND ONES
THAT WERE REALLY TRYING TO
FOCUS ON WHAT. AMENDMENT THAT
MAY BE COMING SOON TO THE BILL.
BUT THE BIGGEST ONE IS LIKELY
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE THIS
MORE CLEAR FOR EMPLOYERS SO
THAT. WE WANT. TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS.BUT DON'T SURE THAT
WHEN WORKERS NOT WHEN WORKERS
NOTIFY EMPLOYER. AN EXPORTER
HAS A ABOUT TWO TRIGGERS IT.
RIGHT NOW THE BILL BROKERAGES
AND NOWHERE CHAU KNOW STANDARD
THAT COMMON GROUND WORKERS COMP
AND HEALTH AND SAFETY. WE WANT
TO MAKE IT CLEAR TO EMPLOYERS
THAT THIS ONLY APPLIES WHEN.
WHEN THERE HAS BEEN THAT CLEAR
NOTIFICATION THERE ARE ALSO A
VARIETY OF OTHER AMENDMENTS
THAT WE'RE GOING TO DO ONE OF
WHICH IS THAT. THE EXPOSURE
MUST HAVE OCCURRED AT THE WORK
SITE- THE BILL DOES NOT REQUIRE
EMPLOYERS TO DISCLOSE ANY
CONFIDENTIAL MEDICAL
INFORMATION. AND THERE ARE A
FEW OTHERS OF PROGRESS ON WORK
WITH PRIVACY WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THE PERSON IDENTIFIABLE
INFORMATION. IS NOT SUBJECT TO
A PR IN REQUESTING CAN'T BE
SHARED WITH OUTSIDE AGENCIES
OTHER THAN COLLISION OF THE
PART OF PUBLIC HEALTH. OVERALL
THE MAIN THING THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE IS JUST MAKE
SURE THAT. WORKERS HAVE THE
IMPORTANT INFORMATION THAT THEY
NEED TO KEEP THEMSELVES SAFE ON
THE JOB. AND WE ARE YOUR
SUPPORT. GOOD YOU VERY MUCH OF.
A YOU HAVE A SECOND. I BELIEVE.
VEGA YES MISTER BIG UP. THANK.
YOU MISTER CHAIR IN NINETEEN
NUMBER. OKAY HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE U. S. B. W. LECTERN STATE
COUNCIL WE REPRESENT MEMBERS IN
MEAT PACKING PLANT AND GROCERY
STORES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
AND WE STARTED HEARING STORIES
LIKE THIS RIGHT AWAY IN THE
PANDEMIC ABOUT WORKERS COMING
TO WORK AND FINDING OUT THAT
SOMEONE AT WORK HAD GOTTEN THEY
HAD BEEN ON. THAT HOME BECAUSE
THEY TESTED POSITIVE- BUT WE'RE
NOT GIVEN THAT INFORMATION
UNTIL THEY HAD ALREADY NOT ONLY
BEEN EXPOSED THEMSELVES IN MANY
CASES ON HOMES AND THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS I KNOWINGLY EXPOSING
THEIR FAMILY TO WHATEVER
ADDRESS THEY WORK. TO THE
WORKING SITE WE ALSO SEEN CASES
WHERE NOTIFICATIONS ARE NOT
MADE TO CALLOUS AT AND ARE NOT
MADE TO THE PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT NO ONE IN THE WHERE
TO EVEN BEGIN THE CONTACT
TRACING OR TO ENSURE THAT.
HELLO CHAU GUIDELINES ARE BEING
FOLLOWED UP WITH IN THE
WORKSITE IT WAS VERY IMPORTANT
TO OUR UNION THAT WE
STREAMLINED UNIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS AND ALSO THAT WE
START TRACKING BY EMPLOYER WE
VIEW THIS CRISIS AS
FUNDAMENTALLY AND WORKER SAFETY
CRISIS FAR TOO MANY WORKERS ARE
BEING EXPOSED AT THE WORK SITE
EITHER BECAUSE THEY AREN'T
GETTING ACCESS TO KEEP
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT THEY NEED.
THEY ARE BEING TOLD ABOUT
OUTBREAK THEY ARE BEING HEARD
TO LEAVE WORK WHEN THEY DON'T
FEEL WELL IN SOME CASES THEY
FACE RETALIATION WHEN THEY
REQUEST PASSING OR WHEN THEY
REQUEST ACCESS TO INFORMATION
ABOUT WORKSITE SAFETY. ALL
ACROSS THE BOARD WE FEEL THAT
THIS. IS AN URGENT CRISIS.
ABILENE THAT THE RELEVANT STATE
AGENCIES AND LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS HAVE ACCESS
TO THAT INFORMATION AND WE CAN
TRACK WHERE THE EMPLOYERS WHERE
THEY INDUSTRIES WHERE WE SEE
OUT AND WHERE WE NEED TO
DEVELOP THE FORCES OUT OF OUR
AUTHOR MENTIONED AND I WANT TO
THANK OUR AUTHOR OF FOR HER
INCREDIBLE LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE THIS IS KIRK THE
CORONAVIRUS HASREALLY-
EXACERBATED THE INEQUALITY THAT
WE ALREADY FACE IN THE STATE
AND FEDERALLY. RIGHT NO WORKERS
BASED ON THE JOB CURRENTLY-
CALIFORNIA CASES ARE ABOUT 60%
LATINO DUE IN LARGE PART TO THE
FACT THAT THAT YOU KNOW WORKERS
BEEN MUCH LESS LIKELY TO BE
ABLE TO WORK FROM HOME AND
OFTEN ANY PHYSICIAN THAT
REQUIRE THEM TO GO DAY AFTER
DAY AND SO MANY OTHER WORKERS
ARE ABLE TO SHELTER AT HOME AND
BE PROTECTED FROM THE THREAT.
THAT WE BELIEVE THAT IT BOTH AS
WORKER SAFETY CRISIS AND ALSO
REALLY A RACIAL JUSTICE ISSUE
THAT WE HAVE TO ACT AS A STATE
TO INSURE WORKERS HAVE BEEN
INFORMATION AND IN THE STATE IS
ABLE TO IMPORT ARE NOT. WE
THANKS FOR YOUR- THANK YOU. FOR
THE TESTIMONY IN ASSEMBLY IF IT
IS WITH YOU BY WE ON TO THE
TELECOM WITNESSES SO IF WE
COULD A CORE PLEASE WITH THE-
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CENTER
PLEASE TURN ON MICROPHONE SPEAK
INTO THE MICROPHONE FOR THE
PURPOSES OF ROLE CENTER HILL.
HERE SENATOR HILL HERE SO
MORALE. HERE CENTER A CENTER
MOREAU HERE CENTER JACKSON
JACKSON HEARING CENTER JACKSON
HERE CENTER MITCHELL MITCHELL
HERE CENTER MITCHELL HERE
CENTER PAN. HERE THANK YOU
CENTER PAN HERE. VERY WE HAVE
ESTABLISHED A QUORUM SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND- WE WILL NOW
GO TO- WITNESSES HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIX EIGHTY FIVE
WHO ARE IN THE GALLERY IS THERE
ANYONE HERE REALLY TO TESTIFY
GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
CREEK COMMITTEE CHRISTY VALMONT
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS IN SUPPORT. GOOD
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
IN THE GALLERY. TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT WHO MOVED TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY ANYONE IN TWENTY
FORTY WISHING JUST TESTIFIED IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIX EIGHTY FIVE
C. NO ONE THERE. THANK YOU WE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO THE
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY BE
THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
MODERATOR. IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROPERTY INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX
EIGHTY FIVE WE WILL BEGIN.
SHARE AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NOW. AGAIN
FOR SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO NOW. IF YOU'RE IN THE
QUEUE FOR OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS THE ONE DOWN THERE- NOW
TO REMOVE YOURSELF. AGAIN THIS
IS FOR. PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN THEIR OWN NOW. THE
MODERATOR THEN WE'D YOU HAVE
ABOUT. THIS IS FOR OF AB SIX
EIGHT FIVE FOUR MAKE SURE THAT
THE- THOSE ON THE LINE NO THAT.
AND WE DO HAVE ABOUT TWELVE AND
THE QUEUE. FIRST OF ALL TELL
LINE. ONE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE
CALL I HAD. NO I BOTTOM ALL
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR
THE TESTIMONY. MAXALT ONLINE
ONE SIXTY EIGHT PEOPLE I HAD.
EXACTLY WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MAXILLA TIMELINE
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES YOU ARE WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
MACULATA ONE FORTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. FOR BLACK AMERICA ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
PESTICIDE REFORM AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. IAN MAC THE LITTLE
TO LINE A ONE THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA THAT A CONFERENCE OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS WORK
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ENACT THE
LAW TO LINE SIXTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. DAVID RUFFIN THE
COMMUNITY ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY
FARMERS IN SUPPORT VERY GOOD
THANK YOU FOR TESTIFYING.
MACULATA LINE TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS TOM RILEY
ON BEHALF OF WESTERN
OCCUPATIONAL ENVIRONMENTAL
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MAPPILA
TIMELINE AT ONE FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
MEDIA THE NEEDS THAT I WAS FINE
AND WITH THE WAREHOUSE WORKER
RESEARCH CENTER AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT LEVEL
TIMELINE ONE TWENTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MEMBERS ATT BROUGHT
ON THE AFTER THE TEAMSTERS AND
AMALGAMATED TRANSIT UNION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NOT A LOT TO LINE ONE THIRTY
ONE CLEVELAND HAD. THAT'S THAT
WE'RE ON WE HAVE GOT TO FIGHT
ACTION NETWORK FILIPINO
COALITION FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA AND LEADERSHIP
COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. AND AS A REMINDER TO SHOW
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THEIR OWN NOW AGAIN ONE THEN
ZERO TO SHOW SUPPORT. AND IT
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE A PMR COMING
AND IT'LL BE JUST A MOMENT
THANK YOU. NOW LOOKS LIKE WE
HAVE Q. AND THE Q. AND JUST A
SECOND I ANNOUNCE THE NEXT LINE.
NEXT THE LOCAL LINE OF ONE
FIFTY THREE AND SUPPORT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE ONE FIFTY THREE
WALDRON. MY NAME S USUALLY
MONTERO IN BEHALF OF PHYSICAL
THERAPY ASSOCIATION IN
CALIFORNIA I AM IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MAX A LOT TIMELINE
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MONEYNESS WHAT THE MUCH THAT
THE IT WAS REPRESENTATION SANTA
CRUZ ACTION BRINGING CARMIE AND
WE ARE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
HELLO TIELINE ONE EIGHTY ONE
GLAD. OR IS PETERSON OVER
CENTER FOR ANY. PURPOSE BUILT
ENGINEERING THAT I SUPPORT AB
THREE ZERO SEVEN FIVE. THANK
YOU. AND THEN WE HAVE JUST ONE
MORE IN MY QUEUE IT UP IN JUST
A MOMENT. THAT THE LAW TO LINE
ONE SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. REBLOG THIRTY SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE NO MORE
IN THE QUEUE AT THE MOMENT AND
MODERATOR WOULD YOU PREFER
CURRENTLY- PROPS ONE MORE TIME
TO SEE IF THERE ARE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IF I COULD SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF. AB SIX EIGHTY FIVE.
SURE AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE BEEN THERE ON NOW.
AGAIN. ONE AND THEN ZERO FOUR
SUPPORT. AND SO WE HAVE ABOUT
THREE IN THE QUEUE AND I'LL
JUST A MOMENT. IMMACULATA LINE
SIXTY EIGHT CRITICAL I HAD. MY
NAME IS LAURIE WELL- WITH
AMERICAN PHYSICAL THERAPY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. ENACT
THE LOCAL LINE EIGHTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES PAUL SMITH
SENATE DISTRICT STATE SENATE
DISTRICT TWENTY THREE- I CALL
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND WE
NEED TO HAVE A PMR QUEUING UP
AT THE MOMENT IT'LL BE JUST A
MOMENT BEFORE I ANNOUNCE THE
NEXT NUMBERS THERE'S PEOPLE IN
THE QUEUE THANK YOU. BACK TO
THE HOTEL. NINE ONE EIGHTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
KEVIN MCCARTY AND A PHYSICAL
THERAPIST ASSISTANT AND I AM
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SEN MACK MIDDLETON LINE ONE
SIX- SORRY ONE EIGHTY SIX LINE
ONE EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS ANNE
HAPPILY IN THE PHYSICAL
THERAPIST FROM- DISTRICT
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT AB TWO
TWO FIVE SEVEN. THANK YOU. AND
THEN IT LOOKS LIKE WE DO HAVE A
ONE MORE AND MAKE YOU IT'LL BE
JUST A MOMENT. WE NOW HAVE A
FEW IN MY QUEUE ABOUT THREE.
THANKS A LOT TO LINE ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS LEAH PHYSICAL THERAPY
FIFTY CENT FROM THE DESCRIPTION
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT
INTEGRATION OF AN AMENDMENT TO
AB TWO TWO FIVE SEVEN TO
ADDRESS HARDSHIPS CREATED BY AB.
AND DAY NUMBER THREE THIS IS A
LIFE THREATENING IT'S NOT THE
BILL WHAT WE'RE DISCUSSING
RIGHT NOW RUN. EIGHTY SIX
EIGHTY FIVE I THINK YOU. IN
SUPPORT FOR THAT BILL. PLEASE
MOVE ON AND MODERATOR. SATURDAY
NIGHT OF OCT ONLINE AT ONE
SIXTY THREE PEOPLE I HAD. I'M
SORRY I'M ON THE WRONG- I'M
WAITING FOR A DIFFERENT BILL.
HELLO TO LINE AT ONE FORTY TWO
pTURNER I'M A PHYSICAL THERAPIST
SEVEN SUPPORT ALTHOUGH IF
SUPPORT OF AB TWO FIVE SEVEN
AND THE THIRTY BEEN CALLED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THIS
THERE'S NO ONE THANK YOU A
MOMENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH HAVE
BEEN HEARD FROM ALL OF THE
SUPPORTERS WE WILL NOW FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS. HERE FROM ANY
OPPOSITION I UNDERSTAND THERE
ARE TWO WITNESSES LEAD
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OF ROB
MORE TREE. FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND JEFF
NEAL FOR LEGISLATIVE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES. YOU WILL HAVE A TOTAL
OF EIGHT MINUTES BETWEEN YOU.
PLEASE CHECK PROCEED. MR
MOULTRIE I WOULD SUGGEST. THANK
YOU SENATOR HELLO AND GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE I HOPE YOU
CAN HEAR ME CLEARLY YES WE CAN.
PERFECT AGAIN ROBERT WHICH IS
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND WE ARE OPPOSED TO
AB SIX EIGHTY FIVE. AND THANKS
AFFECT THEIR OWN L. I THINK
REALLY CATCHES A LOT OF THE
INDICATING CONCERN THIS BILL-
AND- JUST START UP AND BEING
CLEAR WE ARE NOT OPPOSE THE
BILL BECAUSE THEY WANT TO
DOWNPLAY. HOLDEN NINETEEN OR
BECAUSE YOU'RE OPPOSED TO
PROVIDING SOME KIND OF.
FEASIBLE NO- OUR CONCERN HERE
IS REALLY WITH THE TAX THE BILL
HAS IT IS WRITTEN IN THE FORM
THAT IT IS NOT CLEAR OR
WORKABLE INJURY. CONTROL FOR A
SHOULD WE FAIL TO COMPLY WITH
THE. IN THE U. S. RECALL AND I.
AT THE MENTION OF A TO A TO THE-
YOU. AND CLARIFY TRIGGER. I
APPRECIATE THAT MENTION DOES
HAVE A SHARING WITH THAT SO I
CAN'T SPEAK TO THE PRESENT BUT
GLAD TO HEAR THAT THEY ARE
POTENTIAL DAHLE QUALITY WITH
THE TECH. PRESENT SO FIRST
DEALING WITH THE TREE EXPOSURE
ON THE TRIGGERING EXPOSURE TO
COLD AT NIGHT OF BILL REFERENCE
THINGS LIKE EXPOSURE TO SOMEONE
WHO MAY HAVE BEEN NINETEEN. BUT
THE BILL DOES NOT DEFINE WHAT
QUALIFIES AS AN EXPLOSION- AND
THIS IS IMPORTANT WE THINK
ABOUT YOU KNOW FOR EXAMPLE
APPLYING TO THE WORKPLACE. AND
IF I HAVE A WORKER WHO IS UNDER
WORKPLACE MORE THAN TEN FEET
AWAY FROM EVERYONE ELSE AT ALL
TIMES. AND ORDER HERE WEARING A
PROPER FACIAL COVERING
COMPAGNIA. CALLOSUM DIED. BUT
ONE OF MY WORK COUNTY. IT
SOCIAL GATHERING AT AS NOTED BY
THE I PLAY THAT THE SPOT. THE
BILL HAS NOT WOMEN TO EXPOSE IN
WORKPLACE BY THE KIND OF WHERE
WITH THE OKAY ORDER NOR. AND
pPROP BE BETTER. THIS BILL IS
NOT CLEAR WHETHER THE WORKER
PROPERLY DIDN'T IN KEEPING
COMPETENT. IN MY AND HELP THAT
WOULD BE. THAT MEANS THAT WE
DON'T KNOW WHEN THE TRIGGER IS
FLIP SO TO SPEAK AND AS NOTED
THAT ONLY TWENTY FOUR HOURS. TO
DETERMINE IF THIS WAS A
QUALIFYING. IN PROVIDER
REQUIRED THAT BUT- CLEARLY
APPROPRIATE GIVEN THE BRIEF
TIME ON. THAT IMPROVISED LOOK
TO. HOW WILL ALSO PART OF THEIR
GROWTH THE CUSTOMER PRIME
BECAUSE FOR CALIFORNIA PLAYERS
WERE AND PLAY CURRENTLY UP FOR.
PROTECTIONS FROM DISCLOSING
HEALTH CONDITIONS TO A POINT
THAT WE HAVE BEEN CONCERNED
THAT SPONSOR MENTION THAT I'M
HOPEFUL THAT THEY CAN BE
RESOLVED BUTTON CONCERNED ABOUT
REQUIRING POLICE TO DISCLOSE
HEALTH INFORMATION- EMPLOYERS
AND EMPLOYERS AS WELL THE
COMMISSION TO STAGING. I HAVE
KNOWN ANOTHER POINT BACK YET BY
IT BONTA KNOWLEDGE AND BE A
CONCERN THERE THEN BRING TO DO
WITH THE FACT BEGIN GET YOUR
EVEN IF CAN TURN THAT A I KNOW
TO ARE KEEPING A CLOSE HAD THE
HEARD WHAT QUALIFY AS I'M
GIVING THE REQUIRED. THE BILL
PACKAGES ONE THAT ANOTHER OF
BACKING. BUT BILL TECH RICK IN
TO CALL MAKE READ EFFORT THAT
TO NOTIFY. BEFORE BUT AGAIN
WHAT THAT MEAN IN A CO NINETY
CONCEPT LAST YEAR YOU KNOW YOU
TO HELP A VERY LARGE AND JUST
HOPE THAT. SOMETHING BEGINNING
IS BACK OF THING. BUT NOW THAT
NOT THE OCCURRING AND WE DON'T
WANT TO HAPPEN NEED. IT DOES
NOT REQUIRE. INDIVIDUAL PHONE
CALLS THE REQUIRED MAIL TO. HOW
DO WE FIND SURE WE MAY EVERY WE
EFFORT NOT EARLY JADI THE E.
OPTION TO THIS QUICK AND SCALE.
WOULD BE A NEW BUT THAT HE. I
WANTED. SO AND I DON'T HAVE A
FIGURE I JUST KNOW THAT AIM TO
WOULD BE GREAT THREE FOR A WHEN
YOU GET PENALTY AND BILL. OF
ANOTHER CORNER LIKE ADDED THE
PRESS THIS BILL DOES REALLY
SEPARATE THE GOOD IN THE ACT
NOTABLY. THIS IS PERTAINING TO
THE NOTE THAT. TO HELLO SHE THE
PUBLICATION THAT INFORMATION
WHICH IS THAT LATER SECTION OF
THE BILL. PRESENTLY IN IT
PROVISION. REQUIRED TO REPORT
ANY SUCH. EXPOSURES THAT THEY-
IN ADDITION TO THE PRIVACY
CONCERNS THE MANSION GO THE
CONCERN HERE IS OKAY LET ME I
WOULD HAVE AND AT THE IT SAID
THE WORKER CATCHES KATE CHAU
RIGHT OR THEY THEY PARK OVER
THERE CAN'T THEY DON'T KNOW
THEY COME TO WORK FOR A WEEK
AND THEY START TO SHOW SIGNS IT
DID CAN BE A FOR LENGTHY. IT
HAPPENED BOB. THE POINT THE
EMPLOYER PRETEND THAT. EVERY
CALENDAR BECAUSE- PROPERTY. A
WORKER. BUT AN INVOICE AND THEN
I GET CAUGHT SOMEWHERE ELSE.
THAT STILL IN THE QUALIFY LOWS
IN THE BILL THAT WILL RESULT IN
A REPORTING. HELLO CHEF AND
OPEN PUBLICATION THAT EMPLOY.
YEAH I WAS EMPLOYER HAD MORE OF.
THIS EASILY THE MATH NOTED
DESPITE TRANSACTION. AND THIS
IS ALL COMPOUNDED THE FACT
CARRIED CRIMINAL IF YOU CAN'T
DETERMINE EXPO AND WITH
REQUIREMENTS INTO FOUR HOUR.
YOU TAKE MEDINA COLONEL. THAT
PUT THAT INTO SITUATION WE GO
TO. ARE REALLY SUFFER HERE
BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW HOW TO
COMPLY. SO ALL RIGHT THERE AND
PASS IT OVER TO THE COUNTY FOR
THESE REASONS WE OPPOSE TO
FIGHT. WHAT THE INTENTIONS AND
UNDERSTANDING- WE'RE CLOSE THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND THE MISTER NEAL YOU
HAVE. TWO MINUTES AND FORTY TWO
SECONDS LEFT. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. THAT JACKIE. WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES- TO START BY SAYING
THAT WE SHARE THE CONCERNS
EXPRESSED BY NATURE MISTER
MUTRIE. AND I WAS GOING TO SAY
THAT WE APPRECIATE AND AGREE
WITH THE INTENT OF THE BILL. I
DO HAVE SOME. THE WATCH THIS TO
PUBLIC AGENTS BIRDS. AS A-
POSSIBILITIES AS A HOSPITAL OR
THE CLINIC. OR IN JAIL
SHERIFF'S STATION OR A PUBLICLY
RUN HOMELESS SHELTER RECREATION
FACILITY- WHERE NOTIFICATIONS
WOULD CONCEIVABLY HAVE TO BE
PROVIDED. BOTH IN WRITING AND
FOR ME AS OFTEN AS DALY. AT THE
END OF COURSE THE RISK THAT A
PUBLIC SERVANT ADMINISTERING
THOSE FACILITIES WOULD FACE
MISDEMEANOR CHARGES- IF
NOTIFICATION WAS. DELAYED FOR
ANY REASON. AND NOTIFICATION
CITY THAT THE WORKERS
THEMSELVES EXPERIENCE IN THESE
CASES- SO NOT ONLY A WE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE POTENTIAL.
THE BRIEF TO THAT COULD LEAD
BECAUSE SO THAT BUT WE'RE ALL
WORRIED DAY EVEN. A SINGLE
TENDER DOLLAR FINE IN CERTAIN
INSTANCES COULD FORCE THE
CLOSURE OF A BUSINESS THAT THEY
CAN'T THAT A COUNTY BOARD OF
THE PUBLIC AGENCY RELIES ON THE
AND THAT SURVIVES ON A MARGIN
AN EXAMPLE SUCH AS EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION FACILITY.
THAT SERVES EMERGENCY WORKERS
OR OTHER PERSONNEL OR A
HOMELESS SHELTER RUN BY A
NONPROFIT BUT CONCERNED ABOUT
THE POSSIBLE EFFECTS ON THESE.
PAGES ENTITIES IN THAT GAP EVEN.
AT A SINGLE VIOLATION. CAN YOU
JUST WORKING. VERY CLOSELY
CORPS WITH THIS. WITH OUR OWN
PUB HELP TO. THAT THE BILL
WOULD HAVE NOTICED. AND OF
COURSE WITH OUR TEAM ST COURSE
OF THE- TO KEEP THE PUBLIC
ENEMY STATE. INCLUDING CURRENT
ONGOING NEGOTIATIONS WITH
UNIONS ABOUT THE BEST WAY TO
MAKE EXACTLY THE NOTIFICATIONS.
SO I WANT TO THANK YOU MISTER
CARE THE OPPORTUNITY SPEAK
TODAY AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR TO MAKE
THIS BILL BETTER. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE TESTIMONY WE
WILL NOW- MOVED TO WITNESSES IN
THE GALLERY IN OPPOSITION TO A.
B. SIX EIGHTY FIVE IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE GALLERY WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SEE NO
ONE. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO ROOM
TO FORTY IS THERE ANYONE IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. TO A B.
SIX EIGHTY FIVE C. IN NO SEE NO
ONE THERE- MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE PROMPT THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY SIX
EIGHTY FIVE WE WILL BEGIN. AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO UPHOLD AB YEAR SIX
EIGHTY FIVE. PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO NOW AGAIN THIS IS FOR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO NOW. WELL FIRST BILL
TO LINE ONE FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BLIGHTS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AIRPORTS COUNCIL
AIRPORTS ARE OPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WELL NOT GO TO LINE THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
DILLON GIBBONS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION I OPPOSITION
HOPING THAT PUBLIC AGENCIES
REMOVED FROM THE BILL. THANK
YOU. THE LAW TIMELINE AT ONE
NINETY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS RICHARD AND I'M MORE
OF A PHYSICAL THERAPIST
ASSISTANT- FRIEND- CENTER BILL
DISTRICT OF CALIFORNIA AND I
SUPPORT INCLUSION OF AN
AMENDMENT TO AB. TWO TWO FIVE
SEVEN TO ADDRESS HARD SORRY. AB
FIVE THE MEASURE THAT'S NOT
BILL WE'RE DISCUSSING RIGHT NOW
THIS IS A EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY
FIVE THOSE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
MOVE ON MADAME MODERATOR. SHARE
THANK YOU. THE LAW TO LINE
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN
BREAKING THE PEACE EDUCATION
ACT CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE
DISTRICT IN OPPOSITION FOR THE
WRITTEN PREVIOUSLY THANK YOU
THANK YOU. MAXALT CAROLINE
NINETY ONE PLEASE- I HAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS STATE
MORTGAGE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY AND THE FAMILY
FITNESS ASSOCIATION A
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU. MAXALT AT ONE SIXTY
SEVEN PLEASE CALL I HAD HE- YES
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
CASTING DOWN AUSTIN
REPRESENTING UNITED AIRLINES
SIDE WE ALONG WITH THE AIRLINES
FOR AMERICA THE BILL THANK YOU.
JUST SO YOU KNOW WE HAVE ABOUT
SIXTEEN MORE IN THEY KEEP. AND
AS MIND THIS IS FOR OP FOR
EIGHT YEARS THANK EIGHTY FIVE
ON THAT GOAL LINE ONE NINETY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
KATIE HANSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION. WE ARE HERE IN
OPPOSITION AS WELL THANK YOU.
IN FACT THE WHOLE TIMELINE ONE
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
KEVIN ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF THE
HEALTHCARE DISTRIBUTION
ALLIANCE AND FAMILY WINEMAKERS
THE CALIFORNIA ALSO IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MACROPHYLLA TIMELINE TWENTY
THREE PLEASE CALL I HAD. HI
THERE WHAT THE CALIFORNIA THERE
COULD BE GROCERS ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NATURAL LOT TIMELINE
A ONE FORTY PLEASE GO I HAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CARE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MATTHEW ON THE
WESTERN GROWERS. WE ARE ALSO IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. MAXALT
ONLINE ONE FIFTY POLITICAL I
HAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THAT STUFF
ANYMORE WELL ON BEHALF OF THE
ADVANCED MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION AND VIACOM. THANK
YOU. NETTLETON NINE ONE EIGHTY
NINE PLEASE CALL I HAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CARE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE OF OUR KNOWING HE
TOOK ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA
CITRUS MUTUAL ALL CALIFORNIA
FRESH FRUIT ASSOCIATION FARM
EQUIPMENT DEALER IN- CALIFORNIA
RIGHT MISSION WHAT YOUR PLAN
HEALTH ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS
SEVERAL OTHER ARAB ORGANIZATION
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. WELL
NEXT COURT TRYING ONE EIGHTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN PERSONAL
COLD RICE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION IN ME TO R. COSTA
THANK YOU THANK YOU. MONOCLE
COMBINED ONE THIRTY FIVE PLEASE
CALL I HAD. JERRY MEMBERS CAME
AND DIMITRI WITH THE FACT THAT
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU. ONE
MEXICO TIMELINE ONE FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN TOM SHE HE
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
LANDSCAPE CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION IN OFFICE. WE DO
UNDERSTAND THE NEED TO TRACK
TRACE COVERED CASE LETTING
OTHER STUDENTS THANK YOU ALL
BUSINESSES CRIMINALS INFIGHTING.
THANK YOU PLEASE MOVE ON
MODERATOR. IF SOMEONE I GO TO
EIGHT THREE PLEASE CALL I HAD.
IN THE MAIL. PHYSICAL THERAPIST
DISTRICT. FORTY AND I IN THE
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. WELL I FULL TIME ONE SEVEN
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR MEMBERS AMY
BLOOMBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH FACILITIES AND
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. MONOCLE
TIMELINE FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
KAMALA COMPETITION IN WINE
GRAPE GROWERS WE ARE RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE ABOUT FOUR MORE IN
KILO ONE ECHO TO LINE AT ONE
SEVENTY SEVEN CRITICAL HAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN JOHN
CALDWELL ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA HOTEL AND LODGING
ASSOCIATION WERE OPPOSED. THANK
YOU THE ONE THAT GOLDLINE KILL
NINE VEHICLE I HAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISS CHAIRMAN THIS IS
MAY HERE WITH CALIFORNIA LIFE
ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ONE THAT CALLED KLEIN ONE SIXTY
VERY PLEASED BECAUSE I HAD. THE
MARKET VENERATION REPRESENTING
MASTER HEALTHCARE SOLUTIONS I
AM IN OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY
EIGHT EIGHT FIVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. MONECK BLOODLINE ONE
FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MARGARET LATCHING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION WERE IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. MONACO TRYING TO
ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THAT
PERSON AT THIS CONNECTED WE
HAVE ONE MORE IN Q. AT THIS
MOMENT I'LL BE JUST A MOMENT TO
ADD VERY MINOR FOR OPPOSITION
EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO NOW
AGAIN FOR OPPOSITION. FOR
EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE
PRESS. ONE THAN THEIR OWN NOW.
GO TO ALIGN TO. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS BOB NAYLOR FOR SIX IN
KENNESAW TWO THOUSAND ASSISTED
LIVING FACILITIES OPPOSE EIGHTY
SIX EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU. AND
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU
AT THE MOMENT VERY GOOD THANK
YOU MODERATOR APPRECIATE THAT
THANK YOU TO ALL OUR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WE WILL
NOW BRING THAT DISCUSSION BACK
TO THE MEMBERS- REMEMBER HAVE
QUESTIONS OR- YES SENATOR
JACKSON. THANK YOU A MANAGER
AND- MEMBER SIDE I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT. I
DAY'S WERE WERE TESTING IN A
BOWL AND- TAKE A TRACING IS
EVEN MORE QUESTIONABLE THAT AT
LEAST WE GIVE PEOPLE SOME
KNOWLEDGE OF WHETHER OR NOT%
THEY HAVE BEEN ACTIVELY EXPOSED
OR ACTUALLY HAVE COME DOWN WITH
COVERT NINETEEN. THAT BEING
SAID. I OUR- QUESTIONS BECAUSE
IF THIS WERE SO SIMPLE I THINK
WE WOULD HAVE BEEN DOING THIS
ALREADY- ONE OF THE SUGGESTIONS
USE THAT WE TRY TO- ADDRESS AND
BOB MODEL IS. ON THE BEST
PRACTICES THAT WAS ONE OF THE
RECOMMENDED YES IT WAS ME BOB.
I ABC COMMITTEE STAFF OF AND
CARE ON THIS MAN AND I DIDN'T
KNOW WHETHER OR NOT THERE WAS
SOMETHING. YOU WERE ABLE TO AND
I YOUR. NAPPING I DO WE HAVE
TO. I KNOW I KNOW BUSINESSES
ARE ALWAYS OF THEY'RE GONNA GET
SUED SOMETHING A THE MORE
AFRAID OF THAT THE- TRYING TO
FIX PROBLEM ON THE FRONT AND
BUT I DO AGREE WITH SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT THEY'VE
EXPRESSED. IN THE HOPES THAT
THEY RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE
OF MAKING SURE THAT THEIR
EMPLOYEES. AND THE WITH WHOM
THEY CONDUCT BUSINESS WHETHER
IT'S ONE ON ONE OR WHAT HAVE
YOU ARE. DID IT SHOULD FORM
SYMBOL. TO THEIR AS WELL COURSE
BUT THAT BE SAID I IF YOU CALM
ON. SOME OF LECTURE CONCERNS
PARTICULARLY IN IN THE AREA ALL
OF. THE GET DIRECTIONS SO THAT
AT LEAST HAVE PERHAPS SOME KIND
OF COMMON I SIDE AND- FOR
JURORS. IN NEW OUR MORE. THAN A-
AND IF WE MAKE THE- THANK YOU
SENATOR. THANK YOU SENATOR
ABSOLUTELY I THINK THAT IN OUR
DISCUSSIONS WITH. THOSE WHO
HAVE VOICEDTHEIR OPPOSITION-
WE HAVE LEARNED MUCH OF ON FROM
THE EMPLOYERS PERSPECTIVE. AND
HAVE INCLUDED TO MATCH MUCH OF
WHAT THEY HAVE REQUESTED- AND
WE ARE WORKING ON THOSE
AMENDMENTS- WE ARE CLARIFYING
THE BILL TO REQUIRE
NOTIFICATION. ONLY ONCE THE
EMPLOYER BECAUSE THIS I THINK
THAT WAS MISTER MONITORING WHO
HAD SAID. THEY OPPOSE THE FACT
THAT WE INCLUDED LANGUAGE IS
SAID. THAT IF EMPLOYER KNEW OR
SHOULD HAVE KNOWN. THAT'S ONE
OF THOSE CHANGE IS THE WILL BE.
ARE ALSO GOING TO CLEAR APART.
THE COULD BE EXPOSURE TO WERE
THE SOME OF THE EMPLOYERS IT'S
WELL WE IF THERE WERE REMOTE
THERE'S STILL A OR STOLEN. WE
STILL HAVE NOTIFY SO WE WANT TO
COMMENTS AMENDMENTS TO THIS-
WE'RE NOT TRYING TO MAKE IT SO
DIFFICULT BUT I DO APPRECIATE
THAT EVEN OF THE OPPOSITION
THEY RECOGNIZE THE NEED TO
PROTECT OUR WORKERS THESE ARE
THEIR EMPLOYEES. THESE ARE THE
PEOPLE THEY'RE HELPING THEIR
BUSINESS STEP ALIVE SO I AND I
THINK THAT IT'S NOT A QUESTION
OF WHETHER WE HAVE GOOD ACTORS
ARE BAD ACTORS WHAT THE
EMPHASIS HAS TO BE ON THE
EMPLOYEES WE HAVE TO PROTECT
THE EMPLOYEES- WE ALSO ARE
WORKING ON AND AMENDMENTS TO
CLARIFY THAT THE TRIGGERING
EVENT. IS THE EXPOSURE OF THE
WORKSITE BY PERSON WITH THE
BEEN DIAGNOSED AS HAVING CO BID
FOR ORDER TO ISOLATE ON THE
SYMPTOMS. COVERT NINETEEN. WE
ARE GOING TO PROVIDE DOES NOT
EMPLOYER TO DO. COMP MEDICAL
INFORMATION. THESE ARE ALL
THINGS THAT I THINK FALL UNDER
BEST PRACTICES AND WE WILL MAKE
SURE THAT ALL OF THESE ARE
INCLUDED. THANK YOU OTHER KEPT
QUESTIONS YES SENATOR PAN. I
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH AND-
FIRST OF ALL IT'S WANT THANK-
THE SEMI WOMEN FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD AND-
APPRECIATE- BOTH HER WORK AND
SPONSORS AND TRY TO BE SURE WE
PROTECT WORKERS AND THAT THEY
HAVE INFORMATION THAT- THEY
NEED TO ATTRACT YOU TO SELL
STATE SENATOR FANS MICROPHONE
ON- IT IS I'M NOT SURE WHAT.
OKAY THE HEARING. NOW THE
SOUTHWEST AREA OKAY SO ON THAT
THE PROVIDER ALL RIGHT- BUT I
THINK THAT. YELL AT I HEARD
THAT YOUR TAKING AMENDMENTS TO
ADDRESS I THINK THE TRIGGERS
AND SO THAT'S ONE THING I DID
WANT TO TRY TO GET INTO A
LITTLE BIT AND- BECAUSE AT
LEAST SO FAR I'VE HEARD NO
ANSWER DISAGREES WITH THE
PREMISE OF THE BILL PER SE AT
LEAST KNOWS EXPRESSED THAT YET
I THINK THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT
HOW WOULD WORK. SO AND I HEARD
YOU DID OUTLINE SOME OF THE
AMENDMENTS THAT YOUR PLANE TO
TAKE AROUND THAT. I GUESS IN
TERMS OF- NOTIFICATION AGAIN
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO THEIR
TIME BE SURE EMPLOYEES ALSO
ACCURATE ACTIONABLE INFORMATION
RIGHT SO YOU TALKED ABOUT
RUMORS AND PEOPLE HAVEN'T ACT
AROUND RUMORS. SO TERM OF.
ASSEMBLY SAID THIS DEBATE
EMPLOYEE HAS A POSITIVE SO
FIRST PERSONAL PRIDE ONE
THRESHOLD WOULD BE A PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENT THAT'S PRETTY
STRAIGHTFORWARD. A SOMEONE
WHO'S POSITIVE I GUESS ARE WE
LOOKING AT SOME PARAMETERS
AROUND THAT AND SO I MEAN BY
THAT IS IF YOU'RE IN A THAT'S A
RETAIL TYPE LOCATION RIGHT WHAT
IS OTHER PEOPLE FROM THE PUBLIC
COMING IN. AND SOMEONE.
NOTIFIES THE EMPLOYER RIGHT I
WAS IN YOUR STORE R. I WAS YOU
KNOW IN YOUR SITE. AND I'VE
COME BACK POSITIVE I TESTED
POSITIVE FOR A COVETED. TWO
WEEKS AGO R. I WAS YOU KNOW
THAT AND WHAT WOULD THEY HAVE
TO DO RIGHT SO THE SENATE
EDUCATION SAYING SOMEONE CAME
BY TWO WEEKS AGO. FOR LAST WEEK
L. BECAUSE AMERICA THE TECH
THERE WAS A LACK TIME THEY GOT
THE RESULTS WE KNOW SOME PEOPLE
WAITING A CONSERVE AMOUNT OF
TIMES SAME ALSO WITH AN-
EMPLOYEE AS WELL IN TERMS OF
THAT. TURNAROUND TIME IF THEY
CHOOSE TO REPORT- ALSO WHEN YOU
SAY POSITIVE TESTS YOU KNOW THE
PCR TEST IS THE TEST THAT
ACTUALLY TEST WITH THE YOU'RE
ACTIVELY INFECTED. DELIVERY
DISTINGUISHING THAT FROM A
SEROLOGY TESTS WHICH COULD BE
USED SOMETIMES. OF COULD DETECT
RECENT SECTION BUT COULD BE FOR
AN OLD INFECTION THE PERSON HAS
BEEN RECOVERED. I REALIZE THESE
ARE TECHNICAL ISSUES PERHAPS
BUT- AND- I SEE YOUR BILL FOR.
BUT I THINK THAT IF THERE'S
EITHER SOMEWHERE TRY TO ADDRESS
TO PROVIDE SOME CLARITY AROUND
THAT BECAUSE OF. SITUATIONS
MAYBE THAT SHOULD BE LOOKED TO
HER PLEASE HE'S- ACCURATE FACTS
WELL IN. TION THAT THEY CAN.
FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN
INCORPORATE THOSE TYPES OF
MECHANISMS WITH THE GUIDANCE OF
PUBLIC HEALTH TO ENSURE THAT
ARE UP TO DISPOSE CLARITY FOR
EMPLOYERS BUT ALSO THAT THE
EMPLOYEES ARE GETTING
INFORMATION THAT IT. FULL TO
THEM ANYWAY SO- THAT THAT-
INSTEAD OF PERHAPS GETTING LOTS
OF NOTICES THAT THEY'RE NOT
SURE HOW TO INTERPRET. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU DR PAM I THINK
THAT ONE OF THE FIRST THINGS
YOU TALKED ABOUT WAS RUMORS. A
RUMOR IS NOT GOING TO TRIGGER
THIS- WE- WE HAVE EMPLOYEES WHO
TESTED POSITIVE. THOSE ARE THE
EMPLOYEES THAT ARE NOW EXPOSING
THE BRICK THAT. EXPOSING OTHER
EMPLOYEES ARE. THE EMPLOYEES
MUST BE NOTIFIED I ABSOLUTELY
WOULD TO A WELCOME THE INPUT
FROM THE DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HELP. IN SETTING THE PARAMETERS
I THINK THAT IF WE KNOW WHO ALL
OF THE DETAILS OF COPA NINETY
IN AND WE KNEW WHAT THE DATE
IS. IT WAS. FIRST ON NO. SO THE
PURPOSE OF THE BILL I THINK T
WOULD HAVE TO AND- WITH THE
RECOGNIZE IS TO PROTECT THE-
AND IF WE KNOW THAT SOMEBODY
WAS EXPOSED TWO WEEKS AGO. THAT
STILL NEEDS TO BE REPORTED
BECAUSE WE WANT TO KNOW IF
THEY'RE HOT SPOTS. SO MAYBE
NOBODY ELSE HAS BEEN EXPOSED TO
IT BUT IT'S STILL A HOT SPOT
BECAUSE YOU HAVE AN EMPLOYEE
THERE THAT HAS TO GO TO CAL
OSHA THAT HAS TO GO TO THE-
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC. HEALTH THE-
ROLFING THAT WE ARE WORKING
WITH STATE CALL AND IT'S BEEN A
VERY MEANINGFUL AND ROBUST
DISCUSSION- WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND COMING UP WITH
pFOR AMENDMENTS THAT I'VE THAT
I'VE THOSE SPECIFIED HERE. THAT
IS A FOLLOW UP AGAIN JUST AS
QUICK FAR SO ENOUGH TO IT I
THANK YOU SO MANY WOMEN- YEAH
CERTAINLY I AM VERY INTERESTED
IN SEEING WHAT THE AMENDMENTS
ARE DECKED OUT I KNOW THATYOU
AND THE SPONSORS TO WORKING ON
THEM. I A THERE ARE SOME
NUANCES- THAT- THAT WE NEED TO
THINK ABOUT HOW WE NAVIGATE
BEGAN TO ACHIEVE YOUR VERY GOAL
THAT YOU EXPRESSED- TO BE SURE
THAT WE PROTECT EMPLOYEES AND
DO SO IN A IN A MANNER THAT'S-
THAT'S IT'S GOING TO BE. THAT
TRULY DOES IS EFFECTIVE FOR
THEM SO- CERTAINLY I'D BE YOU
KNOW- I'M GONNA BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL TODAY BUT ALSO WANT
TO. ALSO SEE THE ATTENDANCES
ARE COMING FORWARD AND I
RECOGNIZE THAT YOU KNOW THERE
ARE SOME COMPLEXITIES THAT
THAT- THAT STILL. NEED TO BE
WORKED OUT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU OTHER QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS SO I JUST AND I WANT
TO ASSURE MEMBER IS THE IN THIS.
A VERY IMPORTANT BILL- I MEAN
SOME OF THE STORIES WE'VE
HEARD- IN SITUATIONS THAT WE
FOUND EMPLOYEES HAVE FOUND
THEMSELVES IN A BEEN BEEN VERY
DIFFICULT- BUT I THINK YOU HAVE
A LOT OF WORK AHEAD OF YOU
DEFERRED FROM SOME MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AND CERTAINLY
FROM THE OPPOSITION. IN NUMBER
OF STAKEHOLDERS THAT ARE
INVOLVED SO IT WILL BE A IT
LOOKS AS IF WE'LL BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT THE BILL THAT I WILL
SUPPORT THE BUILDER DAVID
CERTAINLY WANT YOU TO WORK
CLOSELY IF YOU WOULD WITH A
COMMITTEE- AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD SO THAT WE CAN KIND OF
REFINED AND KIND OF PUT OUR-
AROUND SOME OF. THESE ISSUES
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED. TODAY UP
BY MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AS
WELL AS SOME OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS SO THANK YOU FOR
THAT AND A WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLUBS. YES I DO WANT TO THANK
THE- AND TO STAFF FOR THE WORK.
ON THIS BILL. AND I WANT TO
TAKE THE TIME TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THE CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
ANALYSIS. AND BY THE
STAKEHOLDERS. SOME OF THOSE
I'VE ALREADY DISCUSSED HERE.
WE'VE BUT I DO WANT YOU TO KNOW
THAT WE HAVE MET WITH LOCAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS AND TO THE
EMPLOYER OPPOSITION TO
UNDERSTAND THEIR CONCERNS. AND
WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON THE
AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS THESE. IN
ADDITION TO THOSE AMENDMENTS
THAT I HAVE DISCUSSED I DO WANT
TO MENTION THAT ANOTHER.
AMENDMENT IS TO ADD THAT
EMPLOYERS CANNOT RETALIATE
AGAINST WORKERS. BASED ON THE
DISCLOSURE OF POSITIVE CODE
NINETEEN TEST OR DIAGNOSIS.
WE'RE ALSO SEEKING FEEDBACK
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION TO
ENSURE THE BILL IS
IMPLEMENTABLE AND TO CONSIDER
WAYS TO MAKE THE DATA PUBLIC
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE IN A WAY
THAT IT'S COST THAT IS COST
EFFECTIVE. I AM COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS WITH
INDUSTRIES ON HOW TO
STREAMLINED REQUIREMENTS AT
MULTI EMPLOYER ENVIRONMENTS
SUCH AS THE AIRPORTS WITHOUT
JEOPARDIZING THE MOST
VULNERABLE WORKERS LIKE OUR
JANITORS WHO MAY BE EXPOSED
THROUGHOUT THE WORK SITE. ON
BEHALF OF THE ESSENTIAL WORKERS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. VERY GOOD THANK YOU IS
THERE A MOTION ON. A. B. SIX
EIGHTY FIVE WE HAVE A MOTION BY
DOCTOR PAN. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS- THANK
YOU OF IT PLEASE SIR CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AND THE
VOTE. MEMBERS PLEASE TURN ON
YOUR MICROPHONES IN ORDER TO
VOTE CENTER HILL HI CENTER HILL
HI. CENTER MORALE SENATE AROUND
NO CENTER MORALE NO CENTER
JACKSON JACKSON AYE CENTER
JACKSON HI CENTER MITCHELL HI
SENATOR MITCHELL HI CENTER PAM
HI HI CENTER PAN HI. THE BILL
HAS FOUR. THROUGH INSTEAD OF.
QUESTION RAISED WOODEN- VICE
CHAIR MERRELL VOTED I SAW HIM
ON MY SCREEN WAS HE ON THE
SCREEN HERE WAS THERE A VISUAL
OF. I'M SORRY. COULD WE DO THE
VOTE ONE MORE TIME FOR VICE
CHAIR MORRELL SO THAT HE'S VOTE
WILL BE RECORDED ON THE SCREEN
FOR EVERYONE TO WITNESS. THE
BILL IS AB SIX EIGHTY FIVE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CENTER MORALE.
GENERAL WILL TO KNOW CENTER
MORALE NO. THANK YOU THE VOTERS
FOR TWO ONE AND THAT MEASURE
PASSES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. WE'LL GET READY FOR
ITEM NUMBER TWO I AT S. EIGHTY
SEVEN THIRTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN BUT BEFORE
WE DO THAT WE COULD TAKE UP THE
CONSENT. CALENDAR AND AGENDA
TODAY. WE HAVE A NUMBEROF
ITEMS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
I CAN- IN ONE ITEM HAS BEEN
REMOVED FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDA CONSENT AGENDA I WILL
READ THOSE ITEMS THAT ARE ON
THE CALENDAR TODAY. ITEM NUMBER
OF ALL ELECTRIC AB NINETEEN OH
SIX. AB NINETEEN FORTY FIVE AB
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AB. TWENTY ONE
OH ONE. AB TWENTY THREE ELEVEN
AB TWENTY THREE NINETY NINE. AB
TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY NINE IN AB
THIRTY FIFTY THREE A. B. TWENTY
TWO THIRTY FOUR HAS BEEN
REMOVED FROM THE CONSENT
AGENDA. IS THERE A MOTION ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. SO MOVE
FROM SENATOR JACKSON THANK YOU
OF WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL CONSULTANT ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. SENATOR HILL HI
SENATOR HILL HI SENATOR MORALE.
SENATOR MORALE- BY CENTER
MOREAU BY SENATOR JACKSON HI
SENATOR JACKSON HI SEN SENATOR
MITCHELL MITCHELL AYE CENTER
MIDDLE HI CENTER PAN HI CENTER
PAN BY. VERY GOOD THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS- ADOPTED FIVE ZERO.
GOOD AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY MEMBER-
AND WELCOME AND- PLEASE- BEGIN
PRESENTED AB SEVEN THIRTY SIX
HEY GOOD AFTERNOON THAT A
MISTER CHAIR AND SENATORS AB
SEVEN THIRTY SIX PROVIDES A
NARROW CLARIFICATION TO THE
LABOR CODE SO THAT PART TIME
ADJUNCT FACULTY AT NONPROFIT
INDEPENDENT COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES CAN CONTINUE TO BE
TREATED AS THE HIGHLY TRAINED
PROFESSIONALS THEY ARE.
SPONSORED BY A. I. CCQ AND SEIU
CALIFORNIA THE BILL SETS A
MINIMUM COMPENSATION FOR BASED
ON A FORMULA FOR TOTAL HOURS OF
SERVICE. NOT JUST CLASSROOM
TIME TO ACCOUNT FOR TIME SPENT
PREPARING LESSONS GRADING AND
RESPONDING TO STUDENTS. I'M
PROUD TO SAY THIS BILL REFLECTS
MONTHS OF COLLABORATION AND
COMPROMISE THAT HONORS BOTH THE
INTERESTS OF THE SCHOOLS AND
FACULTY MEMBERS AS WELL AS THE
STUDENTS THEY SERVE. THIS BILL
WILL ENSURE THAT ACTION FACULTY
MEMBERS ENJOY FLEXIBILITY AND
INDEPENDENCE WHILE BENEFITING
STUDENTS WITH THEIR
PROFESSIONAL EXPERIENCE. GIVEN
THE TRANSITION TO ONLINE
LEARNING TO COPE AT NINETEEN
THIS BILL WILL HELP ENSURE THAT
STUDENTS CAN CONTINUE THEIR
EDUCATION DURING THESE CALL
CHALLENGING TIMES. WITH ME
TODAY ARE ALEX GRAVES ON BEHALF
OF A ICC YOU AND MATT. THE J.
ON BEHALF OF S. CI CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU AND YOUR WITNESSES
WILL HAVE A TOTAL FOR A MINUTE.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT TO
ON THE LINE. FOUR EIGHTY SEVEN
THIRTY SIX. THIS IS. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS ALEX RATED
THE ICC YOU CAN YOU HEAR ME OK
WE HEAR YOU FINE THANK YOU
MISTER GRAVES OKAY GREAT GREAT
A GOOD AFTERNOON SURE MEMBERS
AT ALEX FRASER CEO REPRESENTING
EIGHTY FIVE INDEPENDENT
NONPROFIT COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES IN THE STATE-
WE'RE PROUD TO CO SPONSOR FOR
THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE WITH
THAT YEAH YOU. WHICH ADDRESSES
SHORTCOMINGS HISTOLOGIC
CITIZENS ABILITY. THEY ARE. THE
STORE. WE HAVE BEEN A PART IN
THIS OF WORK LIKE TO AS HE THEY
CONTROLLED OWN WORK ON SKY
INCLUDING TIME GRADING AND
OFFICE OUR THERE TO AS PER AND
NOT SUBJECT TO THE SAME
POLICIES FOR HOURLY EMPLOYEES
SUCH AS TIME TRACKING- MEAL AND
REST BREAKS. HOWEVER THE
EXISTING LAW DOES NOT ALLOW
ADJUNCT FACULTY BE TREATED THIS
EXAM PROFESSIONALS THAT THEY
ARE NOT PAID A SALARY
EQUIVALENT TWICE MINIMUM WAGE
FOR FULL TIME EMPLOYMENT- SO
IT'S A PART TIME STAFF MEMBER
IS PAID A MINIMUM AMOUNT PER
COURSE IT OUTLINED IN THIS BILL.
CREATE AN EXAM PROFESSIONAL.
THAT WE IS OUR INTER. ONE TO
TREAT THEIR- FACULTY TO BE
TREATED AND THE ANALYSIS OF
THIS BILL NOTE. THAT A SIMILAR
DEAL WITH VETOED LAST YEAR BY
THE GOVERNOR- WE WORKED
EXTENSIVE WITH STAFF AND LABOR
AGENCY ON THIS LANGUAGE. TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS EXPRESSED-
PREVIOUSLY AND BELIEVE THE BILL
BEFORE YOU ADDRESSES THOSE
CONCERNS BY. UNIVERSE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR QUESTION RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT VERY GOOD
THANK YOU. THE NEXT WITNESS IN
SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON SHARE
MEMBERS GOT WAS A ON BEHALF OF
THE SEVENTY THOUSAND MEMBERS OF
SK YOU CALIFORNIA NCLUDING
OVER TWO. THOUSAND ADJUNCT
FACULTY. AND WE ARE THE CO
SPONSORS AT EIGHTY SEVEN THIRTY
SIX WE LIKE TO THINK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IRWIN INTERPOSE SPONSOR
A ICC YOU FOR WORKING
COLLABORATION TO MOVE THIS
IMPORTANT BILL FORD AND I'LL
KEEP A RELATIVELY BRIEF BUT I
JUST WANT TO POINT OUT IN
ALIGNMENT COMMENTED COLLEAGUES.
EARLIER BUT ALSO TO POINT OUT
THAT. WILL RESULT IN A INCREASE
OF FROM 50% FOR OUR LOWEST PAID
OUT ON CRACKLE TEAM CALIFORNIA-
WHILE WE'RE ALSO ADDRESSING
SOME OF THE LAWSUITS THAT HAVE
BEEN DIVERTING RESOURCES AWAY
FROM SUPPORTING. STUDENTS ABOUT
RESEARCHSO FOR THESE REASONS I
SEE I IS HAPPY TO WORK IN
COLLABORATION. TELL ME APPS.
YEAH YEAH RPB. VERY GOOD THANK
VERY MUCH THE TEST THEM NOW
IT'S BIG WITH ANY. THAT ARE
HERE IN THE GALLERY ON A. B.
SEVEN THIRTY SIX ANY SUPPORTERS
IN THE GALLERY SCENE NO ONE
THERE IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
ROOM TWENTY FORTY WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF AB SEVEN
THIRTY SIX SEE NO ONE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPTLY INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF AB SEVEN
THIRTY SIX WHO WILL BEGIN.
SHARE I MIGHT EVEN END UP
BENEFIT FOR SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN
THIRTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN THEIR OWN NOW. AGAIN FOR
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO NOW. IF YOU ARE ALREADY IN
THE QUEUE FOR OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN THERE NOW
THOUGHT. AGAIN FOR SUPPORT
LONDON ZERO NOW. AND WE D HAVE
ONE IN THE KEEL LOCAL TO LINE
FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU. SANTILLANA JOHN
PROFESSOR AT SAINT MARY'S
COLLEGE MEMBER OF THIS SEE YOU
TEND ONE LEVERAGE COLLEGE
CHAPTER VICE PRESIDENT AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB SEVEN
THIRTY SIX THANK YOU. THANK
MAXILLA CAROLINE ONE FIFTY
THREE PER VEHICLE I HAD.
USUALLY MONTERO PHYSICAL
THERAPIST CLINICAL INSTRUCTOR
IN SUPPORT EIGHTY SEVEN FOR USE.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU. AND AS A
REMINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR
EIGHTY SEVEN THIRTY SIX PLEASE
ONE THEN THEIR OWN NOW AGAIN
FOR SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO NOW. AND WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE THANK YOU AT THE
MOMENT. THE USS ONE MORE TIME
TO CHECK THE LINE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE ELSE WILLING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. THIRTY SIX
PLEASE AND FOR SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY SEVEN THIRTY SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN THEY'RE ON
NOW AGAIN FOR SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE LINDERO NOW. GOOD. WE
HAD NO ONE IN Q. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SO HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
OF THE SUPPORTERS WE WILL NOW
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS AND
HEAR FROM ANY OPPOSITION- THERE
IS NO REGISTERED OPPOSITION
WILLING TO SPEAK UP INTERMENT
IN WITNESSES WITNESSING TODAY.
SO IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
GALLERY WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO AB SEVEN THIRTY
SIX SEE NO ONE IS THERE ANYONE
IN ROOM TWENTY FOUR. WISHING TO
SPEAK SHE NO ONE IN ROOM
TWENTY. SPEAKING OPPOSITION TO
THE SEVEN THIRTY SIX- THANK
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES.
WHICH WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
THE TELECONFERENCE ORBIS SO
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROP THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY. IN OPPOSITION TO AB
SEVEN THIRTY SIX WE WILL THEN
BEGIN. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
THANK YOU UP HOLD AB SEVEN
THIRTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
BEEN THERE- NOW. AGAIN FOR
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO NOW. AND WE HAVE NO
ONE THANK YOU AT THE MOMENT.
GOOD THANK YOU THAT A
MODERATOR- WE WOULD THEN THANK
YOU TO ALL OF THOSE IN SUPPORT
AND THOSE WHO. POTENTIALLY WERE
IN OPPOSITION TO THE WITNESSES
WILL NOW BRING THE DISCUSSION
BACK TO THE MEMBERS SINCE WE
HAVE NO ONE IN. OPPOSITION TO
THE UP TO THE BILL SO IT ANY
MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS MOVE THE BILL CENTER
PAN WE HAVE A MOTION VERY GOOD
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. HI I
JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND I DO WANT TO
COMMEND. A ICC YOU AND SEIU
CALIFORNIA THIS WAS ACTUALLY A
VERY DIFFICULT NEGOTIATION AND-
I THINK IT'S A WIN WIN FOR
EVERYBODY SO. YES YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHEN AND SO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON A. B. SEVEN THIRTY
SIX FROM- DOCTOR PAN AND THE
MOTION IS. TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS- THE CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE REPUBLIC.
MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS MEMBERS PLEASE
TURN ON YOUR MICROPHONE SIMILAR
TO VOTE SENATOR HILL HI SENATOR
HILL HI SENATOR MORALE. SENATOR
MORAL CENTER MOREAU HI SENATOR
JACKSON. HI SENATOR JACKSON HI
SENATOR MITCHELL. MITCHELL AYE
CENTER MITCHELL HI CENTER PAN.
SENATOR PAN HI THE BILL HAS
FIVE BOOKS AND IS A THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHEN.
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB TEN SIXTY SIX ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GONZALEZ I SEE YOU IN
THE BACK. AND WE WILL THEN TAKE
YOUR SECOND BILL. AFTER THAT
WILL THEN TAKE AB TWENTY TWO
FIFTY SEVEN AFTER. THE FIRST
BILL PLEASE PROCEED AT YOUR
CONVENIENCE. A. TEN TEN SIXTY
SIX. I CAN'T I CAN'T ANSWER
CAN'T HERE'S A MICROPHONE ON.
THANK YOU NOTING THAT I HAVE
FOR BILLS OR IF- IF YOU DO THEM
AND AS USUAL ALL. NOT
CONTROVERSIAL AND EASY TO GO.
WE'LL START WITH AB TEN SIXTY
SIX THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THE UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
PROGRAM HAS BEEN CRITICAL
LIFELINE FOR WORKING FAMILIES
ACROSS THE STATE EXPERIENCING
SEVERE ECONOMIC HARDSHIP DURING
POPE AT NINETEEN. PANDEMIC SO
MANY OF US HAVE A EXPERIENCE
THE PROBLEMS WITH EDT RECENTLY
AND I THINK OUR CONSTITUENTS-
HAVE HAVE MADE IT CLEAR. WHAT
THESE DELAYS HAVE DONE TO THEM
BUT WHAT WE HAVEN'T SEEN IS THE
BEHIND THE SCENES ISSUES THAT
SOMETIMES BECAUSE THOSE DELAYS
AND YES- EDT DOES HAVE YOU KNOW
A PROCESS AND ARE TRYING TO GET
THROUGH A LOT OF BACKLOG. BUT
IT'S MADE ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE
WHEN WE HAVE COMPANIES WHO
WON'T RESPOND TO THE REQUEST.
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS TWO FOLD
ONE. IT TAKES A LOT OF WHAT IS
ALREADY EXISTING- NPD'S
PAPERWORK INTHEIR ABILITY- TO
pPURSUE THINGS AND CODIFIES IT
BASICALLY IT TAKES THINGS THAT
YOU FIND ON FORMS REQUIRED THAT
THE BUSINESSES RESEARCH INTO A-
TO THE UNEMPLOYMENT FOR TEN
DAYS AND KIND OF. A LAW THAT
WAY THE WORKER ISN'T LEFT ON
THE HOOK WHEN THE EMPLOYEE.
DOES RESEARCH. WE IS. I KNOW OF
SITUATION IN SOMEONE HERE ABOUT
WHERE BURKE. HAVE WAITING FOR.
A REASON TIME WHICH HAS BEEN
THREE MONTHS BECAUSE AN
EMPLOYER REFUSES TO HAND OVER
WAGE INFORMATION ON THAT WORKER
SO THIS JUST STRENGTHENS EDIE'S
POSITION AND REQUIRING
EMPLOYERS TO DO THAT WE ARE
TAKING SOME AMENDMENTS THAT
WOULD BE REALLY CLEAR WE TOOK
SERIOUSLY- THE CHAMBERS
OPPOSITION BECAUSE- WE FELT
LIKE. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TWO
DIFFERENT TYPES OF EMPLOYERS
HERE WE'RE WE'RE NOT REALLY
TALKING ABOUT THE EMPLOYERS FOR
REGISTERING THEIR EMPLOYEES AB
ET DE INTER FOLLOWING BASICALLY
THE LAWS AND MIGHT MISS A FORM
AND TIME. UNDER THOSE
CIRCUMSTANCES WE'RE TAKING.
AMENDMENTS TO CLARIFY THAT THE
EMPLOYERS CAN RECEIVE AN
EXTENSION FOR GOOD REASON IF
THEY MISS THE TEN DAY-
VERIFICATION LETTER OR THEY
CAN'T PROVIDED TEN DAYS THAT
THEY COULDN'T GET TO THE MAIL
OR SOMETHING. LIKE THAT
HAPPENED- WERE ALSO CLEAR FIND
THE GOOD BECAUSE EXTENSION.
STILL FLIES IT IT APPLIES AND
THEY CAN APPEAL THAT SO THE
PEEL PROCESS IS STILL IN THERE
STILL A THIRTY DAY APPEAL
PROCESS. WE ARE GOING TO
COMPLETELY TAKE OUT OF THE
BILL- IF THEY SHOULD MOVE
FORWARD THE PORTION ABOUT IF
THIS HAPPENS MORE THAN FIVE
EMPLOYEES WHAT WE WERE TRYING
TO DO IS WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE
SOME EMPLOYERS AGREE JUSTLY
DOING THIS FOR EVERY SINGLE
EMPLOYEE. PRIMARILY OVER LEFT
THEY'RE JUST NOT RESPONDING AND
WE WERE TRYING TO STREAMLINE IT
FOR THE EMPLOYEES WHO ARE
DESPERATELY WAITING ON THAT
CHECK. BUT WE UNDERSTAND THAT
BUT CONFUSING AND WE ACTUALLY
AGREE WITH THE CHAMBER AND IT'S
BEST TO JUST TAKE THAT PIECE
OUT. SO EVERY SINGLE CLAIM IT
WOULD STILL HAVE. THE TEN DAY
PROCESS BY WHICH THE EMPLOYER
WHAT WOULD HAVE TO RESPOND.
WHAT WHAT THIS SAYS IS WHEN THE
EMPLOYER RESPONDS. WHAT DOES
NOT RESPOND THAT ALLOWS THE EDG
WORKER. TO ASSUME WHAT THE
WORKERS TELLING THEM THAT THE
EMPLOYEE IS TELLING THEM. THEIR
TEN NINETY NINE FORMS ARE BANK
STATEMENTS ALL THAT INFORMATION
THAT THEY GAVE IS ACCURATE AS
FAR AS WHAT THEIR WAGE WISE SO
THAT THEY CAN GET UP TO THE
MAXIMUM BENEFIT WHAT WE'VE SEEN
IS A NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO EDT
WENT THROUGH THE PROCESS
CLEARLY THESE INPUT WORKERS
EMPLOYEES. THERE AND THEY ARE-
THEY DESERVE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE BUT THEY'RE GETTING
CLAIMS OF ZERO DOLLARS BECAUSE
THEY CANNOT GET INFORMATION
FROM THE COMPANIES SO THIS JUST
SAYS IT COMPANIES IF YOU DON'T
PARTICIPATE THE ET DE R.
ARTICLES FORWARD AND WE HAD WE
ASSUME THROUGH THE WORK WITH
THE EMPLOYEE WHAT THEIR WAGES
ARE SO THAT THEY CAN ACTUALLY
GET A CHECK. NOW THIS. ACTUALLY
EXISTING LAW. I MEAN EDT HAVE
THE FLEXIBILITY TO DO THIS IT
IT EXISTS IN THEIR PRACTICE BUT
WE'RE GONNA CODIFY INTO LAW.
THE OTHER HALF OF THE BILL IS
SIMPLY TO ALLOW. BIT EDT AND
THE EIGHT EIGHT G. NOT JUST
EIGHTY THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TO
GO AFTER COMPANIES. WITH FIVE
HUNDRED OR MORE EMPLOYEES WHO
DID NOT PAY INTO UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE. WHAT WE KNOW IS WE
HAVE HAD TO TAKE OUT A LOAN
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
BECAUSE OUR FUND IS BROKEN. AND
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WHEN
WE HAVE TO PAY BACK THAT FUND
BUT THAT'S NOT PUT ON SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT HAVE ACTUALLY
BEEN ABIDING BY THE LAW PEEN
INTO YOU WHY THIS ENTIRE TIME
WELL HUGE CORPORATIONS WHO HAVE
REFUSED TO PAY N. ARE PAYING
THEIR FAIR SHARE. AND WE WANT
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TO BE ABLE
TO GO AFTER THOSE CORPORATIONS-
WITH HOPEFULLY THOSE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS I HOPE WE CAN MOVE
THIS BILL FORWARD. I KNOW THAT
IT'S- HOW TO CONFUSING LIKE
EVERYTHING WITH EDT- BUT WE A-
WE DID TRY TO USE THE ACTUAL
BURBAGE. AND THE EXPECTATIONS
ALREADY LAID OUT IN EDIE'S
PROCESS TO JUST CODIFY IT CAN
MAKE IT MORE FRIENDLY TO THE
WORKERS NOT GETTING THEIR X.
GOOD OF WITNESSES. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE PRESENTATION
AND WE DO HAVE ONE LEAD
WITNESS- IS IT ANGEL. CAñADA
MOBILE WORKERS ALLIANCE- YOU
WOULD HAVE FOR A TOTAL OF EIGHT
MINUTES. TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
ARE YOU ON YOUR HEARING. I HEAR
YOU YES THANK YOU HELLO YES
OKAY YEAH. WHEN ASSEMBLY YOU
NUMBERS ON HAS BEEN A LONG. THE
ON THE C. THOUGH BUT OUR
LEADERS- IMPORTANT METAL DOES
THEY'LL SURPRISE NINE YOU'LL
SEE MENU. ESOP WILL NOT MEMBERS
BUT WE ALSO THEIR MOBILE WATER
TO FLY AND GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS I'M HERE IN ATLANTA AND
I HAVE BEEN DRIVING FOR LIFT
FOR CRYING FOR THREE AND A HALF
YEARS. AND I'M A PROUD MEMBER
OF THE MOBILE WORKERS ALLIANCE.
ALTHOUGH THERE ARE BROADBAND A
KOBE YES ELEVEN. MIDDLEMAN
THURMOND AND HOW- PROMOTE I'M
INVESTING ONE TOLD US FOR
SAMANA YEAR OF BODY ARE NOT A
REGULAR LOW TO NOTICE YOU
IMPOSE ON THURSDAY OWN CLOUT OF
LOTUS. EMBEDDABLE ACCUSER THERE.
ARE MULTIPLE. THIS BOY IS A
WELL I'M NOT A- THE BILL NO
THERE'S SAFE OLDEST SOLO ME UP
WITH ANOTHER MAN BECAUSE YOU
WENT ALONG. PRIOR TO THAT OF
COLD AND I TOOK DROVE ABOUT
FIFTY PER. AND I CAN MAKE ABOUT
NINE HUNDRED BEFORE FACTORING
IN EXPENSES. ON MARCH FIFTEENTH
HOWEVER AFTER WORKING A SIX
HOUR SHIFT. I ONLY MADE FIFTY
DOLLARS. FOUNDER LOS- SALARIES
HILLS VATICAN BUT APPEALS.
SICKENING TO READ ON THERE'S
AND SALAS THE BORDER LAWS
ORDINANCE NO PROBLEM IS THE
ABUNDANCE DIMASA. WOODROW IN A
LETTER. HE IS A LITTLE OVERCOME
A LOT OF THEM ARE THAT MONDAY
YEAH HERE. THE BEST OF THIS UP
ON THIS YEAR ON DEMAND IT IS
SEEING. SERVICE IN THEIR- A LOT
OF BUT ON ABOUT A QUARTER. ARE
STILL NECESSARY. BUT I THOUGHT
AND I GOT A. IS THE FIRST
TRANSLATOR THERE PLEASE IT IS
JUST. EXISTS GARCIA. THE
RESOLUTION GREATER AND LOOKS
LIKE HIM LINE HAS DROPPED-
IT'LL BE JUST A MOMENT TO SEE
IF HE CALLED BACK AGAIN THANK
YOU. I DO NOT SHOW UP LINE
REJOINING AT THIS TIME. IF YOU
WANT I CAN TAKE JUST A MOMENT
AND TRY TO CALL BACK A LOT TO
HIM WHAT WE COULD DO WE HAVE
HIM BACK ON THE LINE THANK YOU.
R. YES I'M BACK PART. I'M
FEELING A LITTLE. DE NOT
ALLOWED FICTIONPRESS. OKAY ALL
RIGHT- ALTHOUGH REYES SHARES
RIGHT SURE SERVICES ARE DEEMED
ESSENTIAL BY THE LOCAL AND
STATE PAPER AT HOME AND PUBLIC
HEALTH ORDERS. THE DEMAND FOR
RIDE BACK AND I WAS LEFT
WITHOUT ENOUGH WORK TO EVEN
COVER THE GAS NEEDED TO KEEP ME
ON THE ROAD. MANY OTHER THERE
REALLY- SEVERE GETTING. THE
ONLY GOAL BUT BILLION DOLLARS
FLINT SOLICITADO. CIRCLED BIT
ASSEMBLY ALL. ASIDE DAY A POOR
PART MUSA INDIVIDUALS. THE
DALLAS THE RESTAURANT. ANY
LISTED BELOW A CV ORACLE OR NOT
BECAUSE HE ON THEIR BENEFICIOS
AND THERE THIS AND BAIL AND
MOST OKAY. A. B. INBEV SO
BILLION. THERE ARE THE SEATTLE
WE CAN NO LONGER BODY I YOU
CANNOT YOU ON OUT OR OF THE
WOMB YOU. EIGHT I EAT KNEW THAT
MY- OPTION WAS TO FILE FOR ON
INSURANCE. DESPITE ENTERING MY
QUARTERLY EARNINGS ON MY
APPLICATION. RECEIVED A NOTICE
OF UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE OR
WAR. EDT IN THE MAIL THAT SHOW
THAT MY INCOME FROM LATE ONE
ZERO AND THAT ALLEN WASN'T
GOING TO BE AWARDED ANY
BENEFITS. WELL IF YOU'RE
LIMITED BECAUSE HE WON THE
SOLICITOR TODAY. OR NOT
INVESTIGAR SI WONDERFUL LOS
HANG IN. THERE AS A LITTLE BIT.
ASSEMBLY ALL- WITH SANDEL YOU
ARE. YOU ONLINE. HE TOLD ME
I'LL INDIA HELLO. INFORMANTS ON
BED SO IT LOOKS E. L. ET AND
THEN GUNMEN. STOLE ACERCA DE R.
THE SIMPLE. AFTER RECEIVING THE
NO I REQUEST A WAGE. INTO YOU
I. ONLINE PORTAL AND SUBMITTED
MY WAGE INFORMATION AGAIN I
NEVER HEARD BACK FROM EDB ABOUT
MY YOU I CLEAN. BLACKLISTED
BECAUSE YOU ON THEIR OWN YOU
KNOW THEY ME AND OTHER POLICY
ISSUES- AND BELLOWS. THERE'S
NOBODY ON THE- THIS CALL WRONG.
AT HIM BECAUSE- THEN DEADLINE
YOU OKAY GO SOCK US OUR CONTACT.
VETO CARE IF SAN. ALSO MEANT
LOS EXTEND SPOT ON BUT IF YOU
GOT MOMMY IN GASOL YES SIR
SZYMON- THE PROCESS AND NOT
ENOUGH OF SEEING OR NOT. OUT
FOR MONTHS. THERE AMONG THEM IN
THE MONTHS THERE ARE MEAN FOR
ME. MY EMPLOYERS MISS CLASS. OF
ITS EMPLOYEES IT THE CAR. AND
THIS IS ANOTHER. OF THE HARM IT
INFLICTS ON ITS DRIVERS BECAUSE
LEFT REFUSED TO SUBMIT RECORDS
VERIFY MY INCOME I SPENT A WEEK
WENT OUT A WAY TO SUPPORT MY
FAMILY. WE'LL. ZERO ZERO ZERO
ZERO MAYBE ONLY GOGGLE
COMPLIMENTS SUDDEN OAKLAND I'M
GOING TO SEE IT- NO AMENDED
AGAIN IN A SUNDAY THE DISORDER-
AND THEY'RE O'CLOCK. AND DINNER
LOCAL SIMPLE NO FRIEND THAT YEP
US GIVE LANDELL WHEN I MUST GOT
ON. WHAT ON VIA. I'M NOT
INTENDED ALLOTMENT OF MODELS.
INDIA IN LATE MAY DUE TO MY
FINANCIAL SITUATION. I WAS
FORCED TO START DRIVING. AGAIN
I PAID FOR AND INSTALLED A
PLEXIGLAS DIVIDER BETWEEN THE
FRONT IN TH BACKSEAT WORE A
MASK ALL DAY AND TRY TO WASH MY
HANDS FREQUENTLY. MELENDEZ ON
ALL NO MATTER WHAT YOUR BILL
AND ALLOW. IT WAS GOING TO
SINGLE WHO KNEW ALL LITERACY V.
ALSO TO BE ABLE. VOCAL THIS
QUESTION ME ON YET VERY INSTANT
MESSAGE. ISRAEL THEY WAS
SOMETHING NOT ANNUAL IN ME AS
QUALIFY ME HUH I'M BE IMPORTANT
FOR THE PEOPLE. SHE ULTIMATELY
THAT IT DIDN'T PROTECT ME FROM
CATCHING THE VIRUS. ON JULY
TWENTY FOUR I RECEIVED POSITIVE
RESULTS SHORTLY AFTER MY
FIFTEEN MONTH OLD
GRANDDAUGHTER. MY EIGHTY NINE
YEAR OLD MOTHER IN LAW AND MY
Y. ALL TESTED POSITIVE AS WELL.
BILL NOTICIA- A LITTLE BIT-
ASSEMBLY ALL WAS ALL AND NOT. I
WELL SO I MEAN FOR MEDIA
ANDREAS IT'LL- ANY L. SERVE
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT BILL THIS
WILL NOT. TO SPEND OKAY THOSE
LAWS ABOUT HOW THE ORDER
MEDICINE MOST BE LADEN YOU KNOW
WHEN YOU GO OUT. BY PHONE OR
LIVE. ELISABET ON THE BOAT AS-
BABY OUT OWN BUT APPEALS NOT
WAITING OCCUR IT- BLANKET LAW.
ORDER ISSUES AND THEY'RE A
LITTLE ONLY GOTTEN BETTER
SINGLE S. OKAY NORRIS THROWS
EMPLOYERS WANT. TO KNOW ON YOUR
LAND ONLY. NOT RECEIVING AN AND
INSURANCE THAT MY FAMILY OUT
REST. UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE IS
A LIFELINE FOR ALL WORKERS.
DESERVE AND THE ONLY REASON
THOUSANDS OF RIDE SHARE DRIVERS
CANNOT ACCESS IT DURING HE
SAME TREES AND WIRES AND THEN
WORST PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS. IS
BECAUSE OUR EMPLOYERS CONTINUE
TO BREAK THE LAW. A LOT OF
ALIASES AND PAYSAFE HE LOOKED
ON THE ALSO THE CARE. SO LONG A
CRITICAL FATAH PROPORCIONAN.
HELLO STILL HAD LOTUS OFFICIAL
HELLO GREG WATER SOURCE QUE
NECESITA UN BUT ON MONDAY AND
THEN ALSO THE FAMILIAR PEOPLE
MONNING OTHERS SAY WATER.
BORDER IS TELEPHONE LIST LITTLE
HOLE FOR THE DOMINICAN STATUS
THE CARE ACCORDING LAW OF IT IN
THE ASSEMBLY SADIE'S. CATHOLIC
WHICH HONEST AUDIO ONE OF THE-
AB TEN SIXTY SIX AND THE
CHANGES IT WILL MAKE ARE
CRITICAL TO PROVIDE WORKERS
ACTED WITH THE RESOURCES THEY
NEED TO KEEP THEIR FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITY SAFE. THESE REASON I
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO SUPPORT AB
SIXTY SIX. THANK YOU VERY GOOD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I DID
EXTEND THE TIME TO ALLOW FOR
THE TRANSLATION- AND APPRECIATE
THE TESTIMONY TODAY. WELL ON
THAT- THAT THE ISSUE WE WILL
NOW GO TO THOSE IN SUPPORT IN
THE CHAMBERS. I SEE NO ONE IN
SUPPORT OF- AB TEN SIXTY SIX IN
THE CHAMBERS IS THERE ANYONE IN
TEN FORTY WHO TWENTY FORTY WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY. IN
SUPPORT OF AB TEN SIXTY SIX YOU
WOULD SEE NO ONE THERE- NOW
LET'S MOVE TO- THOSE WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB TEN
SIXTY SIX WE WILL THEN BEGIN.
SHARE AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SHOW SUPPORT OF
AB TEN SIXTY SIX. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO NOW. AGAIN WHAT
WERE SUPPORT OF AB TEN SIXTY
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO NOW. IF YOU HAVE JOIN THE
QUEUE BEFORE NOW IN YOUR IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN THERE'LL TO REMOVE
YOURSELF. AGAIN THIS IS FOR
SUPPORT OF AB. TEN SIXTY SIX.
WELL FIRST LINE CHIU FORTY ONE
PEOPLE HAD. NO WAY OUT BOTTOM
ALL REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THE ONE THAT CALLED TO
MIND Q. FIFTY FOUR PLEASE CALL
I HAD. FOR NAY BAYARDO WITH
SARU CAL IN PART THANK YOU. AND
WILL NOT GO TIMELINE TWO THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. STATER
BROS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION IN PORT THANK YOU.
MAXALT CAROLINE. TWO TWENTY.
GEORGE WARNER ILLEGALLY THAT
WORK ON THEM SUPPORT HELLO MY
NAME. OKAY LOOK AT. THE LITTLE
GOLDLINE Q. THIRTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MATTHEW TO CARLESS FROM THAT
STATIC LEGAL SERVICES IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT LEVEL
CAROLINE ONE EIGHTY ONE FOR YOU
WELL I HAD. ONE EIGHTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN YOU MAY BE NEEDED
ON YOUR END. AND AGAIN TO SHOW
SUPPORT OF AB TEN SIXTY SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN THEY'RE
ON NOW AGAIN LONDON ZERO FOUR
SUPPORT. AND WE'LL LOOK BACK TO
LINE AT ONE EIGHTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NO I APOLOGIZE IT'LL
BE JUST A MOMENT BUT AS A
REMINDER AGAIN FOR SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THAN THEIR OWN
NOW. I WILL GO BACK TO LINE ONE
AB ONE VEHICLE I HAD. DISCOURSE
PETERSON- CARE FOR UNIVERSITY
CENTER FOR INTEGRATED
FACILITIES ENGINEERING AND I AM
THE PORT. THAT WAS THE WAR
STORY I'VE EVER HEARD THANK YOU.
CAN WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
QUEUE AT THE MOMENT GOOD THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO- WE'VE HEARD FROM THOSE IN
SUPPORT WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
THOSE IN OPPOSITION I BELIEVE
THERE IS ONE LEAD. OPPOSITION
WITNESS ROBERT RIVAS THE
CHAMBER OF COUNTY CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE ARE YOU ON THE LINE.
YES I AM HERE TO HELP THANK YOU
AGAIN AND I PROMISE I HOPE TO
NOT BE ACTED ON THE NEXT BILL
SO THAT EVERYONE ELSE WILL GET
WILL GET A CRACK. WE GET
THROUGH. AND HE SAID ROBERT YOU
TALK WHEN YOUR COVERAGE OPPOSED
AB TEN FIFTY SIX BECAUSE AS YOU
READ THIS BILL WE COULD NOT HE
IS RESOLVING IT DIDN'T WORKING
TO MAKE GREAT BECAUSE PROBLEMS
UNDERCOVER NINE. ABSOLUTELY
YOUR COMMENT THE- RATHER THAN
MAIL BE EASY BECAUSE OCEAN OFF
OF COMMENT THAT THE SHARE SOME
CONCERNS HERE AND LET ME
RESPOND IN KIND BY THING I
AGREE WITH THE AUTHOR- THAT.
YOU THE EIGHT ON EACH SIDE AND
GETTING OUT OUR PROBLEM AND-
REALLY UNACCEPTABLE I WENT ON
CALIFORNIA'S- POPULATION
NEEDED. I'M AND I ALSO THINK
THAT. I WILL AGREE THAT WE ALL
WISH WE HADN'T. YET THE
INTERNAL WORKINGS AB BECAUSE.
INFORMATION ON THE- DISTINCT
BECAUSE OF DELAYS AND EASY
RESPONDING TO ENQUIRIES AND HE
HAD TO TAKE BREAKING DOWN. YOU
KNOW WHAT CAUSED THE DELAY I
WISH WE COULD GET THAT
INFORMATION- BUT- YEAH TO THAT
POINT ASIAN CLARIFY THAT I'M
NOT AWARE OF ANY DATA SHOWING
THAT DEEP AND SPECIAL AND I
THINK THAT'LL DELAYS ARE CAUSED
BY EMPLOYEE. THANK YOU POINTS
FOR I SAW WITH A NUMBER OF
FORMER EASY OFFICIAL INTO THE
CALL THAT THEY CAN GET PRINT.
I'LL TRY TO CLARIFY COOLEY THE
ISSUE TO GO FORWARD HOPEFULLY
TO ADDRESS. LET ME UP EXTEND MY-
SYMPATHIES TO THE- FAMILY AND
SELF I DIDN'T HEAR COMMENTS
ANYWAY. ANYONE NOT MAKING IT
HOPEFUL I HOPE THAT EVERY
WINTER KIND REALLY AND- AT
TERRIBLE. SO MY THOUGHTS AND
PRAYERS GO TO- ON THE ADULT
TRADE IS ALWAYS. HAVE TO BOOK I
DON'T LIKE I DON'T I'M
HOPEFULLY BECAUSE- WERE LOOKING
A LOT OR ANYONE COULD NOT
CATEGORY BE ABLE TO STORAGE.
MATHIS THEN. STATION SO THAT IS
NOT CORRECT. OKAY THANKS AFTER
NOW ON THREE ISSUES FIRST THE
TEN DEADLINE SO I'D LIKE TO TRY
TO CLARIFY WHY POINT WE IS
PRESENTLY THIS. AT THE TOPIC
I'M ET READ TIME. AFTER WHICH
THEY IGNORE THE AUTHOR THANK
YOU IN A PLACE LOCKERS. AND IN.
PRESUME YEAH. YEAH YOU KNOW
THAT THAT'S LITTLE BIT. HOWEVER
THIS BILL NOT AS WE READ IT
DOES NOT SIMPLY BECAUSE WILL
EXIST FRIENDLY EASY USE OUR OF
HIGH DEPENDING ON THE. ATION
SOME OF THE TEN DAYS OF THOSE
ARE. THIRTY DAY DEADLINE. SO
OUR CONCERN AND TO BE CLEAR
THOSE DEADLINE ARE NOT. ON THE
BY. THANK YOU CAN IN EACH
RECTOR. THAT WOULD ADMITTEDLY
HARD FIND BUT THEY ARE DIDN'T.
SO WE HAVE BEEN ABOUT
SHORTENING. PRESENTLY A RANGE
OF TIMELINE DEPENDING ON THE
COMPLEXITY OF THE REQUESTED
INFORMATION. AND HAD LINE IS
THAT YOU. AND THAT PARTICULARLY.
THE BILL OF TEN YEARS THAT
YOU'RE PRIOR I SPOKE TO A
NUMBER EMPLOYERS TOLD ME THAT
EVEN YEARS THEY RECEIVED
LETTERS REQUESTING DOCUMENTS
FOR ADD WITH THE TEN DAY
TIMELINE ANY SITUATIONAND THAT
WAS THE LETTER LIKE THAT. FIVE
OR SEVEN FOUR AN AFFIDAVIT
POSSIBLE TO ME BUT WHAT ABOUT A
TEN. TIMELINE READ. THAT WAS
PRIOR AND AN- OBVIOUS. BUT WE
CAN ALL AGREE IT YEAR WITH CALL
IN NINETEEN. MANY WORKPLACE
THAT OFFER THAT ARE NOT
FUNCTION. WHERE THEY ARE.
PERSEVERE UNDERSTAFFED IN
RESPONSE MAYBE OR AND THAT
COMPOUND ARE CONCERNED OVER
SPENDING ALL TIME LOW. PAID
STATUTES UNDER. THIS BILL I'D
LIKE TO. ALL THE NAY WONDER
WHICH IS REGARDING THE NET THAT
TO USE THAT FISH TO MAKE THAT
THE LATE MONTHS OCUR. I YOU TO
EMPATHIZE THAT AGAIN EMPLOY.
BUT YOU NEED TO THE ALREADY.
CAN AT ONE IT REACHES EACH
REGULATORY THAT DOES IGNORE
EMPLOYERS. THEY WERE GONNA
ALLOCATE NEXT BENEFIT. ALL
RIGHT COMMITTEE SHOULD IN THE
NEED THE THAT CREDIT. LEFT IT
BACK FOR THE SITUATION THE BILL
TO ACCOMPLISH THAT I SHOULD
PAY. DOESN'T SEEM ACCURATE
UNDER THE REGULATION- FROM OUR
REACH. TALK ABOUT A. EXCEPTION
OF LIKE THAT THAT APPRECIATE
THAT DISCUSSIONS I HAVEN'T SEEN
AS A MEMBER I CAN'T IN DETAIL
BUT I DO THINK THAT THAT KIND
OF BEG THE QUESTION IF THE TEN
DAY DEADLINE IS GONNA BE A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL SOLUTION TO A
MULTIPLICITY OF POTENTIAL
REQUEST. AND WE'RE GOING TO FIX
DIFFICULT IMPLYING THEY APPLY
YEAH. YEAH YEAH. I'M SORRY HOPE
THAT FEEDBACK IS OVER NOW. IF
THAT IF THAT ONE TECHNICAL
STANDARDS CAN BE DIFFICULT TO
COMPLY WITH- BECAUSE IT'S
CHANGING A MULTIPLICITY OF THE
SENATE ONE. FINANCIALLY IT
BECAUSE THE QUESTION ISN'T THE
RIGHT SOLUTION MORE INSTEAD
SPEAKING WITH A RANGE OF
DEADLINE PRESENTLY IN PLACE.
MIGHT AVOID THE NEED TO
REPEATEDLY UTILIZED THAT THE
CONNECTION WHICH- YOU HAVE
GIVEN HERE TODAY BEING
OVERWHELMED THEY ARE AND
BUSINESSES MANY OF NOT
FUNCTIONING OR STRUGGLING TO
CONTINUE TO FUNCTION. YOU KNOW
THE RESOURCES ON BOTH SIDES TO.
THIS A GOOD THING SESSION WITH.
AT THEY GET IN ADDITION. IF I
COULD BRIEFLY ON THE MEDICAL
ISSUE EGGMAN WE HAVE A
DIFFERENT READING BUT WE DON'T
DO THAT DELIVERS ALL THE
APPLICATION OR COMPUTER ISSUES
THAT ARE EIGHTY FIVE. ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT PRESERVING TIME
TO WORK THROUGH THOSE ISSUES IN
THE NORMAL APPEALS PROCESS AND
I GET HERE HOWEVER IN DOLLARS-
THAT IN THEIR EDUCATE BILL DID
NOT CUT SHORT THE APPEAL
DEADLINE WE WILL. NOT THAT
ACTUALLY WOULD CUT SHORT THE
APPEAL THAT REQUIRED TO TALK.
YOU KNOW TO TRY TO. BUT ON.
TRUE MIDDLE CLASS ISSUES WHICH
WE IS IMPORTANT RIGHT WITH IT
EIGHTY FIVE CHANGING LANDSCAPE
HELP WE WANT TO PRESERVE THAT
TIME TO WORK THROUGH IT I
APPRECIATE THE- HELLO COMMENT
REGARDING REMOVING THAT KIND OF
ONE FOR ALL PUNISHMENT
PROVISIONS. THAT HELPFUL.
EARNED OUT OF THE BAG IF I
APPRECIATE THAT CONCERN WAS
HEARD- LAST POINT AT TD ADDING
A TRAIN GENERAL IMPORTANT I'D
LIKE TO KNOW. HE DID HE ALREADY
HAD QUITE DRAWING HORSEMEN THEY
ALREADY LATE PROBABLY NOT YOUR
PROPERTY GARNISH YOUR WAGES AND
HAVE YOU QUITE GET. INTO
LAKEPORT DELAYEDPAYMENT SO
ONLY A SMALL POINT IN A LETTER
BUT I DO THINK THAT I THANK TO
US WHAT AGE ENFORCEMENT WILL
CHANGE GIVEN A PRESS. AND I
THINK FULL RANGE WELL ANY CAN
AND WE CAN YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. OCULUS REASONS
RESPECTFULLY A AB TEN FIFTY
SIX. BURGER THANK YOU FOR THE
TEST OF I WOULD NOW LOOK FOR IN
OPPOSITION TO. IT BE TEN SIXTY
SIX CALORIES. WHEN IN THE AREAS
ONE IN TWENTY FOUR. WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AB SIX
SIXTY NO ONE THERE WILL MOVE
NOW TO. WAITING TO TELL. VIA
THE PUBLIC. ORVIS OF MODERATE
IF YOU WOULD. THE INDIVIDUAL
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TEN SIXTY BUT.
I REQUEST YOU LADIES AND GENTS.
TO SHOP IN THE FOR AB TENSING
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
THE TIME. TRICKLED ALIGNED TWO
FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
TRUDIE HUGHES FOR THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE IF THE
PRODUCER. OF THE COMMENTS MADE
BY THE CALCHAMBER THANK YOUR-
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY APOLOGIES
MISTER CHAIR THIS IS SERRA
FLOCKS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TEN SIXTY
SIX I JUST MISSED THAT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. ONE TO THIRTY
TWO YOUR LONG RUN. WHAT IS HE-DOING IT CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION LIKE TO
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF THE
CHAMBER- IN. SAKE WELL POSITION
AND LOOK FORWARD TO THE
AMENDMENT SHOULD BE REVIEWING
THEM MATHIS THIS BILL MOVE
FORWARD THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SEVENTY LINE IS OPEN. PICTURE
NUMBER CAITLYN DATA ON BEHALF
OF THE TRANSPORT WORKERS UNION
OF AMERICA APOLOGY WE ALSO ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT EIGHT MILLION
THANK YOU. ONCE AGAIN TO SHOW
UP IN FOR A BI TEN SIXTY SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME PLAIN TO SIXTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TO TAKE
BETTER MOVE THEMSELVES TO SIXTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE OF ARNOLD AND
HE TOOK ON BEHALF OF BUT JAN
PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA COTTON GENERATING
RECORD THAT THE ASIAN
CALIFORNIA TRIP MUTUAL
AMERICANS TRUST YOUR VERY
CALIFORNIA FRESH FRUIT
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION.
THANK THANK YOU FORTY TWO YEAR
LOW ITSELF. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS CAME TO ME SHE
WITH TECHNOLOGY ALSO IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
JOHN CALDWELL FOR THE
CALIFORNIA HOTEL AND LODGING
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MICHAEL CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF WINE GRAPE GROWERS WE
GREATLY APPRECIATE INDICTMENTS
THAT WERE DISCUSSED- BUT WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NINE ONE NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE NINE ZERO
YOUR LINE OPEN. THE RESPONSIBLE
BONTA LINE TO ELEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS YOU FIREMAN
ALZHEIMER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS YOU SHOULD
ALSO IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NINE TO SIXTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS A POP I REMEMBER
DAD LENT A COULD NOT AFTER CAPE
COD AND- OF AB CAN TAKE EFFECT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SEVENTY
YEAR LINE IS. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS NOW FOR ON BEHALF OF
THE IN EIGHTY IN SUPPORT
APOLOGIZE FORGET IN THE RIGHT
THANK YOU. WE SHOULD. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN AS A REMINDER TO
UP TO SHOW UP FOR A BI SIXTY
SIXTY MAY PRESS THEN ZERO
ACTIVE TIME. I HAVE NO NO
SHOWING OPPOSITION- I APOLOGIZE
WE DO HAVE ONE MORE. LINE ONE
NINETY THANK YOU SIR WHEN I DO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION AND WE
ARE OPPOSED TO A BEACON SIXTY
SIX THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND
ONCE AGAIN TO SHOW UP IN
SEARCHES FOR AB TEN SIXTY SIX
YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I'VE KNOWN NOW
SHOWING OPPOSITION PLEASE
CONTINUE THANK YOU MODERATOR
APPRECIATE THE GREAT SERVICE
TODAY. THANK YOU TO ALL OUR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION WITNESSES
WHEN I BRING THE DISCUSSION
BACK TO OUR MEMBERS TO ANY
MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS YES. DR OKAY. I THANK
YOU AND THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I. FROM BEING THE FOR.
US WE NEED TO TRY TO GET OUR
WORKERS- THERE YOU AYE. I DID
WHAT DID JUST THAT. HE PERHAPS
BEST SOME OF THE OPPOSITION
POINT IT GETS ONE OF THINGS.
ASSANGE THAT THIS TAKES. A
DIFFERENT KIND OF BATTLE AND-
IT INTO ONE TENT ATE DEADLINE
IT. WAS THAT. AND I. TALKED
ABOUT. THERE'S A- WITHIN TEN
DAYS IF A BIT. AB CAN UP. I
GUESS THE ANSWER. THAT THEY ARE
THAT THE PLEASE OUR PRODUCER
WRECKED THAT THERE THAT THAT
PERSON IS ENTITLED TO BENEFITS
THERE'S A COMPRESSED CONCLUSIVE
PRESUMPTION AND OUT OF THE-
PREVIOUS. EITHER A LONGER LINE
TO PRODUCE RIGHT MISTER SHOW.
AGING SHIP. I HEAR THAT THE TOP
ANY ADMITTED MR CAN YOU PERHAPS
JUST ADDRESS THE- TIME PERIODS
THAT THEY REFERRED. MAYBE JUST
ALSO IF THERE'S A DISPUTE ABOUT
WHETHER SOMEONE IS AN EMPLOYEE
OR ARE NOT AND THEY DESERVE YOU
LIED IT IS ADEQUATE TIME. THAT
KIND OF EVIDENCE- KEEP. RIGHT
YEAH. I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
CHECKING HER MAIL THE WAY ALL
THE WAY OVER THERE NOW I GOT
THIS IS COMPLEX AND THE WE YEAH
I'M A LOT DIFFERENTLY THAN THE
CHAMBERS WERE WILLING TO. IN
THE BACK END MEN'S. BY WE'RE
NOT TALKING ABOUT THE THIRTY
DAY. WHAT WE'RE TALKING IS THIS
INITIAL FORM SO THIS INITIAL
PERFORMANCE CENTER IT SAYS
RIGHT THERE. BETTER TO RETURN
AT TEN THIRTY. RIGHT NOW TO FOR
EIGHTY IT'S- TIME. AN BECAUSE
OF WHAT ON REASONABLE TIME
BECOMES BACK BURN WE JUST
DIDN'T GET IT RIGHT SO. WHAT WE
WANT TO DO IS AFTER TEN DAYS OF
NOT SEEING THE WARM TO COLD I
THINK CONTINUE TO TEST THE
CLAIM. THEY HAVE TO. IF YOU.
RECEIVED A TEN NINETY. THE
WORKER SAYS I'M NOT PC IT
APPROPRIATELY THEY STILL HAVE
TO GO THROUGH THAT TO GAUGE AND
DETERMINE THAT HAS HAPPENED
WITH A LOT OF THE DRIVERS.
THIRD THIRD. I MEAN THE- EIGHTY
THOUSAND THREE. WHAT AT THAT
POINT. EDT STILL AS WE ON THIS
WAGE DATA AND SO THEY ARE.
THESE LETTERS AND WE HAVE
HUNDREDS OF THEM TO SHOW YOU.
HUNDREDS OF LETTERS THAT SAY
YOU GET A WAGE CLAIM OF ZERO
DOLLARS BECAUSE YOUR EMPLOYER
HAS NOT SUBMITTED THE FORMS
MMHM. WE WANT THEM TO SAY IS
OKAY. THIS DOESN'T HURT. THEIR
STATE LEADING ANTI. RIGHT BUT
LET'S GET THAT MONEY IN THE
HANDS OF THE WORKER NOW. THE
WORKER IS. THERE'S THEY'VE
GIVEN THEM THEY'RE BEING
STATEMENTS. ARE PATIENT HE WON.
IT WE'RE PRESUME THEN IT MOVE
FORWARD ON THIS BY THE WAY IF
SOMETHING UP WE IN THE PLAYERS
I JUST YOU KNOW I DIDN'T GET TO
THE SCENE THIS IS A NUMBER THEY
CAN EAT WE'RE GOING TO MAKE
SURE WE RIGHT AT THEIR- BECAUSE
THIS CAN GET AND- CAN. NO
IMPORT TO BE GIVEN. TO AB. AND
OVERPAID. BUT SOUTH THIS IS
STILL GOING THAT PROCESS
BUTTONS OF. WAITING THREE
MONTHS FOR MY- WHICH LITERALLY
I MEAN I. THE STORY OF A DRIVER
WHO GOT COBIT. THERE IS A
DRIVER IN MY- DIET WAITING
UNDER EIGHTY D. BECAUSE THEY
HAVE BACK TO WORK IN IN THE
CONTRACT TO COVER WORK. YOU
KNOW I THINK. BELIEVE HER CLAIM
AND FACT THAT. IT ME BECAUSE WE
SHOULD BE PROVIDE RIGHT NOW WAS
BUT WE SHOULD PREVIOUS. WORKERS
WITH THE MONEY THAT THEY
DESERVE AND IN DEALING WITH THE
EMPLOYER ONE WAY OR ANOTHER
LATER AND SO THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL AIMS TO DO WE CAN CONTINUE
TO CLEAR IT SO THAT THE CHAMBER
IS MORE PEOPLE BUT THE CLAIM
THAT THESE. WELL THAT'S STILL
T. THEY DIDN'T. INSURANCE AND
UNEMPLOYMENT WILL LAST LONG
THAN HE SO WHY ARE WE GO TOLD.
JUST FILE FOR THE FED BENEFITS
THAT'S GOING TO. BEFORE YOU THE
BENEFIT THAT YOU AT DESERVE SO
I JUST YOU KNOW I UNDERSTAND.
NO IN. IT HAS A GOOD RING FOR
IGNORING THESE IS GOING TO BE
HELD IN A POSITION IN EXPLAIN
THAT TO EIGHTY WHAT THE MEAN
TIME WE'RE GOING TO PUT
PEOPLE'S POCKETS NOT FOR
TECHNICAL WORKS THANK YOU
THAT'S A SEPARATE HELPFUL
EXPLANATION EARLY. FRIDAY THAT
SITS. IN BUT THAT ALSO I TO
THANK AS SOMEONE WHO IS ARE BIZ
OWNER WHO PAYS ARE ARE YOU. I
THE DO PAYROLL I GET THIS AT
ALL FIVE PAYROLL. I CERTAINLY
WANT. THE ARE OR ANY OF
BUSINESS TO SUBSIDIZE LARGE
BUSINESSES WHO ARE NOT RESPONSE
WHO ARE PAYING INTO THE U. AYE
FINDS AYE PREDATE THAT PART OF
THE BILL AS WELL. AND DOESN'T
YOU MUCH YEAH CERTAINLY. THE
BILL THE PROPERTY. THANK YOU
PREVENT YES. SENATE MITCHELL
THANK YOU THANK YOU JUST A
QUICK CLEAR FOR. MMHM ALL WHEN
I ASKED QUESTION YOU'LL WILL BE
SURPRISES COMING FOR ME SO THE
BILL INCREASES THE ENFORCEMENT
POWER OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
TO COLLECT RECOVER OUTSTANDING
YOU. EDUCATION DO YOU HAVE A
ROUGH HAVE ANY IDEA ON HOW MUCH
UNTIL DOLLARS COME. BE ABLE
RECOVER AND TRANSFERRED TO THE
UNEMPLOYMENT FUND. AS WE
BELIEVE IN THIS IS DONE BY AS
GIVES YOU D. SANTA CRUZ UC
BERKELEY STUDY YEAH IT'S A
BALLOT. AT FOR THE TO MAJOR
PLAYERS. I HAVE BEEN DOING THIS
AT THE- OUR- AND FOR THIS YEAR
MORE TIME BEFORE THE YEAR THAT
WAS LIKE BUT LOOKING BACK AT
THE LAST FOUR GOT IT IN IS
THERE A TIME LINE ON HOW FAR
BACK TO TREAT YOUR OLD WILL BE.
TO GO BACK. I'M YOU ASKED THAT
QUESTION I JUST ASKED THIS
QUESTION. A STATUE LIMITATIONS
BUT TRADITIONALLY IT'S A FOUR
YEAR LOOK BACK. FOR YOU FOR
YEARS THANK YOU THANK YOU
CENTERHOUSTON RITUAL OTHER CO
YES SENATOR JACKSON. YES I JUST
WANNA THANK YOU FOR TAKING THAT
AMENDMENT THAT I HAD REQUESTED
THAT I THOUGHT WAS WILL TO
BROAD. AGAIN THE GOAL IS TO GET.
COMPANIES TO COME. THE ONE THAT
WE HEARD TODAY I DON'T THINK
THE PUBLIC. HAS MUCH TOLERANCE
FOR THAT KIND OF A SITUATION
WHEN THEY WERE AWARE OF IT SO
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR TAKING
THE MOMENT IN FOR BRING THE
BILL. THANK YOU. VERY GOOD
THANK YOU. FOR THE COMMENTS AND
THE- ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ
THANK YOU FOR. FOR REALLY
BRINGING THIS- THIS BILL
FORWARD AFTER THE NINETEEN
FIFTY THREE STATUTE IT'S ABOUT
TIME IT'S- IT'S REVIEWED AND-
WE PROVIDE SOME. RECORDS FROM
THE EDT A FOR THE TV FROM- ARE
EMPLOYERS- AND I APPRECIATE YOU
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS THAT YOU
HAVE I THINK THAT REALLY NEAR.
THE BILL. BE THE BILL AND
CLARIFIED IT HELLO. I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT. THANK YOU
WATSON WITH PEACE OF THE BILL
TODAY. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THIS GAP OF NINE. THANK YOU BUT
WITH THE MOST. IN OF PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION TO
PASS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
MEMBERS PLEASE TURN ON YOUR
MICROPHONES IN ORDER TO VOTE
SENATOR HILL HI SENATOR HILL HI
DINNER MORALE. SENATOR MORRELL
NO SENATOR MOREAU NO SENATOR
JACKSON JACKSON. SENATOR
JACKSON HI SENATOR MITCHELL
MITCHELL LIVE CENTER MITCHELL
HI SENATOR PAN AND I CENTER PAN
HI. THE BILL HAS FOUR VOTES
BORDER ONE IT IS OUT THANK YOU
FOR THAT AND NOW IF WE COULD
MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN
WHICH IS AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU YOU MIGHT MY
FAVORITE WORK THIS YEAR HAS
BEEN TRYING TO ADD
CLARIFICATION AND- DO THE
FOLLOW UP WORK THAT WE PROMISED
AFTER AB FIVE WE HAD A NUMBER
OF BILLS WHEN WE STARTED
BECAUSE WE HOPE TO PUSH ONE
QUICKLY WE NOW HAVE JUST
COMBINED THEM ALL INTO THE
URGENT KERR'S THAT WE- GET IT.
SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR AND WE
CLEAR FIGHT AND- BETTER ABOUT
THEIR SITUATION. THIRTY E. AND-
AFTER JUST. DOES WHAT TWENTY
TWO FIFTY SEVEN DOES- TO AB
FIVE BASICALLY THE AMENDMENTS
THAT IT DOES IT THAT IS TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT. WE CLARIFIED- THE
BUSINESS TO BUSINESS THERE.
THERE WAS THIS BILL SOME THAT
TO BUSINESSES- COULDN'T CONTACT
WITH ONE ANOTHER AND SERVE EACH
OTHER'S CLIENTS. WE CLARIFIED
THAT IMPACT THE KIANA IS LONG
AS THE PEOPLE SERVING THE
CLIENTS ARE EMPLOYEES OF ONE OF
THOSE BUSINESSES WE DON'T WANT
YOU KNOW CHAIN OF INDEPENDENT.
IN FOR BUSINESS SERVING CLIENTS
ISN'T BUT OVER THE STATE.
THIRTEEN ALL OF OUR CLIENTS IS
AN IT THERE YOU KNOW THE SOLE
PROPRIETOR THE DIRT THEY CAN
HAVE THE TO BE REALLY. BUT THIS
SAYS YES IF YOU CONTRACT WITH
THE COMPANY WHICH WE ALWAYS
THOUGHT THIS LONG. LETTER TO
THE JOURNAL LAST YEAR SAYING
THIS. I'M IN CONTRACTING A
COMPANY. IT HAPPENS ALL ON
HEALTHCARE. THE CAN COME IN AND
CORPS. THE SAME CLIENT IN THE
SAME LOCATION BUT THE PERSON IS
AN EMPLOYEE THIS IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE- WHAT WE CARE MOST
ABOUT IS THAT EMPLOYEES
PROTECTED. DOESN'T MATTER WHO
IT MIGHT MATTER BUT IT WHO'S
DOING THAT PROTECT THE
PROVIDING FOR THEIR PROTECTIONS
WHETHER IT'S SICK DAYS ARE-
MINIMUM WAGE AND OVERTIME AND
ALL THOSE YOU KNOW WE HAVE AN
EMPLOYER OF RECORD. THAT SHOULD
ACTUALLY WILL HELP A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO HAD QUESTIONS UNDER
AB FIVE THE THING THAT WE DID.
WELL AS- YOUR ENDEAVOR OF THIS
ENTIRE BILL WHICH TO
DISTINGUISH BETWEEN A LABOUR
BROKER IN A TRUE REFERRAL
AGENCY AND WE REALLY STRUGGLED
WITH IT BECAUSE IT WASN'T
ALWAYS CLEAR WHEN PEOPLE ARE
ACTING AS A LABOR WORKER IN
CALLING THEM BASICALLY REFERRAL
AGENCY AND WE THOUGHT IF WE
CRAP UNTIL OF DIFFERENT ASK
ITSELF LAST YEAR WE ARE TRYING
TO. PAYS EIGHTY WORKERS GEN
WHAT YES. EVERYBODY FOR ALL
AGES ANDERSON CIRCUMSTANCES IF
YOU'RE A REFERRAL SO AND X.
THAT SO THAT SHOULD TAKE CARE
OF A LOT OF THE QUESTIONS
PEOPLE HAD ABOUT A THIRD OF
INTERPRETERS AS- THE IT. IN THE
WORK IS TRUE. A TO SAY YES NO
TO A- THAT THEY'RE WORKING
UNDER THEIR OWN CONDITIONS ARE
WORKING AS THEMSELVES- AND
REALLY THAT THE REFERRAL AGENCY
OR THE COMPANY IF YOU WILL IS
JUST DOING THE PROCEDURAL STUFF
YOU KNOW CALLING THEM UP DO YOU
WANT THIS JOB OKAY. WE'RE
PROCESSING THE PAYMENT WE DON'T
CHARGE. MANY CLIENTS FOR THAT
SERVICE SO THAT'S WHERE THE
MONEY FLOWS AND- THAT THE
INDIVIDUAL CAN SAY YES THEY CAN
SAY NO THEY GO OUT ON THEIR OWN
THEY DO IT. IT REQUIRES THAT
INDIVIDUAL TO HAVE A BUSINESS
LICENSE- THAT WAS A WHILE
BEFORE I MEAN THIS IS NOTHING
NEW. AS I DO THE ANALYSIS WAS
WAS RIGHT WE'RE WE'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT BECAUSE WE MADE IT
ALMOST SEEMED LIKE OPTIONAL
WHETHER THERE AND CHECK IT OR
NOT AND- WE WILL FIGURE THAT
PIECE- CHOIRS THAT. IT'S A
CERTIFICATE CAN NECESSARY TO DO
THAT JOB OR BE ABLE TO DO THAT
JOB THAT THEY HAVE TO. SO YOU
CAMPUS AN INTERPRETER WHO IS
NOT SIR IN SPANISH BECAUSE WE
HAS BEEN A CERTIFICATION FOR
INTERPRETERS. HOWEVER IF IT'S
AN INDIGENOUS LANGUAGE- YOU
KNOW FROM CARRILLO THAT THERE'S
NO CERTIFICATION AVAILABLE.
THERE THERE'S NO CERTIFICATION
NEEDED SO THAT'S THE WAY WE
DEALT WITH IT. THE NOW
SUGGESTED. I THINK WE FINALLY
GOT IT RIGHT WE'VE BEEN REALLY
STRUGGLING WITH. INSURING
INDIVIDUALS WERE NEGOTIATING
FOR THEMSELVES ARE ABLE TO DO
SO IN THE THIRD. QUALITY THEY
HAVE THE THAT THEY HAVE A SKILL
THAT IS DESIRABLE AND SO THEY
HAVE THE ABILITY TO- BETTER.
SERVE THEMSELVES SO THIS NEW
REFERRAL LANGUAGE. GIVES POWER
TO BE THOSE INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS WERE WORKING UNDER
IT AND HOPEFULLY PREVENT APRIL
AGENCY FROM JUST BEING A LABOR
BROKER. AND TAKING 50% OF
SOMEBODY'S WAGES AND THE THINGS
THAT WE'VE KIND OF SEEN
HISTORICALLY UNFORTUNATELY IN A
LOT OF LOW WAGE WORKERS. IT
ALSO DOESN'T ALLOW- CERTAIN
CRITTERS TO FALL UNDER THIS AND
THOSE WERE THE ONES THAT ARE
DETAINED- HELLO SHE HAD THE
DESIGNATION AS HIGH HAZARD
INDUSTRIES. BORN IN HAS
DIFFICULT HIGHER RISK OF INJURY
ON THE JOB. AND THE REASON WE
DON'T WANT THAT IS WE DON'T.
WANT INDEPENDENT. I READ. I'M
WITHOUT THAT WORKS AND WE DON'T
WANT IT TO BE USED AS A TOOL
AVOID WORK COMP AND FOR SECONDS
AND YOU KNOW IT HIGH RISK. SO
THAT. I THINK WILL SATISFY-
LEGITIMATE. INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS IN THESE FIELDS. AT
THAT HAVE WANT TO WORK
INDEPENDENTLY CAN WORK
INDEPENDENTLY AND I'M HAVE THE
CERTIFICATIONS TO DO SO WE ALSO
HAVE- SPECIFIC LANGUAGE THAT WE
HAVE. CAPTURED ACTIONS WE HAVE
A- RECORDING ARTISTS MUSICIANS
WE HAVE GREATER CLARITY FOR A
AND PHOTOGRAPHERS MULTIMEDIA
PROFESSIONALS IN SOME
EXEMPTIONS THAT- WE STARTED
WORKING OUT RIGHT AFTER AB FIVE
WAS PASSED. WE STILL HAVE WORK
TO DO- AND WE ARE CONTINUING TO
DO THE NEXT SET WHICH WE WILL
WORK WITH IF THIS PASSES YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF AS WELL AS IT
MOVES INTO APPROPRIATIONS. I
MISSED ONE THAT WE AT WE HAVE
ALSO- JUDGES INDEPENDENT JUDGES
AND NOT JUDGE. JUDGE AND JURY
JUDGE LIKE GETTING A CATTLE
SHOW OR A DANCE COMPETITION
THAT THEY'RE NOT EMPLOYEES AND
WE ARE TRYING TO GET IN. M. M.
TO REFEREE HE'S AT THAT THEY
CAN WORK OBVIOUSLY TO REFER
AGENCY AND THEN THERE ARE WAYS-
BUT THE THINGS THAT WE'RE STILL
WORKING ON. PERFORMING ARTISTS
TO PRESENT THEIR OWN ORIGINAL
WORK. SO THIS IS A BECOME AN
ISSUE WHERE A PERFORMING ARTIST
OWN THEIR OWN ORIGINAL WORK AND
SO THEY'RE NOT. AND I'LL TAKE
THE EXAMPLE COMEDIAN A COMEDIAN
AT A COMEDY CLUB. IT IS THEY'RE
DIRECTING THEMSELVES THEY'VE
CREATED IT THE ONCE. THEY DON'T
WORK FOR SOMEBODY BECAUSE OF.
THIRDS OF PROPERTY ISSUE THEN
FOR THE WORK THAT WE'RE WORKING
IN THAT. THAT SHOULD ALSO WORK
FOR. CLOWN JUDGE IS IT NOT THE
CHAIRED CARES DEEPLY SOME F
THESE WHAT I KNOW THAT THERE IS
US INTO PERFORMANCES THAT THAT.
THAT IT VIGILS HAFTED THEY'RE
NOT TAKING DIRECTION FROM
ANYONE THAT'S NOT THE SAME AS
SOMEBODY WHO'S OBVIOUSLY ACTING
IN A PLAY OR SOMETHING WHETHER
BEING DIRECTED. PRECISELY WHAT
TO DO. THE RELATIONSHIP- WE'RE
ALSO WORKING ON THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN TWO
INDIVIDUAL SUBCONTRACTORS SO
THIS IS INTERESTING AND TOUGH
BUT IF THEY'RE TO INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS WHO ARE WORKING
TOGETHER. IN ONE JOB WHICH YOU
GET THE POINT WHERE THEY CAN
HAVE ONE CHECK IN SPLIT
BASICALLY THROUGH THE CONTRACT
THIS HAPPENS- THE WEDDING
INDUSTRY A LOT YOU KNOW. THERE
CAN A PART SHE CAN WORK IT
DOESN'T IF HE'S AN ENEMY. AND
THE OLDER HEY I ALSO WANT SEVEN
MAYES AND SHE'S A. NOT GONNA
BRING. IT IS VERY LIMITED.
STEPS WHERE THEY COULD JUST
SPLIT A CHECK AND EVERYBODY
KNOWS WHAT EVERYBODY'S GETTING
MOVING AND SO TO INDEPENDENT.
CONTRACTORS WE'RE CONTINUING
AMEND LANGUAGE ON VIDEOGRAPHERS
TO CLARIFY THAT IT DOESN'T
PREVENT PEOPLE FROM. THEIR KIDS
DANCE COMPETITION PUTTING IT UP
ON ON A- THE INTERNET. AYE AYE
THE WAY PEOPLE ARE READING
THING SOMETIMES WE JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE PEOPLE UNDERSTAND NO
THAT'S NOT WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. AND THERE'S ONE MORE AT
LEAST- THOSE SHOULD HOPEFULLY
BE COMPLETE BY THE TIME WE GET
OUT OF HERE AND APPROPRIATIONS
TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE- THAT
COULD PETITION- THE LAST ONE
WAS ALSO AN INDUSTRY IF YOU ARE
AWARE PLAN IN YOUR SET UP.
VENDOR RECEIVE BEGIN FROM THE-
THAT IS MAKE YOU THOSE VENDOR
EMPLOY YOU ARE SOME A CONTRACT
SO WE'RE GONNA CLEAR FOR THAT
IS AND THAT THAT'S I THINK WHAT
WE'RE LEFT TO WE ARE VERY
HOPEFUL. MAYBE TWENTY. THIRTY
PRISTINE OF A BROADER. WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO AVOID DOING IS
WRITING EXEMPTIONS FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO DON'T NEED IT
YOU KNOW IT'S NOT A CASE BY
CASE BASIS A LOT. OTHER
SITUATIONS THAT. RUN ACROSS.
AND THAT'S THE TAP OR TAKING
WITH THESE. NOW THIRD COUPLE WE
HAVE TO WRITE OUT STRAIGHT OUT
JUST TO CLARIFY BUT WE'RE
HOPING NOT TO DO ANYMORE. SO
WITH THAT HI. FULL WE HAVE
SATISFIED A LOT OF FOLKS THAT
LANGUAGE IS NOT PRINT WAS
ANALYZED- THE ANALYSIS. ARE
AMENDED LANGUAGE BUT IT WILL I
THINK BE IN PRINT TOMORROW. AND
I THINK THERE'S A MORE CALM.
I'M GOING RELATED TO OF THE
ISSUES IN YOUR EXCEPT IN THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE IN THE-
ANALYSIS TODAY IS THAT CORRECT.
THE REQUIREMENT THAT THAT WE'VE
THAT ARE OUTLINED I THINK THERE
ARE SOME. IN THERE ARE OTHER
ISSUES THAT WERE. THERE
SOMEWHERE STILL WORKING ON
THERE ARE SOME THAT WERE
SUGGESTED. I DON'T EXACTLY.
KNOW MINIMUM I THINK BUT THE
AGREEMENT THEN YEAH. BERMAN AND
C. L. A. AGREE YOU YOUR EACH
THAT YEMENI YOU VERY I DON'T
SEE ANY LEADS SUPPORT WITNESSES
NO I DON'T WANT OPINION THAT'S
VERY GOOD SO WE WILL GO TO
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY FOUR.
AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY SEVEN TíNH
ONE WILL GO TO ROOM TWENTY ARE
THERE THIS IS NO ONE IN TWENTY
FORTY WATCHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWO. FIFTY
SEVEN NOW WE WILL GO. TO PETER.
NOW MY TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TEST THE TELECOM SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROPERTY INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
TWO FIFTY SEVEN AND WE WILL
BEGIN. YES SIR. GENTLEMEN IF
YOU HAVE NOT ALREADY QUEUED UP
TO FOR AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY
SEVEN TWO SHOW SUPPORT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. IN ORDER LINE TO EIGHTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES I'M
SORRY BUT I'M I'M IN OPPOSITION
ALL RIGHT THEN YOU CAN COMPANY
WILL GO AHEAD AFTERWARDS THANK
YOU. PLEASE MOVE ON. YES OUR
NEXT OPEN LINE NUMBER ONE
TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.%
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
IS CARL WANTED WANTED CONSOLE
ADVOCACY NO RELATION BY THE WAY
I'M HERE EXPRESSED SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF THE RECORDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION OF
AMERICA. AND ALSO THE MUSIC
ARTIST COLDEST WE APPRECIATE
GONZALEZ EFFORTS ON FINDINGS
IT. WHAT THE MUSIC INDUSTRY.
ALSO TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PHYSICAL THERAPY
ASSOCIATION WHICH HAS THE
SUPPORT. FIVE HE IS IN FACT
SIXTEEN. SECOND HARMING A
PROFESSIONAL PHYSICAL THERAPY
THANK YOU FOR KEY AREAS THAT WE
SURVEYED AND WE'RE TRYING TO
FIND A SOLUTION FOR THAT WE
WERE HOPEFUL THE- DILLON.
WELCOME NINE TO THIRTY. LIAM IS
PURPLE BAND AND NATIONALLY
BERMAN IN TURN FROM TO MAKE. I
THINK AB G. SEVEN IF I'M TO A
INCLUDE PROFESSIONAL SERVICE
EXEMPTION REAL TIME COMPUTERS
AND FILING INTERPRETER. GOOD
THING. TWENTY THIRTY AIRLINE
AND- GOOD AFTERNOON THIS ISSUE
ALL THE BEISER ON THE OF THE
CAL NORTH RECOGNIZE WE ARE
INJURED OF THAT AB TWO TWO FIVE
SEVEN. PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED.
BY THE TIME SHE BURKE LEADS
WE'RE LOOKING FOR LOOK WE'RE
GOING TO GO MORE CLOSELY. OTHER
THING YOU VERY MUCH IF YOU YOUR
TO TODAY THANK YOU. TWO THIRTY
ONE YOU'RE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS JAMES MOST OF THE CARE
FROM THE TWENTY FIFTH SENATE
DISTRICT IN CALIFORNIA I AM IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL IS AMENDED
TO FIX THE ISSUE WITH PHYSICAL
THERAPIST IN CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ONE THREE ZERO
TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THREE OH
TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
THIS AMERICAN CENTER AT
VALUATION I'M FROM RETURNING
BACK OUT OF GAS POLLUTION. AND
I SUPPORT EIGHTY FIVE THE END
OF THE COLD CARE FAN
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPISTS
PHYSICAL THERAPISTS AT THE TEN
THIRTY FIVE OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPIST AT THE SENATE. THE
DID NOT. ONE THREE ON THE OPEN
HI THIS IS TRACY THIRTEEN THE
GOLD. I BUT THE- OF DIFFICULT.
THANK YOU. PLAN TO THIRTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS THE
ONLY DIFFERENCE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DSTRICTS
ASSOCIATION WITH THE SUPPORT OF
COMMENDED POSITION TO INCLUDE
ARE RECKONED PARK CLASS
INSTRUCTORS. THANK YOU. TWO
NINETY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BUT SHE MEMBERS MICHAEL NEWTON
ON BEHALF OF THE REAL ESTATE
EVALUATION ASSOCIATION- THE
APPRAISER CLARIFICATION IS VERY
IMPORTANT WE SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU. TWO EIGHTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS ALICIA CALZADA AND ON
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL PRESS
PHOTOGRAPHERS ASSOCIATION. THE
COURT AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY SEVEN
AMENDED AND WE DRAW YOUR
ATTENTION TO OUR REGION I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. COMMENTS THANK
YOU. MY NINETY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. CORRECT SHARON MEMBERS
NAMED COMMON AND AS AN
INDEPENDENT PERFORMANCE
PHYSICAL THERAPIST YOU KNOW
FROM SIXTY NINE TO START THE
CALIFORNIA I DO SUPPORT THE
INCREASE IN THE AB FIVE SEVEN.
A HARDSHIP. INTESTINE MIND
EVERYONE THE LINE THAT WE ARE
HERE TO TESTIFY YOUR- YOUR- AND
YOUR POSITION ON LIVE. AND THAT
IS IT THANK YOU. ONE FORTY ONE
YOUR FAMILY IN YOUR POSITION.
MY NAME IS TO RETURN TO
COMPLEMENT A PHYSICAL THERAPIST
THANK THE CRITIC AGAIN OF AB TO
DO SEVEN ADDRESS. TO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NINETY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS VALERIE TECHNICALLY I'M
A PHYSICAL THERAPIST FROM
OLYMPIA CALIFORNIA NINE S.
SUPPORT AB TWO TWENTY TWO FIFTY
SEVEN IF AMENDED THANK YOU. ONE
TO SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS TERAFLOPS
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION WE
ARE ST SUPPORT POSITION THANK
YOU THANK YOU. TWO EIGHTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS KATIE RECORD I'M CALLING
FROM SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT AND
AB TWO TWO FIVE SEVEN COMMENDED
TO INCLUDE PROFESSIONAL
SERVICES EXEMPTION FOR REAL
TIME CAPTURING AND FINDING MUCH
OF HER. THANK YOU. ONE ONE
EIGHTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE EIGHT TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS KEVIN KEARNEY I
NEED TO CHECK WITH THEIR
SYSTEMS FROM THE FORTY NINTH
DISTRICT OF CALIFORNIA AND I
SPLIT THE INCLUSION OF THE
AMENDMENT OF AB TWO TWO FIVE
SEVEN. THANK YOU. NINE FORTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME
IS RICK CATHOLIC PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA THERAPY
ASSOCIATION THAT SUPPORT AB TWO
TWO FIVE SEVEN AMENDED THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. LEVINE
SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
I JUST WANT TO THINK ABOUT
THEIR FOR ALL THE WORK ON THE
LINE WITH US AND PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS YOU HAVE A COUPLE
OUT ANYTHING TO WORK GROUP AND
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
CONVERSATION WITH YOU. THANK
YOU. LINE EIGHTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I NEED TO KNOW
THAT AERATION CRITICAL CARE
BEDS FROM- DISTRICT FORTY AND I
SUPPORT THE INCLUSION OF THE
AMENDMENT OAKS AB. IT TOOK
PLACE THAT THANK YOU. LINE
SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS J. O. JUMPED OVER
ON THE PHYSICAL THERAPIST FROM
THE TO OF CAN AND I SUPPORT THE
INCLUSION OF AN AMENDMENT TO
EIGHTY TWO TWO FIVE SEVEN TWO
ARE ABOUT THANK YOU FOR. THANK
YOU. ONE FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YES MY NAME IS MADELINE
NEWMAN. AND THE CONDITIONS WITH
YOU AND MANY. THAT TRANSLATED
TO IN EIGHTEEN FIFTY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AT NINE TO THIRTEEN
PETER AND WHEN. PHYSICAL
THERAPY THE EIGHTY FIFTH
STRAIGHT CALIFORNIA. MEANT AB.
THANK YOU. ONE ONE SEVENTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND MY NAME
IS MIKE DENNISON PRESIDENT OF
THE THEATRICAL PRODUCERS LEAGUE
OF LOS ANGELES THE LEAGUE'S
QUICK THE BILL AS AMENDED TO
COVER SMALL NONPROFIT THEATERS
THAT ACT AS INHIBITORS THANK
YOU VERY HOW MUCH MONEY.
FINALLY THE FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE FIVE FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. NO RESPONSE LEVINE TO
LINE TO SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS JOANNE
HUNDRED SOMETHING THAT A
CALIFORNIA I SUPPORT AB TWO TWO
FIVE SEVEN AS AMENDED PLEASE
INCLUDE PROFESSIONAL SERVICES
EXEMPTION FOR REAL TIME
CAPTIONING. WE ARE ACTUALLY
SHOOT YOU TESTAMENT THANK YOU.
NINE TO NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS RYAN
FLORES A PHYSICAL THERAPIST TO
AND FROM THE SIXTY EIGHT MR
CALIFORNIA NINE OR INCLUSION OF
AN AMENDMENT TO AB TWO TWO BY
SEVEN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LAST. HELLO MY
NAME IS SABINA IN THE SUNDAY
AND THEN NATIONALLY CERTIFIED
SIGN LANGUAGE INTERPRETERS FROM
SANTA ROSA CALIFORNIA I SUPPORT
AB TWO TWO FIVE SEVEN IF
AMENDED TO INCLUDE
PROFESSIONALS EXEMPTION FOR
REAL TIME CAPTIONING. WHICH
INTERPRETERS THANK YOU. ONE ONE
TWO SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
TWO SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
HELLO MY NAME IS STEPHANIE AND
I AM A LONGTIME CERTIFIED
NATIONALLY CERTIFIED PLAN
LANGUAGE INTERPRETER I ALSO
REPRESENT THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA REGISTRY OF
INTERPRETERS FOR THE DEAF. AND
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
TWO FIFTY SEVEN IF IT INCLUDES
AN EXEMPTION A PROFESSIONAL
ATTENTION FOR REAL TIME
CAPTIONING FINDING WHICH
INTERPRET THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ONE SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS. MY NAME IS JODY.
THANK YOU I'M PROTECT AND BOTH
NOT AND THAT. THANK YOU. ONE
ONE FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS USUALLY
MONTERO I'M A LONG TIME
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR IN A
PHYSICAL THERAPY I AM IN FULL
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU. NINE THIRTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M DOCTOR LILY
THOMPSON OF THE PHYSICAL
THERAPY THE COURT TV IF YOU
FIVE SEVEN WITH AN AMENDMENT TO
ADDRESS THE PROBLEMS CREATED
REGARD. ACT VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR TO THANK YOU.
NINE ONE SIX ONE YOUR IS OPEN.
HI I'M CHRIS REPUBLIC OF KOREA
AND THE BUSINESS OWNER LOOK
ARABIC YOU HAVE AN AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE. FOR THE CALIFORNIA
BUILT ASSOCIATION. ANCIENT DAY
FALK. OFFICES WE ARE IN. THANK
YOU. NINE EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS A LITTLE
AND THE PHYSICAL DAMAGE STUDENT
ON THE FORTIETH DISTRICT
CALIFORNIA AND I WAS IN AT THE
MOMENT. EIGHTY TWO PERCENT.
THANK YOU. ONE TO THIRTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS MARKET REMEMBER DESCRIPTOR
AN FROM FORTY TWO IN CALIFORNIA
AND I SUPPORT THE INCLUSION OF
THE AMENDMENTS FOR THE H. TWO
TWO FIVE SEVEN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. TWENTY THIRTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
KATHERINE WALLY. I MEAN
NATIONALLY CERTIFIED TRAINING
CENTER ALONG THE CREEK I
SUPPORT AB TWO FIVE EIGHT AND
THEN INTO A LOOK AT SERVICE
EXEMPTION FOR REAL TIME
CAPTIONING AND SIGN LANGUAGE
INTO. THANK YOU. LINE THREE
TRADE YOUR EYES OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS RAPHA BLOCK COME FROM
DISTRICT SIX FOR THE PHYSICAL
THERAPY AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWO TWO FIVE SEVEN THANK YOU
THANK YOU. NINE THREE OH ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE NAME IS
AMANDA READ BECAUSE THEIR PETS
FROM OF THE GREATER LA DISTRICT
OF CALIFORNIA AS A LICENSED
PROFESSIONAL WITH A GRADUATE
DEGREE I SUPPORT INCLUDES THE
AMENDMENT TO AB TWO TWO FIVE
SEVEN. THANK YOU. LINE TO
NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS. CURRENTLY THE
DIFFICULT FROM THE FORTIETH
DISTRICT I SUPPORT INCLUSION OF
AN AMENDMENT TO EACH ISSUE. WE
SHOULD. BLIND TO SIXTY THREE
AIRLINER OPEN. YES MY NAME IS
CINDY FARNHAM I AM A SIGN
LANGUAGE INTERPRETER NATIONALLY-CERTIFIED IN SACRAMENTO I
SUPPORT AB TWO TWO FIVE SEVEN
IF AMENDED TO INCLUDE A
PROFESSIONAL SERVICES MENTIONED
FOR REAL TIME CAPTIONING THANK
YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY. LINE ONE EIGHT
FOR. HI MY NAME IS ERICA WENT
AWAY I WORK AS AN AMERICAN SIGN
LANGUAGE INTERPRETER I ALSO RUN
THE TRAINING PROGRAM FOR
INTERPRETERS AT AMERICAN RIVER
COLLEGE AND A SPECIAL KEY GRANT
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION FOR INTERPRETERS AND
I SUPPORT. EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY
TWO TWO FIVE SEVEN. THANK YOU.
ONE THREE OH SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS DANNY WE
NEED. A BIG BECAUSE ON THE
INLAND. BUT I THINK.
OPPENHEIMER I. THANK YOU. PLAN
TO EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I MEAN SEVEN BY ONE. THIS
SAN DIEGO DISTRICT I SUPPORT
THE AMENDMENT TO EASY TO DO
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
THE TESTIMONY. THREE OH NINE
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. MY NAME
IS CAROL RESNICK I'M A PHYSICAL
THERAPIST FROM THE TWENTY FIFTH
DISTRICT CALIFORNIA AND I
SUPPORT INCLUSION OF AN
AMENDMENT FOR PT TO AB TWO TWO
FIVE SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ONE TWENTY YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. ONE TWENTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MOVING ON TO MY NUMBER
FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS DR ADAM SHEPHERD
A SINGLE THERAPIST FROM THE
TWENTY SECOND DISTRICT HELD FOR
ME AND I SUPPORT INCLUSION OF
AMENDMENT TWO. AB TWO TWO FIVE
SEVEN. THANK YOU. LINE TWENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
LEONARDI UM BECAUSE THIS.
TWENTY SIX CALIFORNIA IS
SUPPORTED I MET TO BE TO SEVEN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE THREE
TEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
MEDIA BECAUSE CRITICAL THERAPY
AND ON JUST YOUR CAL. I'D LIKE
TO TALK HOW THE GUY DEGREE AT
INCLUSION OF AN AMENDMENT. TO
EIGHTY TWO TWO FIVE SEVEN THANK
THANK YOU. ONE OH TWO YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. ONE OH TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS LANA
GEOGRAPHICAL CHARACTERS
ASSISTANCE FROM THE IN THE
COUNTRY IT TOOK A CALIFORNIA
THE PRESIDENT PROFESSIONAL WITH
AMERICAN THE AIRPORT BECAUSE OF
AN AMENDMENT TO EIGHTY TWO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MIGHT BE
TO YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. HELLO
MY NAME IS ARMINE ON THE
PHYSICAL CARE FROM THE SENATE
THERE. HOME PROVIDER PHYSICAL
OCU SPEECH THERAPISTS ARE
ESSENTIAL AND SUPPORT AND-
MEMBER MEASURE CREATIVITY
PUBLIC THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
GREG HAYES WITH STRATEGIES
THREE SIXTY ON BEHALF OF BOTH
SHUTTERSTOCK AND GETTY IMAGES
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO TWO FIVE
SEVEN. THANK YOU. LINE TWENTY
THREE LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
LEARNED IN OLYMPIA REPRESENTING
THE AMERICAN PLANNING
ASSOCIATION WE CURRENTLY DO NOT
HAVE A POSITION ON THE BILL
THAT WOULD LIKELY SUPPORT THE
BILL AS AMENDED TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS THAT RELATE TO PUBLIC
AGENCIES AND OUR MEMBERS TO
PROVIDE CRITICAL PLAN. YEAH
COMMITTEE YOU. LINE THREE
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS AND WE GET A
PHYSICAL THERAPIST FROM THE SAN
DIEGO DISTRICT OF CALIFORNIA AS
A LICENSED PROFESSIONAL WITH
THE GOT GRADUATE DEGREE AT THE
PRECLUSION OF AN AMENDMENT
EIGHTY TWO TWO SEVEN THANK YOU.
LINE NINETY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS ERICA
DALLAS A LICENSED PHYSICAL
THERAPIST FROM THE THIRTY THIRD
DISTRICT OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF THE AMENDMENT TO
DATE B. TWO TWO FIVE SEVEN THE
ADDRESS THE HARDSHIPS CREATED
BY EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NINE THREE
TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS A KING
FISCAL THERAPIST FROM OUR
DISTRICT FOR SEVEN IN MY
DAMAGED OF THE AMENDMENT.
BIDDING AN AMENDMENT. TO ALLOW
PHYSICAL THERAPISTS. TO BE
INDICATING CONTRACTOR GREAT
THANK YOU. ONE TWO SEVENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE TWO SEVEN
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. RESPOND
TO OPEN MY NUMBER FIFTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN IS NOW OPEN.
MY NAME IS KIM CAMPBELL FISCAL
THERAPISTS FROM THE INLAND
COUNTY DISTRICT OF CALIFORNIA I
SUPPORT INCLUSION OF AN
AMENDMENT TO AB TWENTY TWENTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT
NEXT WHAT'S- LINE THREE OH
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
THREE ZERO EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NO RESPONSE WILL OPEN MY
NUMBER TWO EIGHTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
ITSELF AND I'M OF THE TYPICAL
CHARACTER FROM SAN FRANCISCO
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT THE
INCLUSION OF AN AMENDMENT TO
EIGHTY. SEVEN EIGHT. RIGHT
EIGHT THANK YOU. THANKS WITH.
NINE TO FIFTEEN LIGHTED UP.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS YOU
PONTIFICAL BENEFITTED FROM THE
SIXTY EIGHT DISTRICT OF
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT
INCLUSION OF AN AMENDMENT TO AB.
TWO SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS. ONE THREE
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS ALMA GARCIA PHYSICAL
THERAPIST FROM SAN DIEGO
DISTRICT OF CALIFORNIA AND I
SUPPORT INCLUSION OF AN
AMENDMENT TO AB TWO TWO FIVE
SEVEN THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS.
NINE THREE THREE NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
KATHERINE MARTINEZ THIS IS YOUR
SYNDROME SAN DIEGO DISTRICT OF
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT THE
VISION OF AMENDMENTS AND TWO
EIGHTY. FIVE THANK SO MUCH NEXT
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS MELANIE
HARD I'M CERTIFIED SIGN
LANGUAGE INTERPRETER FROM SOUTH
LAKE TAHOE CALIFORNIA I SUPPORT
AB TWO TWO FIVE SEVEN YES
AMENDED TO INCLUDE PROFESSIONAL
PROJECT OPTION. THANK YOU SO
MUCH NEXT WITNESS. LINE EIGHTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
EIGHT EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES I'M PAUL SMITH FROM US
SENATE DISTRICT EIGHT ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT- TWENTY THREE AND I
SAID AMENDED A. B. TWO FIVE
SEVEN TWO CREATE SAFE HARBOR X.
FOR. AND PHYSICAL IS. THANK
THANK YOU FOR THAT. NINE THREE
THIRTY YOUR LINE OPEN. HER NAME
IS SPENCER LARSON LEGAL TO FROM
GREATER AND ACROSS. HAS A
LESSON FOR THE GRAY DEGREE I'VE
INCLUSION OF AN AMEND TO TWO
TWO FIVE TWO FOUR PHYSICAL
OCCUPATIONAL AND SPEECH THERAPY
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THREE FOUR ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I THINK CARMODY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA OUT
TO COUNCIL IN THE ENTERTAINMENT
UNION COALITION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THREE
FOURTEEN LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ZACHARY
SMITH THE QUALIFIED SIGN
LANGUAGE INTERPRETER AND SO
PROPRIETORS B. SMITH RETURNING.
FROM CALIFORNIA I SUPPORT E.
TWO TWO FIVE SEVEN IF AMENDED
TO INCLUDE QUALIFIED SIGN
LANGUAGE. CAN CAPTURE AS
AMENDED BY THE EIGHTY UNDER THE
PROFESSION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WHEN THIS. WHY THREE TWENTY
YEAR IS OPEN. HELLO THIS
ECONOMIC SIGN LANGUAGE
INTERPRETER FROM ELDORADO
COUNTY AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF MYSELF AS AN
INDEPENDENT BUSINESS OWNER AN
IMPORT OF THE DEAF COMMUNITY'S
RIGHT TO ACCEPTABLE
COMMUNICATION AND UNFORTUNATELY
DUE TO THE CONTINUED LACK OF
COMPLIANCE WITH ADA MANDATE.
CALIFORNIANS CANNOT EQUALLY
AGUIAR-CURRY THANK YOU SO MUCH
NO NO TESTIMONY THIS TIME.
THANKS WITNESS LINE THREE FORTY
YES- THREE FORTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS TAKING
A GAMBLE LIKE THEN CRITICAL
CARE BECAUSE WHEN YOU GO TO
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT
INCLUSION OF AMENDMENT. THANKS
FOR MUCH. WHAT TWENTY THREE
FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINEIS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS JOHN NORWOOD ON BEHALF
OF THE INSURANCE FIELD SERVICES
ASSOCIATION AND WHAT SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THREE
FOUR NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THREE FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. NO RESPOND TO OPEN MY
TO NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MARIANA PENSION
LARKIN PRESIDENT OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF INDEPENDENT
JUDICIAL INTERPRETERS OF
CALIFORNIA WITH THE PORT OF
AMENDED. TO ALLOW INTERPRETERS
OF THE GRANDMOTHER AND- THANK
YOU. I NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
THREE ONE LINE IS A- GREETINGS
MY NAME IS DR MARIAM FROM LOS
ANGELES I IT DIFFICULT THEIR
PLACE AND I SUPPORT AND TO AB
TWO TWO FIVE SEVEN TO INCLUDE
PHYSICAL THERAPY. THANK YOU.
THREE FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS FELICIA FIVE
DOWN FROM LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA I AM IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWO TWO FIVE FOUR LICENSE
WILL CONTRAPTION ARSON. THANK
YOU. THREE TWENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS KAREN GERRITY I'M A
MUSICIAN AND WE THE CONTRACTOR
AND I IN THE BOOK IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. HI NINETY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WORKING ON
THE LINE ONE TWENTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ONE TWENTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THREE FIFTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
VICTORIA BECAUSE BY THE
ASSISTANCE FROM THE SAN DIEGO
BASED IN CALIFORNIA I FEEL I
CAN PROFESSIONALLY BADLY GREET
I LIKE ENGLISH AND MANY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I AM. RICHARD
CALLING. TWO EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YEAH HI MY NAME
IS TREATMENT FOR THAT HOW CAN I
MY TIMELINE WHICH INTERPRETER
IN SUPPORT OF AB SHE JUST FIVE
SEVEN. THANK YOU. THIRTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWO THREE
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS IMMEDIATELY ON
BEHALF OF THE NATION AND THEN
THE PENITENTIAL. CALIFORNIA
WE'RE SORT OF A TWEENER WE
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS THE
OPTIMISTIC AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING OUT OUR OUTSTANDING
ISSUES TO ALLOW FOR
INTERPERSONAL. SUBCONTRACTING
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THREE
SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS JENNIFER MYERS
FOR MINISTER. I THINK AB TWENTY
TWO FIFTY SEVEN IF AMENDED O
INCLUDE QUALIFIED PLANNING
WOULD YOU APPRECIATE THAT.
THREE SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY MAJOR I AM A LICENSED
PHYSICAL THERAPIST FROM SAN
DIEGO CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT
OF AN AMENDMENT AB. VERY MUCH
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
THREE THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THREE THREE NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THREE SIXTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JEFF HANSON
INTERNATIONAL FRANCHISE
ASSOCIATION THE RECORD- CENTER
ARE ESSENTIAL TWENTY SEVEN AS A-
THANK YOU THREE SEVENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HEY MY NAME IS
MARTHA RAMIREZ THE PHYSICAL
THERAPIST ASSISTANTS FROM THE
SAN DIEGO DISTRICT OF
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT
INCLUSION OF AN AMENDMENT TO AB
TWO TWO FIVE SEVEN THANK YOU.
EXPLAIN YOUR PLAN. THREE ONE
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WITH NO
RESPONSE TO OPEN MY NUMBER TWO
SEVEN THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I MEAN. I'M FROM LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA I SUPPORT EIGHTY TWO
TO FIVE SEVEN IS AMENDED TO
INCLUDE CORPORATE. THANK YOU.
PRESET ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI FAILING TO GOVERNOR CLINTON
AMENDMENT TO INCLUDE QUALIFIED
SIGN LANGUAGE INTERPRETERS IN
REAL TIME CAPTURING THE
PROFESSIONAL THANK YOU. AB
TWENTY TWO BELL. A MOVE ON
PLEASE. THREE SIXTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MIGHT BE JUST
CATHOLIC GRANT FROM THE
THEATRICAL PRODUCERS NEED WITH
FIVE LOS ANGELES WE SUPPORT
WITHIN AMENDMENT TO A FOR A
PARTIAL EXEMPTION FOR SMALL
NONPROFIT THEATERS. THANK YOU.
THREE TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THREE TWENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NO RESPONSE WILL
OPEN NINE THREE SEVENTY THREE.
SCHNEIDERMAN AMBER TO GEORGIA
SPEECH LANGUAGE PATHOLOGIST
FROM TWENTY TO GO AND I SUPPORT
INCLUSION OF AN AMENDMENT AB
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AMENDED TO
TESTIMONY TODAY PLEASE NEXT
WITNESS. FIFTEEN TO EIGHTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO YES WE
HEAR YOU HELLO YES PLEASE GO
YEAH- SO I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
I MEAN YOU TO PLEASE SPEAK UP.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN TO SPEAK.
PAUL YEAH. A MIDDLE INITIAL
ENOUGH. WHAT WE'RE NOT WE'RE
TAKING SUPPORT TESTIMONY RIGHT
NOW. SO YOU CN CALL BACK AFTER
THANK YOU PLEASE NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. YES SIR THREE SEVENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. MY
NAME IS STEPHANIE GOUGH AGAIN
AND CONTINUE TO CALIFORNIA I
SUPPORT EIGHTY TWO TWO FIVE
SEVEN AMENDED TO INCLUDE
PROFESSIONAL. THANK YOU. THREE
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. ANY GOLDEN CERTIFIED SIGN
LANGUAGE INTERPRETER I SUPPORT
EIGHTY TWENTY TWO FIFTY SEVEN
IF AMENDED TO INCLUDE INTERPRET
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU HAVE NOT
ALREADY QUEUED UP PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO TO SHOW SUPPORT
FOR EIGHTY TWO TWO FIVE SEVEN
AT THE TIME. MY TWO SEVENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER CARE
MEMBERS MAP BROUGHT ON BEHALF
OF SAG AFTER IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. ONE TWENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE TWO ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MOVING ON LINE
THREE SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THREE SEVEN NINE YOUR
LINE IT'LL. NO RESPONSE WERE
MOVING ON TWENTY ONE FIFTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
TOM SHE HE REPRESENTING THE
LANGUAGE ACCESS PROFESSIONALS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
MET DEPRECIATE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR THANK YOU. THIRTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THREE THREE
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MANY
BANISHMENT TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY FROM SAN DIEGO- AND
EXPORT INCLUSION SEVEN MILLION
EIGHTY FIVE SEVEN. LINE THREE
THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. RETREAT I HAD REMOVED
HIMSELF FROM CUBA BONTA THREE
FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THREE FIFTY. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
MA'AM PLEASE GO AHEAD. THREE
FIVE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MCKENNA NEW MYSELF ADULT AND.
MOVING ENVELOPE WERE OPEN LINE
THREE FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS WILL BE
MEMORY CATHOLIC COPTIC CAL
COALITION OF PRACTICING
TRANSLATORS AND INTERPRETERS
I'M IN FAVOR OF TWO TWO FIVE
SEVEN CONFESSION. THANK YOU.
THREE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
LAURIE CLAMOR I'M A PHYSICAL
THERAPIST FROM DISTRICT
EIGHTEEN AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF
TWO TWO AB TWO TWO FIVE SEVEN
THANK YOU THANK YOU. TWO SEVEN.
NOW OPEN. TWO SEVEN ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NO RESPONSE WILL
OPEN NINE THREE EIGHTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. MICHELLE A
BONDING AND I WAS INTERPRETER
AND I SUPPORT TWO TWO EIGHT
FIVE SEVEN F. AMENDED TO IT TOO
TO FIVE SEVENTY TWO. THEY YOU.
THREE SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THREE SEVEN THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AND AT THE TIME
SO WE HAVE NO ALLOW SHOWING
SUPPORT WE CONTINUE WOULD YOU
PLEASE CHECK ONE MORE TIME TO
MAKE SURE COVERED ALL OF WHO.
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. YES
SIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THAT
PRECEDENT THAT THE COMMAND OF
ONE IN ZERO YOU MAY NOW DO SO
TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR AB TWO TWO
FIVE SEVEN. NINE THREE EIGHTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI KATE
MURRAY I'M A BOOK EDITOR AND
COPYWRITER IN SAN DIEGO CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO TWO FIVE
SEVEN THANK YOU THANK YOU. WELL
IT NAY TWO CREATE. WHY NINETY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN I DON'T.
YOU CAN HEAR YOU YES. PLEASE GO
FOR YEAH HEY LEAH. OKAY I'M
SORRY- HELLO MY NAME IS ALFREDO
CASTRO OCCUPATIONAL THERAPIST
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF AB THREE
TWO FIVE SEVEN FOR ALL HOME
HEALTH CARE. THANK YOU ALEX
CHANGES. MACULA CAROLINE THREE
SEVENTY THREE PEOPLE I HAD. MY
NAME IS HEALTH CARE A SPEECH
THERAPIST FROM SAN DIEGO AND I
AM IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO TWO
SEVEN THANK YOU. WELL THE
CAROLINA THREE SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE SEVEN
NINE LINE AND NOW ALL. I HATE
MATH THE LITTLE TIMELINE Q.
SEVENTY PLEASE CALL I HAD.
LYING TO YOURSELF DO YOU YOU
MAY BE NEEDED ON YOUR AND YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. RIGHT NEXT
LEVEL CAROLINA THREE NINETY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS THEIR PRINTS UP
ADDITIONAL THERAPISTS FROM SAN
DIEGO AND I CONDITION TO EIGHTY
PP FIVE SEVEN THANK YOU. NOT
DOUBLE LINE. THREE EIGHTY EIGHT
YOU'VE AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
JESSICA GOMEZ I AM FROM WHEN A
PARK IN THE CAPTION IN I WOULD
SUPPORT OF AB TWO TWO FIVE
SEVEN. THANK YOU. THE LITTLE
CAROLINE THIRTY NINE PLEASE
BOUGHT. HELLO MY NAME IS DAN
WALKED I'M FROM CITY CALIFORNIA
I SUPPORT THE AMERICAN
DISABILITIES ACT AND THE
CAPTION PLEASE INCLUDE.
PROFESSIONAL SERVICES EXAM
REALLY KIND CAPS YEARS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY
APPRECIATED. NEXT WITNESS
NATIONAL TO LINE Q. EIGHTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE Q. EIGHTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. GEN
MAXWELL TO LINE THREE EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. JUNE NOT
HELLO CAROLINE THREE SEVENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
THREE SEVENTY NINE LINE IS NOW
OPEN. MADLA CAROLINE NINETY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN. MY NAME IS CARL'S
GERALD I'M AN OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPIST WHO WORKS WITH
THERAPY COMPANIES WOULD LIKE TO
CONTINUE PROVIDING
SUBCONTRACTED SERVICES FOR
THERAPY COMPANIES AND- MY
SCHOOL WORK. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. ONE MEXICO CAROLINA AT
THREE NINETY SEVEN PLEASE CALL
I HAD. HI MY NAME IS ADRIAN
DUNCAN I'M AN INDEPENDENT
MUSICIAN AND I'M REPRESENTING
INDEPENDENT. MUSIC
PROFESSIONALS UNITED AND WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO TWO FIVE
SEVEN THANK YOU THANK YOU. THAT
LEVEL KILL THIRTY NINETY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. A RAINY
CALLING ON BEHALF OF
INTERNATIONAL FRANCHISE
ASSOCIATION WITH THAT PART OF
THE MANDATE TO PROTECT
FRANCHISE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GLOBAL TEL LINE FOR ALL THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
DAN A CONTAINER AND I MAKE
CAMPBELL AND WE'RE BOTH
MUSICIANS IN L. A. AND WE
SUPPORT AB TWO TWO SEVEN THANK
YOU. HELLO HELLO. THREE SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE THREE
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
RIGHT NOT POLITICAL LINE FOUR
OH FOUR CLEVELAND HAD. HI THIS
BILL BY SECOND URGING SUPPORT
FOR CONTINUED. I CAN'T
TREATMENT BY CALIFORNIA
PERFUSION IS IT HAD BEEN ADDED
TO THE BANKING VERY MUCH.
THANKS A LOT FOUR HUNDRED
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
DAVID POWER I DID INDEPENDENT A
TOGGLE BURKE IN SANDIEGO
HIRED'S SUPPORT IF AMENDED
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANKS
WELL TO ALIGN FOR- TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BUT YOU'RE SURE NUMBERS
MELANIE BUT THE CALIFORNIA
BANKERS ASSOCIATION SUPPORTIVE
OF AMENDMENTS AND DIRECTING
CREEPERS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MACROPHYLLA TO LINE FOR ALL
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES WE YEAH- MY
NAME IS ALICIA BILLION AND I'M
IN UNISON AND A CONTRACTOR AND
I AM IN SUPPORT AND TO FIND.
THANK YOU FOR. GET AXALTA LINE
FOUR OH SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS BRIAN ASHER ALHADEFF
OF THE ARTISTIC AND GENERAL
DIRECTOR OF OPERA SAN LUIS
OBISPO PRESENT EIGHT HUNDRED
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR MUSICIAN.
AND I AM SB HUMANELY OPPOSED TO
A. B. WE'RE ON SUPPORT AT THIS
POINT. NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
WELL THE TIMELINE FOR ALL EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS.
AND I PRO KERR I AM THE CAR
CAPTURE TIME CAPTIONING FOR THE
HARD OF HEARING COMMUNITY AND I
SUPPORT AB TWO TWO FIVE SEVEN
IF AMENDED TO PLEASE INCLUDE
PROFESSIONAL THERE WAS VERY
MUCH IN FOR REAL KIND AND CURE.
FINALLY NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
MAXWELL TELL NINE TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE GERMAN GONZALEZ. MY
NAME IS ON INJURED BIRD AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF HOME
HEALTH CARE WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE GRADUATE
DEGREES. THANK YOU AND AS A
REMINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT AND AB
TWO TWO FIVE SEVEN FOUR SUPPORT.
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NOW AGAIN
LONDON FOUR SUPPORT AB. EIGHT
TWO TWO FIVE SEVEN. UNMATCHABLE
TO LINE Q. EIGHTY PLEASE CALL I
HAD. HELLO MY NAME IS COULD
VIDA PAGLIA AND I'M CALLING FOR
EXPLAINING WHICH INTERPRETER
AND I AM THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOLUTION OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF THE DEAF AND I
SUPPORT EIGHTY TWO TWO FIVE
SEVEN. TWO THANK. WELL THE TO
LINE Q. SEVENTY PLEASE CALL I
HAD. RICHER MEMBERS CAITLIN
DATA FOR THE TRANSPORT WORKERS
UNION OF AMERICA AND JOHN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MAXALT TO
LINE FOR SEVENTEEN CRITICAL I
HAD. LINE FOR PLEASE AHEAD.
JETTING OFF AGAIN THE NEW YORK
CALIFORNIA I SUPPORT AB TWO TWO
FIVE SEVEN AMENDED TO INCLUDE A
PROFESSIONAL SERVICE EXEMPTION
REAL TIME CAPTURE. THANK YOU.
WELL TO ALIGN FOR TWELVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO YES WE HEAR YOU
YES HELLO MY NAME MY NAME IS MY
ASIA AND I AM OPPOSED TO A. B.
TWO WE'RE ON SUPPORT AT THIS
POINT THANK YOU FOR THE
TESTIMONY. I AM NOT AS A
REMINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT OF AB
TWO TWO FAX FIVE SEVEN VERY.
AGAIN THE COURT FOR AB TWO TWO
FIVE SEVEN ONE BEEN THERE ON
NOW. AGAIN THIS IS FOR THE
BOARD OF ATP. TWO FIVE SEVEN.
AND WE HAVE NO ONE IN QUEUE AT
THE MOMENT VERY GOOD THANK YOU
HAVEN'T HEARD FROM ALL OF THE
SUPPORTERS WE WILL NOW FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS AND HEAR FROM
ANY OPPOSITION. I DO NOT HAVE A
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS. IN
ONLINE OR- IN THE SCHEDULE. SO
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO ANYONE IN
THE GALLERY WHO'S HERE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY TWO
FIFTY SEVEN SEE NO ONE. IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY IS THERE ANYONE
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AB TWENTY
TWO FIFTY SEVEN I SEE NO ONE.
THERE IS WELL SHE WILL NOW MOVE
TO WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
BE THE TELECONFERENCE SERVICE.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROP THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITE. OF AB
TWENTY TWO FIFTY SEVEN WE WILL
BEGIN. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU UP HOLD OF AB CUTE Q. FIVE
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO NOW AGAIN THIS IS FOR
OPPOSITION FOR THE- GLOBAL TEL
LINE AT THREE TWENTY TWO PEOPLE
I HAD. YES LORENA ORTIZ
SCHNEIDER PROFESSIONAL
TRANSLATOR AND INTERPRETER AND
FOUNDER OF THE COALITION OF
PRACTICING. AND LEADERS AND
CALIFORNIA. ANALYSTS AMENDED TO
INCLUDE PROFESSIONAL TRANSLATOR
MUCH COVERAGE UNDESERVEDLY
THANK YOU. WE UNDERSTAND HELLO
MICHAEL IT'S CAROLINE FOR ALL
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS BRIAN ASHER ALHADEFF IN THE
ARTISTIC AND GENERAL DIRECTOR
OF OPERA SAN LUIS OBISPO
REPRESENTING EIGHT HUNDRED
CENTRAL COAST INDEPENDENT
MUSICIAN CONTRACTORS AND WE'VE
BEEN REALLY OPPOSE AB TWO TWO
FIVE SEVEN THANK YOU.
MACKSVILLE ONLINE FOR. WELL
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO PHILIP
WE HEAR YOU MY DEAR YEAH YES
THIS IS MY ASIA AND I AM AT ME
AGAIN I AM OPPOSED TO THE H E.
B. TWO TWO FIVE SEVEN BECAUSE
IT'S NOT INCLUSIVE FOR AFL AND
VERY MUCH WE APPRECIATE THAT
THANK YOU. MAXALT SIXTY THREE
PLEASE CALL HAD. YES THIS IS
STEVE CATHOLICA WITH THE
INDEPENDENT PHYSICAL THERAPISTS
ARE CALIFORNIA WE ARE COMING
OUT AND SLIGHTLY DIFFERENTLY WE
ARE OPPOSED TO UNLESS AMENDED
THANK YOU INCLUDES PHYSICAL
THERAPISTS. AND THEN I THOUGHT
TO LINE FOR TWENTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. CURRENTLY THE. NEXT
WITNESS BRITISH. HELLO CAROLINE
THREE TWO YOU'VE GOT. NINE
THREE TO YOUR LIFE ITSELF. IN
AND THEN AGAIN FOR OPPOSING THE
BILL AB FIVE SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE THAN THEIR OWN NOW AGAIN
ONE BEEN THERE ALL OR APOLOGY
AB Q. AND THEN WILL NOT
POLITICAL LINING. TO NINETY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINETEEN
NINETY SEVEN YOUR OPEN. ALL
RIGHT NEXT TO A LITTLE TO LINE
FOR TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FROM DISTRICT TWENTY NINE AT
THE CERTIFIED INTERPRETER
PLEASE. CALL UNLESS THEY HAD
PROFESSIONAL TRAINING VERY MUCH
YOUR TESTIMONY IN AND- NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. MAXALT CAROLINE
FOR THIRTY YEARS SO I HAD. OKAY.
CALIFORNIA. AMENDED THANK YOU
VERY APPRECIATE YOUR TO TODAY.
ARI AND- TO LOCAL AB. TWO TWO
FIVE SEVEN ONE BEEN ZERO NOW.
PRESS ONE BEEN ZERO TO UPHOLD
AB TWO TWO FIVE SEVEN NOW
THAT'S A LITTLE LINE AT ONE
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. BLIND
ONE TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
RIGHT AND THEN WE DO HAVE ONE
OTHER PERSON IN KILO TO BE JUST
A MOMENT. AND AS A REMINDER AT
LONDON'S ZERO TO UPHOLD. WILL
MACBOOK PRO LINE. ONE CAN. WE
HAVE ABOUT THIRTY IN THE QUEUE
AT THE MOMENT GOOD BULLETIN
LINE FOR THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IF SOMEBODY ELSE IS
STILL SPEAKING OF. THREE
RESEARCH BOARD THIRTY TWO
YOU'VE GOT HAD. MY NAME IS BILL
LIBERMAN INTERPRETER FOR THE U.
S. DEPARTMENT OF STATE AND VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF LANGUAGE
SPECIALISTS AND DIES YOU CAN
OPPOSITION TO TROOP. I ENACT
THE LAW CAROLINA FOR THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE FOUR
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
IS IT MY TURN EIGHT YES WE CAN
HEAR YOU. HI I AM CALTRAIN
CHALLENGER TRIED SENDING WHICH
INTERPRETER A SIMILAR ONE
MILLION DOLLARS AND CALLUM AND
DID TO EXEMPT SIGN LANGUAGE
INTERPRETER. THANK YOU AT THE
LOCAL CAROLINA Q. SEVENTY EIGHT
CRITICAL I HAD. HELLO I'M DAVID
PINTO DIRECTOR OF THE NONPROFIT
ACADEMY OF MUSIC FOR THE BLIND
I REPRESENT AFTER SCHOOL
NONPROFIT MUSIC SCHOOLS SERVING.
THEN AGAIN TO OPPOSE AB TWO TWO
FIVE SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
BEEN TERREL AGAIN TO UPHOLD AB
TWO TWO FIVE SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE THAN THEIR OWN NOW. AND L.
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE ABOUT FOUR
IN THE QUEUE GLOBAL TEL NINE
FOUR OH SIX WELL I HAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON SPEAKER AND CHAIR
COMING FROM CIVIC BALLET SAN
LUIS OBISPO AND STATE STREET
BALLET SANTA BARBARA OUR
ORCHESTRAS SUPPOSED. TO TWO BY
THREE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MAXELL LINE FOR THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE CALL I HAD. SURE YOU
WANT AND I APPROACH AB TWO FIVE
SEVEN UNLESS AMENDED FOR SIGN
LANGUAGE INTERPRETER. I VERY
MUCH. MAXALT TO LINE FOR FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOU KNOW MY
NAME IS DAVID JEROME A PHYSICAL
THERAPIST AND THAT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA- PHYSICAL THERAPY IS
IN CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT
INCLUSION OF THE AMENDMENT A.
B. TO. THANK YOU SIR. HELLO
MEXICO TO LINE FOR THIRTY SEVEN
AND AGAIN THIS IS FOR
OPPOSITION OF AB TWO TWO FIVE
SEVEN VEHICLE I HAD FONG LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AMONG CHRISTMAS
AND I'M ATTEMPTING OF THE JEWEL
IN THE OPPOSITION TO TWO FIVE
SEVEN. THE NATIONAL MANAGER.
WITH A PERFECTIONIST SAMPSON
FOR SIGN. LANGUAGE THANK YOU
SIR. THANK YOU AND WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE THANK YOU AT THE
MOMENT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU TO ALL THE SUPPORTED
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WE WILL
NOW BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK
TO. MEMBERS AND I JUST WANTED
TO. MEMBERS IN THE AUTHORS NOTE
THAT TOO WE HAVE A HARD STOP
THIS EVENING AT SEVEN PM AND
THOSE BILLS NOT HEARD HE HEARD
ON THE ELEVENTH WITH THE
REMAINING. SIXTY BILLS THAT WE
HAVE. THERE SO THAT'LL BRING
BACK TO MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. SPAIN YES SENATOR
MITCHELL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR I JUST WANTED TO
JUST MAKE SURE I UNDERSTOOD UP
FRONT PRECIADO THE AUTHORS HARD
WORK ON THIS FAR FROM MY BACK
TO YOU OVER THE COURSE OF THE
YEAR- BUT IN LISTENING TO SOME
OF THE OPPOSITION FROM THE
OPPOSITION- UNLESS AMENDED I
JUST WANT TO BE SHORTLISTED
MAKE SURE I'M- ABOUT. POLLUTION
TO- DEAL WITH I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT. AND THEN THE CORRECT
MY LANGUAGE IF I USED THE WRONG
TERMINOLOGY ASSEMBLY MEMBER-
CERTIFIED. ASL TRANSLATORS OR
INTERPRETERS. CERTIFIED ASL
TRANSLATORS OR INTERPRETERS
RATHER AND. CAN WORK THROUGH A
REFERRAL AGENCY YES
SPECIFICALLY. AND REMAIN
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS. I
THINK. THANK YOU FOR THE
CLARIFICATION THANK YOU SENATOR
SENATOR JACKSON. YES I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR TAKING ON THIS
EXTRAORDINARY TASK OF THE YOU
KNOW THE SAD THING IS THIS IS
HAPPENING. THIS THIS DYNAMIC
DECISION AND THE ABC CRITERIA
OCCURRED BECAUSE OF ABUSES THAT
THE STARTED WITH EMPLOYERS
REALLY TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
PEOPLE AND- BUT THERE ARE SOME
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS WHO
HAVE LEGITIMATELY IN TWENTY
BEEN DEPENDENT AND I KNOW THAT
WE HAD TO. CONVERSE WHAT BEER
ARE I APPRECIATE. THE OPENNESS
WITH TO HAVE RESPONDED TO.
LEGITIMATE CONCERNS IN MANY
CASES- I SUSPECT THIS ISN'T THE
END OF THE ISSUE- FIVE. I'M
SORRY TO SAY THAT BUT I WANTED
TO THANK YOU FOR. DOING YOUR
BEST I KNOW THIS IS BEEN VERY
EMOTIONAL AND VOLATILE A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO. OF FEEL AND PERHAPS
THAT THERE. THE FUTURE OF IN OR
RISK IT WOULD BE GREAT IF WE
HAD A MORE NATIONAL POLICY SO
THAT WE DID HAVE WE FIFTY
DIFFERENT STATES HAVING
DIFFERENT THE FIFTY DIFFERENT
WAYS TO LOOK AT THIS AND-
PERHAPS IN THE FUTURE- TO. IF
WE HAVE A- FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
THAT IS COMMITTED. TO FAIRNESS
WITH EMPLOYEES THAT THAT THIS
MIGHT OCCUR BUT IN THE INTERIM
CALIFORNIA. IS THAT THING I
THINK. PROTECT WORKERS WHICH
THE ULTIMATE GOAL HERE AND YET
THERE ARE ARE THERE ARE SO MANY
NUANCES HERE AND I KNOW WE
HEARD FROM A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO-
EXPRESS CONSTRUCTION THAT THEY
AREN'T INCLUDED OR THAT THEY
SHOULD BE INCLUDED THEN I KNOW
THAT YOU WILL. CAN YOU TO. WORK
WITH IT WITH AN OPEN MIND- BUT
ALWAYS WITH THE NOTION THAT WE
NEED TO PROTECT WORKING PEOPLE
SO THAT THEY'RE NOT TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF SO I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR THAT EFFORT. I WOULD
LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL. THANK
YOU. AND THEN THE SENATOR
MORALE HAZARD BEEN AS WELL
THANK THANK YOU AND I TO WANT
TO IT THANK YOU SUMMER GONZALEZ
FOR DOING THIS BILL- I WOULD.
POINT OUT THAT OF COURSE- THE
START WITH THE DYNAMICS
DECISION BY THE CALIFORNIA
SUPREME COURT AND IN FACT IN
MANY WAYS EIGHTY FIVES IS THIRD
DESCRIBES SOME. EXCEPTIONS SO
SOME PEOPLE WHO SAY WELL EIGHTY
FIVE IS WHAT BECAUSE EVERYTHING
ACTUALLY DYNAVAX THERE WASN'T
P. FIVE THAT AND- EVERYONE WITH
STILL FACE BASICALLY ALL THE
PEOPLE COMPLAINING ABOUT THE
FIVE WITH STILL HAVE SAME
SITUATION. I'M AND OF COURSE
THIS IS A FURTHER- BUT. MORE OF
WHAT WE'VE DONE HISTORICALLY
BUT THE OTHER PART I ALSO WANT
TO POINT OUT AND CERTAINLY HERE
YOU KNOW AS WE'RE EXPERIENCING
KOVIN. THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
VARIOUS EMPLOYEE PROTECTIONS
AND BENEFITS THAT WE OF PUT
INTO CALIFORNIA LAW AND SOME
YOU KNOW AT THIS ALSO FEDERAL
IN THE FEDERAL LAW AS WELL AND
HOW IMPORTANT THEY ARE. SO WELL
CERTAINLY-APPRECIATE THAT MANY
PEOPLE- YOU KNOW IT IS. A WANT
FLEXIBILITY IN OTHER TYPES OF
THINGS AND PERHAPS MAYBE WE
SHOULD BE LOOKING AT SOME OF
THAT OUR OWN EMPLOYMENT LAW.
STILL BEING SURE AT. STILL
BETTER PEOPLE TO EMPLOYED. F.
POSSIBLE AND I THINK THAT'S
WHAT THE SUPREME COURT SAID
AND- THAT IS I THINK WHERE WERE
WE WANT TO TRY TO GO WE JUST
HAD ANOTHER BILL WE TALKED WITH
YOU A AN APPOINTMENT TO GET THE
SIX WHO WERE LET. BECAUSE OF
COVERAGE ALSO THINGS HAPPEN
PEOPLE GET WELL THAT'S WHY WE
HAVE AN EMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
START WITH. A SO I THINK IT'S
SOMETHING FRAME FOR WE HAVE TO
REMEMBER AS TO WHY. IS STILL
YOU KNOW THE BAY AND WE
ACTUALLY. WE'VE WE'VE CHOSEN AS
THIS CALL AND UNLESS PERHAPS
SOME OF THE CUT WHO WHO
ACTUALLY PROVIDING MORE AND IF.
DIRECTLY TO POPULATION TO
GOVERNMENT INSTEAD OF EMPLOYER.
WE HAVE CHOSEN TO IT THROUGH SO
MAKES IT MUCH MORE IMPORTANT. I
UNDERSTAND CERTAINLY HEARD FROM
VERY PEOPLE. ONE AMEND IT'S AN
EXCEPTION BUT WHY DO. WITH THIS
PETITE BILL THAT YOU SYSTEM.
ARKANSAS IS THAT INSTEAD OF
TAKE OFF BY FOR WERE TO CREATE
MORE SO. RULES RIGHT SO WE THE
BUSINESS THE EFFORT XIN. SO THE
THAT DAYS. THAT THE REFERRAL
AGENTS AND I AM I HOPE THAT AS
PEOPLE ARE THINKING. YOU KNOW
THEY PROFESSION THEIR ROLE. TO
THINK ABOUT HOW THEY MAY
ACTUALLY FOR INTO THAT. IN OF
TRYING TO SAY WHY WANT JUST
CARVED. FOR MY PARTICULAR
PROFESSION ACTUALLY FOR EXAMPLE
THIS DOES DEAL INTERPRETER. AND
BUT YOU HAVE TO BE A-
INTERPRETER UNLESS THERE'S A
SORT OF THE- SO. I GUESS
THERE'S SOME PEOPLE WHO. RIDE.
ARE PROVIDING FOR SOMETHING
THAT'S THAT THAT DOES HAVE A
CERTAIN MAY NOT PERHAPS TO
PURSUE CERTIFICATES ARE FEW
THAT THE NINE BARRIER. WELL I
MEAN I THINK THAT YOU KNOW I
DON'T THINK IT'S A FAIR OF THE
BILL THAT WE DO TRY TO THAT AND
I BELIEVE SIGN WE- A SORT OF.
AND SO IT'S NOT THAT DOES WITH
THE ISSUES INTO MAKING. I AM SO
UNDERSTAND IF THERE SOME YOU
KNOW SOME FURTHER CONCERN BUT I
REALLY DO ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO
LOOK AT THIS FRAMEWORK I KNOW
THAT YOU'RE CONTINUING TO WORK
ON THIS. NIGHT BRING PORT. BY
THE PRECIADO TRYING TO TAKE
MORE OF AN APPROACH OF LOOKING
AT THE SYSTEM. INSTEAD OF
TRYING TO PICK UP PROFESSION BY
PROFESSION CREATING THIS YOU
KNOW THIS PARTICULAR PROFESSION
THAT PARTICULAR PROFESSION SAYS
HOW DO WE- GO THROUGH SO.
TIGHTLY YES THE BILL IN THE
YEAR CONTINUED WORK. DR PEPPER
SNAPPLE GROUP TO VICE CHAIR L.
YES I THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COME THINKING WERE ON WAITING
TO GREGORY THERE YOU ARE OKAY
THANK YOU SEVEN MEMBER GUNS FOR
ANY SOME CARP SOME MORE OUT
HERE TO THANK THAT DO ONE AT
SHOW ONE WITH YOU AND YOU A
COUPLE EASY. HERE I HAD A LADY
WHO'S OF THERAPIST AND SHE TOLD
ME SHE WORKS FOR DIFFERENT
DOCTOR BECAUSE THE DOCTOR THAT
SHE WORKS FOR DO NOT HAVE
ENOUGH WORKS HIRE FULL TIME
CITIZENS THEN AGAIN A CON. DR
JOE WILL SEE OVER MISTER MIST.
THE STAFF. AT CERTAIN. SHOULDER
IN. GIVE HER A CALL FAIR SO
QUESTION A NEW IS HOW DO I KNOW
AT BECAUSE STOPPED ARE GONNA
HIRE UNDER W. BE. YOU KNOW THEY
DON'T KNOW HOW. MANY THE BILL
OR FOR FORTY INSULA PUT THIS
THERE'S OTHER LIKE RESPIRATORY
THERAPY SOME MENTIONED. THEY
THINK THEY GOT A OUT FOR THE
SPEECH SO THERE'S A LOT OF. LOT
OF OTHER CHAO HE- AS WE GO AYE
AYE ABOUT THE TO TRUCK. TO
CATERS I KNOW HOW. A CATER NOT
BE AN INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR
ITSELF. CAN YOU HOLD I'M GONNA
FOR THIS. BE BECAUSE YOU CARD
OUT. S. HOW YOU ENVISION- THE
EXAMPLE I GAVE A ONE LADY WHO
WHO WORKS FOR TWELVE DIFFERENT
DOCTORS HOW IS SHE GOING TO BE
W. TWO. THANK YOU BYE. THANK
YOU FIRST- THE PREMISE THAT
SOMEBODY CAN'T WORK FOR TWELVE
DIFFERENT EMPLOYERS AT IT I
KNOW THIS IS SHOCKING TO PEOPLE
BUT THIS ACTUALLY HAPPEN SEAT
YOU CAN RECEIVE TWELVE W. TWOS
WE. TALK TO ANY IOTTIE STATE
HANDLE TELL YOU MANY DOUBLE TWO
IS THAT THEY FOR TO EMPLOYERS
THE- THAT THAT HAVE. SO THAT'S
ONE THEY COULD DO IT ON THE
OTHER IS THE ARE ABLE TO FORM
THEIR OWN BUSINESS AND
INTERNALLY FOR THEIR OWN
BUSINESS AND BUSINESS TO
BUSINESS RELATIONSHIP. I DID A
LITTLE BIT IN HELP DOING THAT
WORK HOW THE FILE THEIR TAXES
IT MIGHT. BUT IT'S A FORMAL. OF
THEIR OWN BUSINESS SO WE KNOW
THAT THOSE I'M- THE I REQUEST
MENTOR BEING CARE. BY BASICALLY
THAT WE THOUGHT. NEED I MEAN
WE'VE TALKED GOT RIGHT NOW. I
WOULD HATE TO BE A HEALTH CARE
PROVIDER AND NOT HAVE- WORKERS
COMPENSATION ARE NOT HAVE. SOME
SORT OF ACCESS TO STI OR PAID
LEAVE GIVEN WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
AND HEALTH CARE SO. IS REQUIRED.
STATION AND NOT IS ANOTHER THAT
THAT THAT'S A CHEAP OR POSSIBLE.
AND ALSO THEY MIGHT BE ABLE TO
WORK THROUGH EVERY AGE AND SO
INTO THE CERTAIN. THAT'S WHY WE
IN THE CAT TO CALL OUT EVERY
SINGLE SESSION BUT SAID THIS IS
HOW YOU CAN SHE REMAINING
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR OR SMALL
BUSINESS AND WORK IN THIS
FASHION IF THAT'S WHAT'S GOING
TO WORK FOR. THE ARMY. THERE'S
GOING TO BE. RUNNING A- LIST OF.
PLAYER AND THOSE ARE GOING TO
EXIST I DO WANT TO POINT OUT
THIS IS IN ONE OF THE THINGS WE
DONE OVER THE LAST YEAR BEFORE
COBIT ESPECIALLY MIDDLE OF TO
THE EIGHTY REALLY DOES IS ONE
COME TO TOP OUT IN THE- WOULD
ASK EDT HOW MANY. A DEAD IN THE
FIELD WHAT THE FOUNDER. AND
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT WERE
BROUGHT UP. IN THE HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS IN THE- IN THE
EIGHTEEN MONTHS FOR THIS BILL
THREE EIGHT HUNDRED AND NINETY
TWO STILL OUT OF. THE GATE.
THEY FOUND. TEN THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN IS
CLASSIFIED WORKERS. IT'S
HAPPENING WAS UNDER BRIGHT IS.
AB FIVE. SO WE KNOW THAT THIS
IS A ISSUE AND WE NEED TO GET
THAT A LOT OF THE EXEMPTION
PEOPLE ARE. FOR WERE NOW LEGAL
UNDER BROWN YOU CAN. SO I TO
NAME A COUPLE THE BECAUSE I
THINK PEOPLE SHOCKED. I'M NOT I
HEARD CATER. WELL THEY CATER
CAN HAVE A KEY COMPANY. BUT YOU
CAN'T HAVE WORKING FOR YOU AND
I CAN'T. TO BARTENDERS ARE
STEPS. I ARE YOU PERCENT
RELEVANT UNDER YOUR PUT YOUR DO
AT. YOU'RE ASKING THEM TO DO IT
YOU BABY IN ANY CERTAIN WOULD
BE IN A SO THIS WASN'T LEGAL
BEEF AN EXAM THEM WOULD PUT
THEM RIGHT BACK UNDER BROWN
WITH JUST ME THAT THESE WERE
HAD A LONG PROCESSED IN ORDER
TO GET THE RIGHTS. WE HEARD A-
TRYING TO GO. WHAT CENTER
MORALE OF THE- ISSUES HE
BROUGHT SAID HE. HELLO THERE
PASSED. IN OTHER STUDIES OUT
THERE BY SOME ECONOMIC THINK
TANKS THAT YOU KNOW THEY'RE
FORECASTING THAT THIS WILL
AFFECT ONE MILLION JOB SO THERE
IS A- YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE WE'RE
KIND IN A- KERRY'S POSITION
HERE WITH CALL THAT. THE
ECONOMY AND SO THOSE KINDA A
LONG TERM THE FACT THAT I. OUT
ON GONNA BE YOU JUST NAY BE
ANOTHER MILLION WERE FOR MAYBE
IT'S ONLY FIVE HUNDRED THAT
STILL OF PEOPLE IT'S IT IS A
BIG BIG IT TWO THEIR LIFE SO. I
JUST YOU KNOW WE HAVE THINK
ABOUT THOSE THINGS WE WANT CAP.
BUT JUST SEEMS LIKE WE'RE DOING
ALL THINGS LESS COMPETITIVE
YEAH WERE. COULDN'T BLOCKS
BLOCKS A LOT OF. WAYS SO ANYWAY
THOSE ARE JUST MY CONCERN IN
THOSE BY THE WAY ON A OF PEOPLE
THAT COME TO ME AND TALK TO ME
AND THEIR THEIR- ABOUT YOU KNOW
THEIR LIVES SO. YOU ANSWERED
MIKE BUT THEY ARE THAT WAS JUST
THE GENERAL TO I WAS. ASK AND
FOR EVERY QUESTION SOMEONE ASKS
THERE FOR OTHER QUESTIONS THAT
COME UP. IN THAT LEAD YOU TO
SOMETHING ELSE SO I APPRECIATE
AND I THINK WE'VE HEARD FROM.
MIKE IN FROM THE COMMUNITY AND
THE- CERTAINLY THE PROFESSIONS
THAT TODAY THIS THE ISSUE OF
THE BUSINESS TO BUSINESS WHICH
IS AFTER PAN MENTIONED BY
BROADENING THAT ORTIZ
CLARIFYING IN MEMORY ON THAT.
AND THE REFERRAL AGENCY THE
LEGITIMACY THAT CAN BE A
OUTLINED THROUGH THAT I THINK
IT'S REALLY AN ANSWER TO THE
CERTIFICATION FOR INTERPRETERS.
A MAJOR MAJOR BENEFIT FOR A LOT
OF US UP AND I KNOW YOU'RE
WORKING ON THE- PERFORMING ARTS
IN SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT
RELATED THERE AND CERTAINLY
WITH COVERT RIGHT NOW IT'S A-
HUGE. THAT COMMUTE IS LOOKED AT
IN THE END WE CAN FIND A PATH
FOR THEM THAT THEY ONE GREW
AREA THAT I. BECOME A SMALL
GROUP. WHO ARE REAL YEAH KIND
OF A HUGE YOU CAN DISAPPEAR NOW
SO I'M HOPING THAT WE GET THAT.
INTEREST THIRD. I GOT HOT THE
FIGHTING WITH URGE COMPANIES
FIGHTING WITH THE- AYE THEY
NEED SOME STE. STATUTE GUIDE
THERE SO HOPEFULLY YOU CAN WORK
WITH THEM AND IN SOME WAY IS
WHAT IS THE BILL. MOVES IN WE
CAN SEE HOW IT WORKS AT BUT I.
DO SUPPORT THE BILL IT TODAY
IS- THE INSPIRATION THAT WE'VE
SEEN IN THE THAT YOU'VE DONE
HAVE BEEN IT'S BEEN JUST THE-
MUCH APPRECIATED AND THERE'S NO
ONE THAT UNDERSTANDS THIS
ISSUE. BETTER THAN YOU AND ALL
THE PRECIADO VERY MUCH IN HERE
SO- WHICH I WE DO HAVE A- A
GOOD APPROPRIATE TIME WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE ASSEMBLY. I JUST.
NOT IT. SOME ON THAT ONE WILL
THAT THAT SENATOR MARIA USED
THERE ARE ONE MILLION
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT'S TRUE AND SO I
GUESS YOU COULD SUGGEST THIS
MAY AFFECT UP TO ONE MILLION
PEOPLE THAT IT'S NOT TRUE. YOU
CANNOT BUY FIRST OF ALL THERE
ARE PLENTY OF INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS WHO FALL UNDER THE
ABC TEST WHO DON'T YOU KNOW
THEY THEY PROVIDE THEIR
SERVICES. IN A GIVEN EXAMPLE IN
FACT BECAUSE I THINK AT SOME
POINT THERE'S SO MUCH
MISINFORMATION OUT THERE RIGHT
NOW SO RIGHT NOW PEOPLE ARE
ASKING A LOT ABOUT TUTORS. CAN
I GET A TUTOR YEAH YOU CAN. AS
AN INDIVIDUAL. YOU CAN HIRE
SOMEBODY TO COME IN YOUR HOUSE
IN AN I AM. TO STAY IN YOUR
HOUSE BECAUSE YOU MIGHT BE
CREATING A HOUSEHOLD EMPLOYEE
BUT YOU CAN HIRE SOMEBODY TO
COME IN AND SAY OKAY WHAT DAYS
ARE YOU AVAILABLE THIRDS. SOME
HELP OUT. YOU CAN BE AN
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR YOU PAY
THEM DIRECTLY YOU KNOW EAT.
THAT'S COMPLETELY LEGAL THEY
NEVER FALL UNDER- THE ABC TESTS
THEY ARE THEY FALL UNDER THE A.
B. C. TESTER THEY'RE IN CONTROL
OF THEIR OWN. SERVICES THEY'RE
SERVING IN THE- THREE
INDEPENDENT BUSINESS AND YOU
DON'T HAVE TO TURN HIS USUAL
COURSE OF BUSINESS. SO WHEN
PEOPLE START YOU KNOW IT'S LIKE
THAT'S ALLOWED NOW. I GOT
NERVOUS WHEN I SAID THAT
BECAUSE THEY SIT IN YOUR HOUSE
AND THERE ARE RULES TAX RULES
THAT PREDATE AB FIVE ABOUT.
WORKERS IN YOUR HOUSE BUT IN
THAT SITUATION TWITTER CAN'T IF
YOU BROUGHT IN A FULL TIME
CHILDCARE PROVIDER THAT'S A
WHOLE DIFFERENT SITUATION
OBVIOUSLY. I WANT PEOPLE TO
READ. MANY OF THESE RULES
EXISTED BEFORE THOSE OF THOSE
RULES DON'T EXIST BUT THERE ARE
LEGITIMATE INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS WHO NEVER THIS IS
NOT AN ISSUE FOR. IN MILLION A
WORK. AND THEN OF COURSE
THERE'S ALL ACTIONS WE MADE
ALREADY. THE FIRST ARE ARE
REALLY BE AFFECTED. AND THEN
FINALLY YES. HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF WORKERS THAT ARE
BEING AFFECTED I WILL NAME SOME
OF THEM TO DATE. THERE ARE
TODAY THE LABOR COMMISSIONER
FILED ON BEHALF OF HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF UBER AND LIFT
DRIVERS WHO HAVE NOT RECEIVED
ENOUGH MINIMUM WAGE THE- THEN
ALAMEDA. BECAUSE FIVE THOUSAND
OF THEM HAD FILED WAIT THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE
YEAH OTHER BEING. DEAD BUT
THAT'S A- GOOD A FACT YOU KNOW
I THINK. MADE WHOLE FROM THAT
THE APRS OF LOST INCOME. THAT'S
POSITIVE AFFECT WE KNOW THAT
THIS DOES CHANGE THE FIRST. OF
LIFE IN DIFFERENT WAYS.
IMPORTANT NO. TRULY THE MINUTE.
THE. TRACTOR WHERE IS
MISCLASSIFIED NOT MAJORITY
WE'RE NOT WAS CUT BUT THE
SERVICE WORKERS THAT WERE
INDEPENDENT YESTERDAY ARE
CHANGING BECAUSE NOW THEY DON'T
HAVE TO GO THROUGH A LENGTHY
COURT CASE TO FIND OUT THAT
THEY WERE MISCLASSIFIED IN THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER CAN DO HER
JOB WHICH HE'S DOING TODAY SO I
WANT TO PUT THAT OUT I ALSO. IF
THEY CAN GET A ON. WHAT WE
HEARD FROM COMPANIES AGAIN.
THERE IS NO WAY I COULD
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU COULD HAVE
A GROUP OF MUSICIANS COMING TO
PERFORM CERTAIN TIME DOING WHAT
A CONDUCTOR IS TELLING THEM TO
PERFORM TOGETHER YOU KNOW
DRESSED A CERTAIN WAY DOING
THINGS A CERTAIN FORM THAT
WHATEVER PASCARELLA. SO IF IT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE THAT WE
EXAMPLE OUT SYMPHONIES ALIVE
OPERAS THEY'VE THEY'VE
TRADITIONALLY IN FACT BEEN
EMPLOYEES OF. I'M GOING TO
POINT THAT OUT WE ALSO KNOW
THAT THERE WERE FOUR THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT
MISCLASSIFIED MUSIC SB FOUR
EIGHTY FIVE THAT'S THAT'S THE
DATA EDT THERE ARE MUSICIANS
WERE NOT IN ABOUT BEYOND PLATE.
AT. RESTAURANT ON A SATURDAY
BUT THERE. WERE GOAL TO WHAT IS
AGE. AND HOW BEEN MISCLASSIFIED.
SO I FEEL LIKE WE DON'T
HOMEWORK THIS WEEK WE
DEFINITELY TRIED TO LOOK AT
EACH INDIVIDUAL CASE WE'VE
CREATED A FRAMEWORK HOPEFULLY
THAT WILL FIT FOR MOST PEOPLE.
BUT LABOR LAWS EXIST AND
THEY'VE EXISTED FOR A LONG TIME
AND THAT A LOT OF THE THINGS
THAT PEOPLE ARE BRINGING UP.
BABY NEVER LEGAL PEOPLE.
REALIZE THAT IT AND WE NEED TO
ENFORCE THOSE LAWS THAT. FOR A
LONG. WELL GET. YOU KNOW I
THINK OF THE NUMBER MAYBE TO
CHANGE A BIT MODEL THEY MIGHT
BE RELIEVED OF THAT THEY DIDN'T
END UP WITH ALL THOSE FINES AND
FEES AND GET SUED AT ONE POINT
NOW THAT. BY THE BENEFITS TO
WORKERS THAT THEY DESERVE SO
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR MARIE
ME WITH THAT AND PLEASE THE
PEOPLE OF QUESTIONS TILL I JUST
HEARD HIM CALL OUR OFFICES ON
THIS THE TUTOR THING REALLY
GOING BECAUSE YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY RIGHT NOW PEOPLE ARE
LOOKING AT A LOT OF DIFFERENT
WAYS TO- PROVIDE LESSONS FOR
THEIR CHILDREN YOU CAN YOU CAN
OTHER PARENTS CAN DIRECTLY. YOU
KNOW. FOR SOMEBODY DO LESSONS
IN THAT DOESN'T MEAN THEIR
EMPLOYER YOU KNOW SO THAT'S I
DON'T KNOW HOW WE GOT DOWN THAT
ROAD AND PEOPLE STARTED MAKING
THAT DECISION SO- WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER NINE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND
WE DO HAVE A SENATOR JACKSON TO
MOVE- ATTACHED TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS-
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
MEMBERS PLEASE SPEAK INTO YOUR
MICROPHONE IN ORDER RECORDED
VOTE. SENATOR HILL HI CENTER
HILL HI SENATOR MORALE. BROWN
HI CENTER MORALE HI SENATOR
JACKSON. JACKSON AYE SENATOR
JACKSON HI SENATOR MITCHELL
MITCHELL LIVE SENATOR MITCHELL
HI SENATOR PAN PAN AYE SENATOR
PAN HI. THE BILL HAS FIVE BOOKS
AND IT IS ABOUT WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO. SB THIRTY FIFTY SIX.
GREAT AS I AM HOPING I DON'T
USE UP ALL YOUR TIME TODAY BUT
WE GOT TWO MORE HOPEFULLY THESE
GO QUICKER AB EIGHT THIRTY
FIFTY SIX- I BASICALLY SAID TO
BE A PRETTY LOW STANDARD FOR
WAREHOUSE- EMPLOYERS AND THEY
HAVE A SYSTEM RIGHT NOW WHERE
THEY HAVE. DEMERIT SYSTEM FOR
WORKERS BECAUSE IT'S CALCULATED
BY HOW QUICKLY THEY'RE PACKING
BOXES AND HOW QUICKLY THEY'RE
MOVING ALONG AND THEY GET TO
MERITS IF YOU WILL I'M CALLING
THEM TO MERIT SAY ME CALL THEM
SOMETHING ELSE- FOR TIME OFF
TASK. WITH THE TIME OF TASK
DEMERITS COME THROUGH ITS
PRETTY AUTOMATED AFTER A
CERTAIN AMOUNT THEY GET FIRED-
FROM THEIR JOB. ALL WE'RE
ASKING IN THIS BILL IS THAT IT
THAT THE TIME OFF TASK CANNOT
INCLUDE TIME. THAT INDIVIDUAL
GOES TO USE THE BATHROOM THAT
THEY CAN'T INCLUDE TIME THAT
INDIVIDUAL GOES TO WASH THEIR
HANDS OR DOCUMENT AN ONSITE
LABOR- VIOLATION. IN ONE HALF
AND WE KNOW FROM LAWSUITS AND
WHAT- SITUATION. THEIR HOUSE IN
RIVER. EMPLOYEES MINUTES TO THE
REST. SO IF A USER RESTROOM
THEY THEY'VE GOT TO ADD
FOURTEEN MINUTES OF TIME OFF
TASK. AND CAN GET IMPACT OF
BEHIND ENOUGH WHERE USING THE
RESTROOM PROVIDE THEM WITH A
DIFFERENT EVENTUALLY THEY WILL
LOSE THEIR AFTER THREE OF THE-
DURING THIS PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS THIS IS ACTUALLY CREATED
CRISIS FACTOR WOULD BE A
LAWSUIT. AND NOW IN. THE EAST
COAST ABOUT THE SAME AMAZON
MAINLY WAREHOUSE WORKERS-
NEEDING TO WASH THEIR HANDS
DURING COLD IT AND THAT THEY
THEY CAN'T BE PENALIZED FOR
HAVING TO WASH THEIR- THAT'S
WHAT THE COURTS DECIDED. THESE
ARE BASIC HUMAN FUNCTIONS WE
SHOULD ALLOW IT TO BE- USED
AGAINST WORKERS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I AM.
PRETTY GOOD THANKS VERY MUCH
AND YOU HAVE LEAD IN SUPPORT.
ROSE MARIE MALIGN OF THE
ANGELES COUNTY LABOR FEDERATION
OR- ARE YOU ON THE LINE THANK
YOU SENT YES THANK YOU CENTER
CAN YOU HEAR ME WE HEAR YOU
FINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU MY
NAME IS ROSE MARIE MOLINA AND
WHAT THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
FEDERATION OF LABOR AND I'LL BE
SERVING AS A PRIMARY WITNESS IN
SUPPORT OF THE V. THIRTY FIFTY
SIX. EIGHTY THIRTY FIFTY SIX
AIMED AT PROVIDING SOLUTIONS TO
WORKLOAD AND BREAK ISSUES AND
WE'RE HELPING. THIS POLICY IS
IMPORTANT NOW DURING THE DAY
MAKE. THE WAREHOUSING INDUSTRY
IS EXPANDING TO MEET THE
CONSUMER. DEMAND INCREASED
ARRAY OF PRODUCTS AND SHORTEN
DELIVERY TIME. WHEN COMPANIES
PROMISED GOOD WITHIN THE SAME
DAY. PURCHASE OTHERS WITHIN OUR.
COULD NOT COME. AT THE- WEAR
WORKERS. IT WAS HARD WORKERS
TAKE BREAK BEFORE. AND CURRENT
ORDER THE MORE BREAKS INTO. BUT
MANY WORKERS DON'T HAVE THE
ROOM TAKE IT BACK OF THESE
PROTOCOLS. THE PROBLEM IS THAT
THE PEOPLE TECHNICALLYHAVE.
THE CURRENT LAW BUT THEY DON'T
HAVE THE WITH. THEM IN A WAY
THAT WILL COUNT AGAINST THEIR
PRODUCTIVITY. ULTIMATELY
RESULTING IN. THE WORKERS. AND
LIKE USAGE RATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
GONZALEZ IT. ONE AMAZON WORKER
RIVERSIDE COUNTY. HOW DID THE
IT WAS TO FOR HER TO USE THE
RESTROOM AND- THE OCT SYSTEM
AND HOW. DEMAND QUOTA SHE SAID
TO A REST BREAK WITH. I WOULD
HAVE TO WALK THREE TO GET TO
THE NEAREST RESTAURANT MY WORK.
AND I WOULD STRESS ABOUT HER
BACK TO MAKE. BECAUSE I KNEW
THE TIME UP TO GET ME IN
TROUBLE.ALSO HELP MAKE MEETING
THE REST OF BECAUSE I HAVE TO
MEET QUOTAS. SIMILARLY A
WALMART WHERE WORKERS SAN. BILL
COUNTY. EVEN THOUGH THE QUOTAS
DOUBLE THANK. WE HAVE NOT BEEN
STOPPING AT ALL TO OUR- MORE.
HOWARD GOING STOP IF THEY'RE
STILL BE DEMAND. TO ME. A CO.
TO HUNDRED I TO PICK A MOVIE
EVERY HOUR. THE WORKERS WANT TO
DOWN THIS. BECAUSE THEY'RE
SCARED. I TERRIFIED OF BRINGING
HOME MY- BUT HE WORKERS. A
COMMON OCCURRENCE. I DON'T
THINK WE WELCOME THE EXPANSION
OF WORKING WHERE HOUSING. BUT
WE STRIVE TO MAKE SURE IT'S
SUSTAINABLE IN STATE. WHAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR IS THAT
WORKERS ARE GIVEN TOPIC. EIGHT
BREAKS PROTECT. NEGATIVELY
IMPACT. THEIR COLLECTIVE. WHAT
VEHICLE. ALL ULTIMATELY THIS
BILL PROVIDES X. BIG BREAK
RESTROOM RECOVERING TO WASH
THEIR HANDS WITHOUT THE FEAR OF
PENALTY WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
BILL PROTECTS WORKERS AND A
GROWING INDUSTRY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION ON BEHALF OF
WORKING PEOPLE I URGE YOU TO.
THANK YOU MISSION ALLEVIATE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
TESTIMONY. WE WILL NOW GO TO
ANYONE IN THE GALLERY WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY FIFTY SIXTY NO ONE IN
THE GET MOVING TO THE- ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. NO ONE IN. TWENTY
FORTY WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB PRETTY FIFTIES.
NOW GO TO THOSE WARNING TO
TESTIFY. VIA TELECONFERENCE
ARVEST MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPTLY INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTY FIFTY SIX AND WE
WILL BEGIN. SHARE GENTLEMEN Q.
SUPPORT AB THIRTY FIFTY SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE THE INVERELL
NOW. AGAIN MR TOWARD THE PORT
EIGHTY THIRTY FIFTY SIX. IF YOU
ARE ALREADY IN THE QUEUE
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS WHAT
THE- REMOVE YOURSELF. AGAIN THE
TOWARD COURT AT EIGHT THIRTY
FIFTY SIX LEVEL TO LINE AT
THREE EIGHT PLEASE CALL I HAD.
DALY GRAVEL WITH YOU AFTER THE
AFTER CAPE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. METROPOLITAN LINE
THREE SIXTY PLEASE GO OUT.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS MITCH
SNIDER WITH CALIFORNIA LABOR
ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THAT
THE LOCAL CAROLINE ONE NINETEEN
VEHICLE I HAD. THE LION NECTAR
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE LAST
WORKERS NETWORK WE SUPPORT AB
THIRTY SIX THANK YOU. MAXILLA
TIMELINE CUTE TWO WE'VE GOT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN THAT BROUGHT ON
HE TEAMSTERS STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. MAX LOCAL
TIMELINE FOR ALL FIVE WE'VE
AHEAD. AFTER KATHY WALLETS THE
ACCOUNT PARTNERSHIP WORKING
FAMILIES IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. MAXELL TO
LINE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS MEGAN ARE TEETH AND THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
INSTITUTE OF POPULAR EDUCATION
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
FIFTY SIX THANK YOU. NOT A LOT
WHY NO ONE NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CARE HILL AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MEETING AT THE NEEDS THAT I
WASN'T AND I'M REPRESENTING THE
WAREHOUSE WORKER RESEARCH
CENTER WE ARE SPONSORS AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT. EIGHTY THREE
FIFTY SIX THANK YOU ASSEMBLY.
BURKE UP. WELL TO ALLIANCE
FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS NINE ARE MADE
WITH THE NATIONAL WOMEN'S LAW
PROJECT IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
MAXALT CAROLINE THIRTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTER THIS IS
COLUMNS WITH THE KOREATOWN
IMMIGRANT WORKERS ALLIANCE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT
A LOT TIMELINE TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BLIND TWENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOU MAY
BE NEEDED ON YOUR END. HELLO
YES YEAH OKAY TO GET BEHIND THE
NUMBER BUT MANY THE WHAT THE
MONTH AT EAGLES I AM
REPRESENTING LOS ANGELES
ALLIANCE FOR A NEW ECONOMY LANE
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY FIFTY SIX. THANK YOU. AT
NINE THIRTY SHOW SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY FIFTY SIX PLEASE PRESS
THE ONE THAN THEIR OWN NOW.
AGAIN TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR A BI
THIRTY FIFTY SIX. ONE THEN NOW.
INTO THE SHOW NO ONE AND YOU AT
THE MOMENT VERY GOOD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
THOSE IN OPPOSITION SINCE WE'VE
HEARD FROM ALL OF THOSE IN
SUPPORT WE HAVE WILL LEAD
OPPOSITION THIS ROB MODE PRE
FROM THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE. YOU ON THE LINE. I AM
THANK YOU AGAIN- HELLO NOW GOOD
AFTERNOON TO EVERYONE AS WELL
THIS WILL BE THE LAST ONE SO MY
APOLOGIES FOR TAKING. SO MUCH
TIME I'LL TRY TO BE QUICK.
SECOND IT IS TRYING TO GO I
KNOW CAISSONS ARE. BETTER OFF
LAW. ON BEHALF OF RETAILERS I
BELIEVE- ALTERNATE THE ALKALINE
SORT THAT OUT. FORWARD BUT IF
YOU REALLY THINK THAT FOR THE
THROWN OUT THE COURTS PROBABLY
TREAT CALTRAIN OPPOSED. THIRTY
TO BE CLEAR IS NOT BASED ON OUR
OPPOSITION IS NOT ON ANY TO
DENY BREAKS WHICH I THANK LIKE
LABOR ALREADY FOR UNDER LAW
LIKE CAN'T FIX THAT IT'S THE-
WHAT I. THINK YOU WITH THAT.
AND THE ACTUAL STAFF NOW THAT
HIGHLIGHT THE VAGUENESS OF THIS
BILL IT GOING TO LEAD TO LIVE
FOR YOU EMPLOYERS AS THEY TRY
TO COMPLY BUT THE WALK YOU
THROUGH THAT AGAIN SO THAT THE
BILL REQUIRE QUOTE. I'M NOT IN.
BUT UNDER WHICH- IS PRESENT
STATE YOUR- THE THERE BUT ALL
CERTAIN ACTIVITY ARE YOU THIS
IS THE QUOTE COUNTY TOWARD THE
REQUIRE FOR HIM THE QUOTA BUT
ACTORS RIGHT IN PLACE OPPOSED
TO COURT UNDER WHICH CERTAIN
ACTIVITIES ARE COUNTED TOWARD
THE TOP PART. HOW TO MAKE
THEY'RE NOT TO PAY FOR BILITY.
WELL YOU KNOW WHAT THEY DON'T
HAVE PLAYED THAT THE END. THAT
THE. THAT THE AUTHOR REFERENCE
AT LEAST SEVEN IN WALK TO
RESTAURANT LET EMPLOYER
MEASURE THE TIME THE RESTAURANT
AND OKAY LOOKS LIKE IT'S SEVEN
MINUTES FOR THE PEOPLE OVER
HERE FORTY PEOPLE OVER HERE
WHENEVER THEY WALK TO THE
RESTAURANT. I'M GONNA TRY TO
TRACK READ BOXES. NOT WHATEVER
IT. THE RESCUE EVERY. SOUNDS
GOOD THE PROBLEM IS THAT UNDER
THIS BILL EVEN IF YOU DID THAT
YOU WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO SAY YOU
WERE SHIELDED HER LIABILITY BUT
LOOK AT THE BILL IS WRITTEN-
SIMPLY HAVING ANY KIND OF
PRODUCTION GOAL OR QUOTA. IS
GOING TO MAKE YOU FACE HI BILLY
THERE'S NO CLEAR PATH TO
COMPLIANCE THAT WOULD IT WOULD
BE. A CLEAR ENOUGH LINE TODAY
OKAY I'VE DONE THIS NOW I'VE
LEFT THE TIME FOR THESE THINGS
WHICH- AREN'T AND THEREFORE I
WON'T THIRTY FIVE. AND THAT
DEATH NOTED NEUTRAL OUTFITS
BAKER HERE. SO WHAT THE WHAT
THE CONCERNED WITH THE
CONSEQUENCES THAT THAT. THE
CONSEQUENCES THAT THIS BILL
INCLUDE. PENALTY PER INCIDENT
AND BECAUSE THE LABOR CODE.
PART OUT OF CONCERNS. WE'RE
SITTING TALKING CONCERN THE
PANEL. WHEN THERE'S NO PATH TO.
MAKE SURE THAT THEY REALLY CAN
COMPLY WITH THIS IN THAT IT YOU
CAN MEET STANDARD THAT THAT'S
THE KIND OF DRAFTING ISSUES ARE
QUITE SIGNIFICANT DOT THAT. AND
I APPRECIATE THAT NOW FOLLOWING
UP HERE'S ALTERNATIVES TO GET
THE SIMILAR GOALS OBVIOUSLY ARE
GONNA HELP IF SOMETHING IS
IMPORTANT AND CAL SHOT THE
PROTECTIONS THERE IT YOU KNOW
HOSTED AREA. BUT WE DON'T SEE
THIS BILL AS WRITTEN CLEARLY
ENOUGH TO ATTRACT THEM AND WE
DO BELIEVE IT'S WRITTEN IN A
WAY THAT WILL LEAD TO A LOT. B.
E. EMPLOYER THEIR BEST TO COME.
WHICH IS REALLY GOOD. SO THAT
RECENT IS RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
IT AB HE'S- AND HOPEFUL MISTER
ALL WHO ARE THAT YEAH USED OUT
HIS. THANK YOU YOUR THE LIONEL
USUALLY VERY GOOD AT WE HEAR
YOU. THE FOR C. THANK THANK YOU.
NUMBER THE- HELLO LEADERS YOU
SHOULD ALSO IN OPPOSITION. I'M
TIRED PRODUCTION MEASUREMENT
BEATING. OF WORK OR OR. OR SOME
OTHER PERFORMANCE REVIEW
PRODUCTION RATE YEAR KNOW. HE'S
FROM. PERRANCE ACCOUNTABILITY
AND SURPRISE OTHERS WITH.
EIGHTY ZERO SIX AFFECTING
RETAIL BROUGHT MEETING WHERE
OPERATION INCLUDE PER STANDARDS
PRODUCTION RATE DESIGNED BE
READ. IF YOUR ACCOUNT
REASONABLE RATE BEYOND. HOW
LONG CLINICS SCHOOL MORE
WITHOUT HAPPY. WELL ABILITY
EACH OTHER LEGAL LARGE SECOND
OF THE AT A TIME WHEN THERE IS
YES NEED FOR AN OPPORTUNITY.
UNFORTUNATELY I LITIGATION
REYES WOULD HELLO I AND FOR TO
IS ONLY GOING TO COME PRESSURE
ON WHERE. YOUR INITIAL ONE
CERTAINTY IN OUR COLLECTION AND
CARMEN PEOPLE ARE LITERALLY
SURVIVING ON THEIR ABILITY TO
HAVE A PRODUCT SHE DELIVERED
DIRECTLY TO THEIR HOMES. DID
YOU READ EVERY APPOINTEE BY THE
CHAMBER HELLO. STILL NEED EVERY
OPERATION REGARDLESS OF THEIR
EFFORTS TO COMPLY WITH FEDERAL
LIABILITY. NOW HERE'S YOUR
WIRES. HUNDRED YOU WANT. SHE
HAD IN THAT CONTEXT RATHER THAN
HOMES. EVEN THE OTHER STATES
DAS A CLOSING YOUR THANK YOU
MUCH VERY GOOD THANK YOU FOR
THE TEST OF WE PRE THAT NOW
WE'RE GOING TO THE TO WITNESSES
IN THE- YOUR THERE ARE NO WHICH
THERE FOR A IN ABA TO BE FIFTY
SO LOOKING AT. ROOM FORTY
ANYONE NO ONE THERE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION DAVEY
THIRTY FIFTY SIX SO NOW WE
WOULD PLEASE THE- NOW MOVES TO
THE WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY THE TELE. ORVIS
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE.
VIGIL WAITING. TO FIGHT UP. B.
THIRTY BASIC. WE WERE
APPRECIATE IT. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN TWO OF AB THIRTY
FIFTIES PLEASE PRESS THE ONE
VENDOR OWN NOW. IF YOU'RE IN
QUEUE OF PLEASE PRESS ONE THAT
THEIR OLD REMOVE. EIGHTY EIGHT.
RIGHT THEN THERE ARE NOW WELL
FOR POLITICAL THREE SIXTY EIGHT
WELL I HAD. WELL ACTUALLY
STERILIZE. THREE SIXTY CALL I
HAD. I APOLOGIZE THAT THEY GIVE
IT JUST A MOMENT. JENNIFER
OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHT THIRTY
FIFTY SIX THE LAW TO LINE TO
FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RIGHT AT THE THIRTY YEARS
CALIFORNIA. FOOD IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MAXILLA CAROLINE FIFTY PLEASE
ON LINE HAS DISCONNECTED AGAIN
TO UPHOLD AB THIRTY FIFTY SIX
TO PLEASE PRESS ONE TO END
THEIR OWN NOW. WEHAD NO ONE IN
THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME GOOD
THANK YOU. SO WE LISTEN TO
THOSE MEMBER THOSE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION TO WILL
NOW BRING IT BACK FOR
DISCUSSION OF THE COMMITTEE
SENATOR PAN P. RAISING YOUR
MICROPHONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND SEVERAL AND GETS ITS I'D
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO KEEP THE LIGHT
SIDE BY. QUITE WELL FIRST OF
ALL. DO YOU SEE THAT PATH THE
COMPLIANCE OF THE HOW TO BE
SURE OF EMPLOYER CAN IS
COMPLIANT WITH THIS BILL LOS.
EVEN SOME OF THE AND THEN THE
OTHER THING THAT WAS NOTED IN
ALSO THE ANALYSIS AS- WELL AS
THAT WELL WHAT POINT DOES THE
QUOTA ARE THESE MEASURES START
BECOMING LIKE PETE. EIGHT AND
IS THAT A LOT THAT ONE ONCE.
ACTUAL LOOK AT OUR FIGUREHEAD
OKAY SO YOU CAN SEE NOW TO
TERMS OF THE BREAD THAT WE PUT
INTO LAW. ONE TO ADDED OR.
DIETS RICH. SAME GOAL SO. UP
PERHAPS YOU TRUST. OKAY IT
ACTION AT OF YOU KNOW WE HAVE
RETALIATES LAWS WITH IT AND
ACTION TAKES MANY FOR AND
EMPLOYEE SHOULD BE ABLE TO GO
TO THE LEFT COMMISSION IF
ADVERSE ACTION HAS HAS TO I'M-
I IT NOT WORRIED ABOUT THE
ENFORCEMENT ASPECT BECAUSE
ITSELF ENFORCED BY. WELL I MEAN
I KNOW YOU'VE SEEN BILLS ON
THIS WE HAVE HAD A LONG HISTORY
OF ABUSE USE AND ABUSE OF
HISTORY IT IS QUICK I MEAN I
CAN EVEN. THERE THERE ARE SOME.
THAT HAS. IT ON. YOUNG STRONG
OF A- THE EMPLOYEES THAT I CAN
THINK IN PARTICULAR THERE ARE
SOME FARMWORKERS TO DO FAR
BETTER UNDER P. THREE THEN THEY
COULD UNDER NAP EARLY RATE BUT
IT'S ALL HOW. ABUSED THREE KEYS
ACT PASSED OF A BOX THE SAME
YOU'RE YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT YOU
KNOW YOU COULD BE PACKING
SOMETHING THAT THAT WEIGHS LESS
THAN A POUND OR YOU COULD BE
PACKING SOMETHING THAT HE'S-
FIVE. AND SO. I DON'T THINK
THAT THE JOB REALLY LINES UP TO
A PIECE RATE KIND OF SITUATION-
AND ALL THE REPORTS WERE
INDICATING THAT THEY'RE USING
QUOTA SYSTEM THAT'S WHAT THESE
WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT TELLING
WAREHOUSES HAVE. NOT T. QUOTA
SYSTEM. INTENTIONALLY COOL AND
CRUDE BUT IF THEY'RE GOING TO
USE IT AT LEAST MAKE EXCEPTIONS
FOR BASIC HUMAN BEHAVIOR THAT
THAT GOES FOR THAT'S WHAT WE
THINK IN THEY CAN CHOOSE NOT TO
USE THE STOCK MARKET OF FIND
SOME OTHER WAY OF EVALUATING IF
AN EMPLOYEE IS A IS DOING THEIR
JOB SO I GUESS JUST. IN THE CAR
YOU SOURCE IN. THE OPPOSITION
SAYING THAT. WHAT'S THE PAST US
BEING SURE AND LEICESTER'S
ESSENTIALLY SAYING THAT THIS IS
EFFECTIVELY BANNING ANY SORT OF
QUOTA SYSTEMHERE WHICH I
UNDERSTAND YOU'RE NOT. SO YES
EMPLOYEE CAN PLAY COMPLAINT.
WELL WHAT HOW DOES THE EMPLOYER
ENSURE THAT. THEY'RE IN
COMPLIANCE I THINK THIS THE
CONCERN THAT WAS RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION AND EVEN AND
ANALYSIS HOW CAN USE EMPLOYER
WHO WANTS TO BE IN COMPLIANCE.
ASSURE THAT THEY ARE IN COMPLY
GIVEN SOME OF THE VARIABLES
THAT- ARE OF THAT HAVE TO BE
SORTED OUT SO IF THEY DO A TIME
MOTION STUDY IN IT SEVEN
MINUTES TODAY I MEAN IT IS THAT
GOOD ENOUGH FOR SO THAT WHEN. I
WAS A IN STATE IT ALL THE STUFF
AND WE FOLLOWING THE LAW I
THINK THE QUESTION THAT THE-
OBVIOUS. KILEY I MEAN THESE
THESE WHERE. ARE HIGHLY
DIGITIZED RIGHT THERE IS A
REASON THEY KNOW WHAT WINNER.
TASK IF YOU TIME OFF TASK. THEY
THEY CAN THEY CAN ACTUALLY
DIGITIZE TAKING I CAN CLOCK OUT
BECAUSE I'M GOING TO THE
RESTROOM AND CLOCK BACK AGAIN
IN THAT. COUNT IT'S ME I MEAN I.
NUMBER WAIT THEY ALLOW FOR
THEIR IN. ABLE TO TAKE TIME
THEY CAN USE ALL SUPER. YOU
KNOW TO. I'M SO BUILT WITHIN
SYSTEM THE THREE NOW WILL
DIGITIZE BASIC. THEY COULD
PROVIDE THAT. TO CLOCK OUT FOR
THOSE OF. TIMES THEY COULD TALK
TO THEIR EMPLOYEES RATHER THE
ISSUE THEM- ADVERSE ACTION.
POLICE SAY EIGHT WE SEE THAT
YOU NEEDED ME. THESE QUOTAS ARE
SORRY I YOU KNOW. I DON'T GET
TO CREATE ON WHITE WHITE PEOPLE
OF BUT YOU KNOW WOMEN IN
PARTICULAR I IN WE DID HAVE
SOME CASES WILL. I YOU KNOW IT.
THERE THEY NEED TO GO TO THE
BACK. NOBODY SHOULD HAVE TO
WEAR YOU KNOW A DIAPER WORRY
ABOUT LEADING THROUGH DURING
THAT TIME OF MONTH AND THEY-
KNOW THE RIGHT. THEY MIGHT NEED
A FEW EXTRA MINUTES AND YOU
KNOW IT IT'S LEADING TO.
SOMEBODY THAT THEY CAN TAKE
THAT TIME. BUT THEY ALSO NEED
TO TALK TO THEIR EMPLOYEES IF
SOMEBODY IS USING THAT TIME
BEFORE THEY THEY GIVE AN
ADVERSE ACTION AND THAT. THE
YOU JUST. THANK YOU. AN AFTER
THREE. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
LARGE CORPORATIONS HERE THIS
ISN'T FOR SMALL RETAILERS THIS
IS FOR WAREHOUSE DISTRIBUTION
CENTERS THAT EMPLOY OVER A
HUNDRED PEOPLE AND WE KNOW FOR
THE MOST PART IT REALLY IT TOO
LOW ASIAN THAT IS RIGHT NOW AND
THEY'RE CORPORATION QUITE
FRANKLY IF KIND OF ASTONISHING
THAT WE'RE TALKING WITHIN A BIG.
HAVING THIS KIND OF CRUEL.
APPROACH TO THEIR WORK FORCE
AND SO I THINK THAT THERE ARE-
THEY'VE COME UP WITH THIS
AMAZING DIGITIZED WAY TO FIGURE
OUT HOW QUICKLY SOMEBODY IS
WORKING HOW MUCH WORK THEY ARE
DOING SOME KIND OF WORKING CAN.
HAD ALL THE EMPLOYEE TO CLASS.
SO IT'S A- THAT BUT WASN'T TALK
ABOUT HOW TO MAKE YOU SO NOT TO
SAY THAT WE WILL TO DO PIECE.
NOW I JUST LOOK AT. MECHANISMS
FOR. CREATING PROTECTION. REAL
THAT THESE RATES THE- WITH THAT.
BUT TRYING TO. ABOUT HOW WE
BRING SOME OF THAT OPENING.
PERSONAL FEEL ABOUT P. BUT IT
ON A ON A- ALSO JUST THE WAY
THAT THEIR POWER. BOX IT'S NOT
LIKE INSERT SEVENTY CALLER ARE
KNOW I MEAN THERE IS. NOT THE
SAME ACTION OVER NUMBER WANTED
IF THEY WERE TO DO. FIGURE OUT.
BILLS FOR A- THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FAN OF THE QUESTION I WHAT
I JUST TO. THE CAN YOU REALLY
FOR HIGHLIGHTED IN THAT I THINK
NEED SOME OF AND IT'S A IT'S
REALLY APPROACH AND I FOR THAT
YOU REMOVE THE PREEMIE PAILAN
FROM THE BILL. AND THE AND NOW
DOES. SHOW AND NOW OF OTHER AIR
SO HOPEFULLY YOU WILL BE WILL
TO. LOOK AT SOME USED TO. THEM
PROVED MAY. SO IT ISSUES THAT
DOES SENATOR PAT MAY AND THAT
RAISED IN AS WE GO FOR SO
REALLY OF. THAT THE WITH THE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO AT THREE SO
LAST NIGHT I WROTE VERY GOOD
THANK YOU FOR MUCH OF THE- DO
WE HAVE A MO. THIS VERY THANK
YOU WE HAVE A FROM JOE. IN THIS
IS TO PASS TO APPROVE. AS OF.
PENNED UP PLEASE THE ROAD.
SENATE HILL HI THERE HILLS HIGH
SENATOR MY. MORALE NO CENTER MY
NO SENATOR JACK HI SENATOR. HI
SENATOR MITCH MITCHELL I
SENATOR MAY. HI SO PAYING HI
SENATOR PAM HI THE HAS FOR VOTE
IN THE OUT WE WILL NOW TO YOUR
FI BILL. I DON'T TWENTY SEVEN
AB SO FIVE MY FINAL BILL AND
IT'S BECAUSE I A HAVE WANTED TO
DO THIS BILL SINCE I MY
PREVIOUS LIFE AS A LEADER WHEN
WE WOULD SEE ADD COMPANIES
ENGAGE IN COMPLETE AND TOTAL
WAIT STAFF GET GET ACTUALLY
CAUGHT FOR IT GET A JUDGMENT A
FINAL JUDGMENT AGAINST THEM AND
IT BY THEIR WORKERS NOT PAID
THEIR WORKERS BUT JUST START A
NEW COMPANY. THAT THE COMPANY
WOULD GO OUT OF BUSINESS SAME
THIRDS WOULD START A NEW
COMPANY AND OFTEN THE SAME
CLIENTS. IN JANET BUSINESS AND
PER WITH CA SO I WAS X. WHEN WE
FIGURE OUT A WAY HOW. TO THE
SITUATION AND MORE EXCITED I
HAVE TO SAY BECAUSE IT'S LIKE
ME I GET SAY THIS AND ACT NOW
IS I GOT. COMMERCE TO. IT WAS
ON THE JOB LESS AND NOW THEY'RE
NEUTRAL SO LIKE. AS BAD AS MY
GOOD FOR FROM SANTA KNOWS THE
REALLY TOUGH TO DO. AND I DON'T
THINK I'VE HAD IT DONE SO WITH
THAT. BASICALLY WHAT IT SAYS IS
IF YOU NAMED IN A FIRE JUDGE.
OF THE WAY THAT CASE IT DID NOT
PAY YOUR EMPLOYEES DO NOT MAKE
THEM. THEY THEN YOU CAN. START
A NEW CORP. PRIEST AND IF YOU
DO START ME CORP CAN IT'S A
COURT. AT THE MOVE AND SOMEBODY
FIND OUT OF IT THAT THEIR STUFF
THEIR LIABILITY SO THAT NEW
CORPORATE HAVE TO PAY OFF THAT
DEBT. THAT THE BILL. IS IT IS.
WE HAVE ONE WHICH- IN A. NEED
WITNESSES TIA CONES FROM THE
YOU LABOR'S ARE YOU A THE PHONE.
YES AND CAN YOU ME WONDER WE
HEAR YOU PLEASE FOR WHEN READY.
GREAT THANK YOU. LABOR CENTER
WE ESTIMATE THE AVERAGE WERE IN
BUT WE CAN GET TREAT IT LOUIS
DAY 12% THEIR PAY TO WAGE THAT
THE PERVASIVE. IN TEN WHO OVER
PAY OR THE RIGHT PAGE BREAKS OR
WASHER. DON'T RECEIVE IT AND
WHAT THREE AT LESS THAN MINIMUM
WAGE. WHAT WE KNOW IS THAT
COULD MAKE ONLY. TRYING TO
OPERATION LOW WAGE WORKERS AND
ALMOST ALL OF IF AND OCCUPY ARE.
OBJECTIONS RECEIVED ANY PAYMENT
WHAT HOWEVER AND EMPLOYER TAKES.
YOU INTEND HEY AT IT SO EARLY
IN PROCESS SHUTTLING SOME POINT
BEFORE A JUDGING ORDERS AND PAY
NO ONE AFTER. AND UP WITH JUDGE
BROWN WAGES YOU HAVE TEN DAYS
TO PAY YOUR WHAT. PLAN LABOR
COMMISSIONER FIND THAT YOU
VIOLATED. MEDIAN HOURLY BACK.
FINANCIAL FLAT. MANY ASSEMBLY
PAID THREE HUNDRED BUCKS
COMPILED NEW ARTICLES OF
INCORPORATION WITH THE
SECRETARY OF STATE AND THEN
TRANSFER THEIR ASSETS TO THE
COMPANY. MANY OF TRANSFERRED
THE COMPANY TO A FAMILY MEMBER
OR TO A MANAGER. JUST A
JUDGMENT DEBTOR. IS ALMOST
LAUGHABLE FEATURED MULTIPLE
VARIATIONS OF THE SAME NAME
ONLY CONSTRUCTION. A
CONSTRUCTION. CONSTRUCTION
COMMA LOC. THING COMPANY
OFFERING THE SAME SERVICES
THANK CUSTOMERS. I THINK WE
THAT FRIDAY TAKES A HUNDRED BUT
OCCASIONALLY TO PROVE IT. STILL
MAKES IT HARDER TO EBAY THAT
LIABILITY FIRST. WHEN I STARTED
IN CALIFORNIA WILL HAVE TO
DECLARE THAT THEY DON'T HAVE
ANY NINETY ALL. IT'S GONNA
FOLLOW IN WHO TRIED IT DOT
LIABILITY BY TRANSFERRING
COMPANY WHAT THE FAMILY MEMBER
MANAGER ARM BUT BUSINESS
CONTINUES TO PROVIDE THE SAME
SERVICES THING CUSTOMERS AT THE
SAME FACILITY AND ARE CLEARLY
FRAUDULENT. PLEASE BILL PUT
MORE BOOTS ON THE GROUND CLEAR.
THAT LOCAL BEACH OFFICE SHARE
JURISDICTION OVER THE LABOR
CODE ANY TIME TWENTY TWO LOCAL
OFFICES THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
GOOD FOR CLAIMS THE CON AND BUY
A MISSIONS LIKE MEAL BREAKS AND
UNPAID OVERTIME AND CHECK. OKAY
THE TEAM COME OF THE TOPIC. AND
YOU SO MUCH AND I LOOK. TO
BRINGING YOU MIGHT HAVE. VERY
GOOD THANK YOU FOR THE TEST OF
A AT. WE MUCH APPRECIATE TODAY
AND NOW WE WILL LOOK FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY SEVENTY FIVE IN THE
GALLERY SEE NO ONE IN THE
GALLERY WILL GO TO TWENTY FORTY
SEE IF THERE'S ANY NO ONE.
FORTY FORTY THIRTY SEVENTY WHO
TWO WITNESSES WAITING TO TALK
TO VIA TELECONFERENCE HIS
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN. COURT OF AB
THIRTY SEVENTY FIVE AND THANK
YOU FOR THE WONDERFUL JOB
YOU'RE DOING TODAY. THANK YOU.
LADIESAND GENTLEMEN TO SUPPORT
AB THIRTY SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NOW. IF YOU
ARE ALREADY IN THE QUEUE AND
YOU WISH TO UPHOLD PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO TO REMOVE
YOURSELF. AGAIN THIS IS FOR THE-
HE THIRTY SEVENTY FIVE. AND WE
DO HAVE ABOUT TWENTY THE KEEL
WILL AFFECT WHAT LINE THREE
EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON NO AT BOTTOM ALL
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION. OR
THANK YOU. MAXALT ONLINE AT
FOUR FIFTY THREE PEOPLE I HAD.
KATHY WALL WITH A PARTITION FOR
WORKING FAMILIES IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MAXALT SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ZERO **** CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. KNECHTEL ONLINE FOR
FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
EVERYONE THOUGHT IT GETS WHAT
THE CLEAN CAR WASH CAMPAIGN IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY SEVENTY
FIVE THANK YOU. MATT PHILLIPS
NINE FOUR FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU RENEE BY ARTUR
WITH YEAH YOU CALIFORNIA WHERE
COSPONSORED ANSWERS SPORT THANK
YOU. MACROPHYLLA CAROLINE THREE
FIFTY THREE PLEASE CALL I HAD.
HELLO IT ALL WITH IT BUT I
THINK WHATEVER SAYS AND WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MACK HELLO CAROLINE
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
MAKE IT OUR TEAM WOULD BEGIN OF
AND THAT'S CALIFORNIA WE ARE
CLOSED FONG THE BILL ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. A LOT. ONE NINE. CLEVELAND
HAD. LINE ONE NINETEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN HE MAY BE NEEDED
ON YOUR END. ALL RIGHT NEXT
LEVEL TO LINE FOR SIXTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I THINK YOU ARE MY
NAME IS CARLOS COMMITTEE ORKER
CENTER OF MOUNTAIN VIEW AND I
GAVE ME THIRTY SEVENTY FIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. MAXALT TO
LINE ONE FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WE HAVE AN EQUAL RIGHT
ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANKS A LOT TO LINE FOR SIXTY
TWO PLEASE GO I HAD. ROAD OVER
TOTAL SANTA CLARA COUNTY WAIT
STAFF COALITION HOLD ON THERE
AND BE STRONG REPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU. MAX THE AUTO LINE
FOR FIFTY EIGHT R. THIRTY FOUR
BETTER YET LITTLE TO LINE FOR
FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MARIN ALINA WITH THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY FEDERATION OF
LABOR IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTY SEVEN FIVE. THANK YOU.
MAXALT ONLINE FOR FIFTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. POLLUTION
FAHMI ABD THE NATIONAL
NONPROFIT PREVENTION INTO COURT
SB THIRTY SEVEN. THANK YOU. IN
FACT A LOT OF FOUR FORTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
NINE TORNADO WITH THE NATIONAL
PLAN THAT LED PROJECT IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MAX THE AUTO
AND ONE EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LINE ONE EIGHTY YOU MAY BE
NEEDED YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IN
FACT THE LAW TO LINE FOR SIXTY
THREE PLEASE CALL I HAD. HELLO
ABIGAIL OTHERNESS BUT THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN SUPPORT. MAXILLA TO
LINE ONE FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MEDIA THE NEEDS THAT ARE
WORKING WITH THE WAREHOUSE
WORKER RESEARCH CENTER AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT AT THIRTY
SEVENTY FIVE. MAX THE LOCAL
LINE SEVENTY THREE PLEASE CALL
HAD. I MADE A MISTAKE MIGHT
HAVE BEEN ASSOCIATION OF 4% IN
THE GRANT AND I AM IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANKS A LOT TALK
AND FOR TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MALLORY BUT WORKING
FOR PUBLIC COUNTY ONE LOS
ANGELES IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
SEVENTY FIVE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT IN LINE Q. FORTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE NEED
A- RESULT WE ENTAIL POLY I'M
HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
SEVENTY FIVE. THANK YOU. MAXALT
TO LINE FOR SIXTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS WHAT
THE SHERMAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTHY NAIL SALON
COLLABORATIVE AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MATRAVILLE
LOCAL LINE THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES CAN YOU HEAR ME
THREE AND HE CAN. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS BRADY COLLINS
WITH THE COURAGE UNABLE TO
WORKERS ALLIANCE FOR CO
SPONSORING THE BILL IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THE
METROPOLITAN LINE ONE EIGHTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALIGN ALIGN AB
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU. OKAY SO WE
KNOW SOMEONE BEING OUT OF THE
FILIPINO EDUCATION A WORKER IN
THE GROUND AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
CEMEX ALLOWED TO LINE ONE
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU
AYE LONG NECKER THAT LEFT IN
LOOK WORKERS CENTER NETWORK
WHERE ONE OF THE SPONSORS IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THEN
AS A REMINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTY SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE PRESS THE ONE BUTTON
ZERO NOW AGAIN SUPPORT. FOR
EIGHTEEN THIRTY SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THAN THEIR OWN
NOW. WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE THANK
YOU AT THE MOMENT VERY GOOD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL NOW
GO TO HEAR. THOSE IN SUPPORT
WILL NOW GO THIS IS A OPPOSITE.
I HAVE A ONE LISTED. AS A LEAD.
SPOKESPERSON FOR OPPOSITION SO
WE WILL GO TO THE GALLERY IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE GALLERY
WISHING TO SPEAK AT POSITION
SEEING NO ONE ON THE THIRTY
SEVEN FIVE INTO TWENTY FORTY.
ONE TO. YOUR POSITION TO THIRD.
FIVE THE MODERATOR WE WILL MOVE
THE TELLER. SERVICE AND PLEASE
PROP THOSE INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO AB.
THREE THIRTY SEVENTY FIVE. AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO UPHOLD
AB THIRTY SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE
PRESS THE ONE BUTTON ZERO NOW.
AGAIN TO UPHOLD AB THIRTY
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
BEEN THERE ON NOW. IN THE MEDIA
NOT SHOW ANYONE IN THE QUEUE.
GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR
WE'VE HEARD FROM THOSE IN
SUPPORT AND ANYONE WHO WAS
WILLING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY TO NOW WE
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR. A DISCUSSION OF
QUESTION SENATOR PAN. A GREAT
BILL. MOVED BILL VERY GOOD
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
ANYONE NOT SEEN ANY YES GREAT
BILL THANK YOU FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD- SO WE HAVE A WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE- I JUST AFTER AND
I FELT VERY GOOD THANK YOU
APPRECIATE THAT IS OUR MOTION.
SENATOR PAN WE HAVE A MOTION TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL FAIR MISTER
CONSULTANT. SENATOR HILL HI
SENATOR HILL HI SENATOR MORALE.
NOT VOTING CENTER MORALE
NONVOTING SENATOR JACKSON
JACKSON LIFE SENATOR JACKSON HI
SENATOR MITCHELL MITCHELL I'D
SENATOR MITCHELL HI SENATOR PAN
FAN I CENTER PAN HI. THE BILL
HAS FOUR VOTES IT IS OUT WILL
NOW MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER FOUR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SHOWN A. B.
ELEVEN FORTY. WELCOME. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND SENATORS
THIS BILL IS A DISTRICT BILL WE
HAVE TO FIRE DEPARTMENTS THAT
FOR ALL THE RIGHT REASONS ARE
CONSOLIDATE HAS THE DISTRICTS
HAVE DONE THEIR BEST WORKING
COMMUNITY WITH EMPLOYEES THE
BOARDS OF THE TWO FIRE
TENDENCIES COME TO AN AGREEMENT
HOW THE CANCER PATIENT CARE AND
SHOULD HAPPEN IT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S WORKED UP LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS AND IS IT IS VERY TIME
BECAUSE- A CLOSE. TO DEALS.
HOWEVER THERE WERE WITH CURSED
BECAUSE BOTH EVEN OF THE TO DO
AGE HAVE TWO DIFFERENT PLANTS
AND UNDER THE LAW PERS CANNOT
WRITE A CONTRACT WITH THE NEW
AGENCY THAT HAS DISPARATE ANY
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE
BENEFITS FROM ONE EMPLOYEE
GROUP OR THE OTHER EMPLOYEE
GROUPS NOW THIS IS HAPPENED IN
THE PAST AND IT TAKES
LEGISLATION TO HELP HER TO BE A
TO WRITE THAT CAR. WE'RE ON A
LINE RIGHT BECAUSE WE CANNOT.
GET THIS BILL PASSED. AND HAVE
THE CONSOLIDATION HAPPENED ON
THE TIME LINE THAT THEY HAD FOR
J. THEN WHAT THE BOY THAT WILL
BE BEANS OFFER THOSE MEMBERS ON
THAT BOARD. BUT WILL STILL HAVE
TO. STAND FOR ELECTION COME
THIS FALL WHICH WOULD BE AN
EXPENSE THAT WOULD BE
UNNECESSARY AND PLACE BURDENS
ON THE DISTRICTS IN THE
CONSOLIDATED DISTRICT IN SUCH A
WAY THAT IT IS REALLY NOT
BENEFITS SO. WE WERE PRETTY
CLOSELY WITH PERSON AND I WANT
TO THANK THE EXECUTIVES AT
PURSE FOR COMING UP WITH A
PRETTY CLEVER IDEAS YOU'LL
NOTICE THE WITH THIS BILL DOES.
IS IT- WOULD ALLOW THE
CONSOLIDATE AGENCY TO HAVE
THOSE TWO PLANTS WHICH IS WHAT
WE ALLOWED BY STATUTE. BUT IT
ALSO MAKES A RETROACTIVE TO
JULY FIRST OF THIS YEAR. THAT'S
THE MECHANISM THAT ALLOWS THE
PLAN TO MOVE FORWARD AND AS
LONG AS THIS BILL PASSES WHICH
I CERTAINLY HOPE IT DOES TODAY.
THEN BY THE TIME THE AGENCY
TAKES ITS APPLICATION TO
PURPOSE WILL BE ABLE TO. MAKE
SURE THAT THE CITY WORK. BETTER
IN PLACE OF PLEASE DON'T LOSE
THE BENEFIT. THAT THEY
BARGAINED FOR IN THE PAST. AND
READ TO THIS TRUCKS. SO THIS IS
A BILL THAT REALLY HELLO. VERY
GOOD DECISION A GOOD COND. TO
MOVE FORWARD AND WE WORKED IT
THROUGH BOTH WITH THE THAT THE
PEOPLE IN THE DISTRICT AND THE-
VOTERS IN THE DISTRICT THE-
EMPLOYEES IN THE DISTRICT THE
FIRE CHIEFS. THE BOARDS OF
DIRECTORS OF THE DISTRICT AND
NOW WE GOT THIS GREAT IDEA FROM
PERSON TO BE ABLE TO ALLOW THIS
TO GO FORWARD SO VERY VERY
HOPEFUL THAT THIS BILL WILL
PASS THIS COMMITTEE. THAT WE
CAN GET THIS DONE THIS YEAR AND
THEN AS LONG AS IT DOES THIS
CONSOLIDATION WILL HAPPEN AND
THAT WILL BE A VERY GOOD THING
FOR THE EFFICIENT. OUR
MANAGEMENT OF FIRE. SERVICES
BETWEEN THESE TWO AGENCIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. AND I AGREE IT'S A VERY
GOOD BILLS SEVEN MEMBERS PHONE
WE HAVE TO MAKE IT EASIER
WITNESSES- THAT HAVE A TOTAL OF
EIGHT MINUTES BETWEEN THEM
CHRISTY VOEPEL PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS. YOUR IN THE
GALLERY. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE KRISTIE BELL HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS AND I
THINK I HAVE A LOCAL
FIREFIGHTER LEADER FROM THE
DISTRICT TO SPEAK FAVOR OF. ON
THE LINE VERY GOOD THANK YOU
ALSO WE HAVE CARL STEINMETZ. I
BELIEVE IS ON THE LINE FOR THAT
YET YES PLEASE PER CBS THAT
PRESIDENT. ALL RIGHT DAD GOOD
EVENING SATURDAY ALL MEMBERS OF
STAFF LABOR AND PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT RETIREMENT COMMITTEE
MY NAME CALL SENATE THEM
PRESIDENT ABOUT POSSIBLE LOCAL
SERVER THIRTY FIVE THIRTY FIVE.
AND THANK YOU FOR CALLING
SPEAKERS COURT EIGHTY FORTY.
THIS BILL WOULD MAKE AN
IMPORTANT OCCASION OF OUR BRING
THE CONSOLIDATION OF LOCAL
AGENCIES ALLOWING FOR THE
CONSOLIDATION OF APPLE SOFTWARE
PROTECTION DISTRICT AND CENTRAL
PARK. DISTRICT CONSOLIDATION
AMONG. THE COMING UP. BUT A LOT
OF SMALLER ENGINE TO DROP
GATHER TO CHEAT CON. RIGHT
QUALITY PARTS SERVICE. YOU KNOW
YOU CAN ACROSS JURISDICTIONAL.
THE CURRENT LAW GOVERNING YOU
CAN MAKE IT CLEAR THAT WENT TO
LARGE ALL OTHER THAT WOULD
AGENTS BECOME THE ABA THE NEW
WEEK A- ADDITIONALLY THE PUBLIC
AND TIME WALKING PROVISIONS
THAT ALLOW FOR THAT ALL THE AND
ALLOWING ACCESS NEEDS ME
CONTRACT WITHIN CALPERS HOWEVER
ON GO BURGER APPLE SILVA AND
GENTLE SHUTTLE DISH CLEAR ON
NEEDED TO ENSURE THAT THE
SUCCESSOR. ABLE TO MAINTAIN THE
BENEFIT OFF FOR HARD BUT- AND
OTHER EMPLOYEES WHO DON'T. WILL
TRAIN FROM THERE INDEED
AGENCIES THE SIX. ELEVEN FORTY
TWELVE I COULD CONSOLIDATION
ONLY WILL CLARIFY DISK EIGHT HE
CREATED BY THE MERGER OF THE
TWO DISTINCT CALPERS
CONTRACTING AGENCIES IS NOT THE
NEW AGENCY. THIS ALL OUT FOR
THE SIX THE CONTACT. IN THE
BENEFITS FOR EMPLOYEES. COME
FROM THE ORIGINAL LANES WALK.
THEIR KARMA. AFTER AFTER THE
NEW HIRES. AB ELEVEN FORTY. TO
SOLVE THE ONLY REMAINING ISSUES
STANDING IN OUR WAY
CONSOLIDATION ELEVEN FORTY WILL
ALLOW SUCCESSFUL CONSOLIDATION
PUBLIC SO THAT. JACKSON THIS
WITHOUT TALKING HOME TO THE PER.
ELEVEN FORTY WILL AND NOW ANTI
CLEAR. IT'S FULLY SUPPORT BY
BOTH CONSULTING. CONSOLIDATED A
LABOR AND MANAGED AS WELL AS
CALPERS BOARD OF ADMINISTRATION
FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK TO SUPPORT A
LATIN FORTY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU FOR YOUR DOES.
LOOK FOR A ELSE IN THE GALLERY
WISHING TO SPEAK TO PORT OF AB
ELEVEN FORTY PLEASE. GOOD WHERE
THE MICROPHONE IS SHE CAN'T
HEAR YOU. CAN HAVE THEIR AGO.
ANDREW WHITE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT SYSTEM IN SUPPORT.
OKAY SO MUCH ANYWHERE ELSE IN
THE GALLERY SEE NO ONE THE TO
TWENTY FORTY IS THERE ANYONE IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN
FORTY SEE NO ONE. HELLO FORTY
WE WILL NOW GO TO THE- VIA THAT
TESTIMONY. IN SUPPORT OF AB
ELEVEN FORTY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS MODERATOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE PROMPT THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WILLING JUST
WANTING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB ELEVEN FORTY. SURE AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN. WHO SHOWS
UP FOR BI A LOT FORD PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NOW AGAIN
THE REPORT PER AB ELEVEN FORTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN NOW. AT
THE MOMENT WE DID NOT SHOW
ANYONE IN THE QUEUE BADBURY
MINE THERE TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR
A BI ELEVEN FORTY PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN THEIR OWN NOW AGAIN I
AM ZERO FOUR SUPPORT FOR ABA.
ELEVEN FORTY. AND WE DID NOT
SHOW ANYONE IN HERE GOOD THANK
YOU MODERATOR WE WILL NOW GO TO
THE OPPOSITION THERE'S NO LEAD
OPPOSITION SPEAKER A WITNESS
TODAY. SO WE WILL LOOK TO THE
GALLERY IS THERE ANYONE AND
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO A BILL LEVIN FORTY THE
NUMBER ONE GOAL TO ROOM TWENTY
EITHER ONE AND- FORTY.
MYSTIFYING OPPOSITION TO AB
ELEVEN FORTY VIA TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS WOULD YOU PLEASE PROMPT
THOSE INDIVIDUALS. WERE WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO AB
ELEVEN FORTY. SHARE HOW MAY BE
EVEN DOWN A MAN TO A POLLS AB
ELEVEN FORTY PLEASE PRESS THE
ONE AND THEN ZERO NOW. AGAIN TO
UPHOLD EIGHT ELEVEN FORTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN THERE
NOW. AND I DO NOT SHOW ANYONE
IN CUBA AS A REMINDER TO UPHOLD
AB ELEVEN FORTY PLEASE PRESS
THE ONE AND THEN ZERO NOW. WE
SHOW NO ONE IN Q. THANK YOU
MODERATOR OF THAT AND GIVING
EVERYONE AN OPPORTUNITY THOSE
IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION WE
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR. COMMENT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH COME
ANY OTHER DISCUSSION OF.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SHARON REGIONAL
BECAUSE I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
HELP THANK. YOU MUCH WE DO HAVE
A MOTION FROM. IN THE PAST TWO
FOR. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CONSULTANT MEMBERS PLEASE TURN
ON YOUR MICROPHONES IN ORDER TO
CAST A VOTE SENATOR HILL HI
SENATOR HILL HI SENATOR MORALE.
HI SENATOR MOREAU HI SENATOR
JACKSON. JACKSON AYE SENATOR
JACKSON BY SENATOR MITCHELL
MITCHELL AYE SENATOR MITCHELL
HI SENATOR PAN AND I SENATOR
PEYTON HI. THAT BILL IT HAS
FIVE FOCUS EDITORS OUT THANK
YOU SEVENTY MEMBERS TO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I DO NOT SEE
HIS. BILL I DO SEE THIS VOTE
THERE SHE IS. MY APOLOGIES.
THIS. IS WE'RE NOT GOING TO
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB FIFTEEN
TWELVE GOOD AFTERNOON WELCOME
HI GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU
PLEASE PROCEED AT YOUR
CONVENIENCE THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'M HERE 2%
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN. PROVIDE
A CLEAR DUE TO THE SECURITY
INDUSTRY AND ENSURE THAT WE
BETTER PROTECT OUR WORKERS AND
A PUBLIC SAFETY BY PROVIDING
GUIDANCE TO EMPLOY. SECURITY
OFFICERS OFTEN ARE THE FIRST TO
RESPOND TO AN EMERGENCY MS AND
THEN CALL. INS FROM POLICE AND
FIRE- FOLLOWED BY A SERVICE
WHENEVER. THEY ARE AN ASSET.
COMPONENT TO OUR PUBLIC IN THE
NATURE OF THE WORK OFTEN
REQUIRES THAT THEY ARE PRESENT
AT ALL TIMES AB THING TWELVE.
THIRTY OFFICERS UNDER A
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT
TO REMAIN ON PREMISE AND
MONITOR RATED RADIOS DURING
THOSE PERIODS AND WILL PERMIT
THE SECURITY OFFICER TO RESUME
THE REST PERIOD. AS SOON AS IS
PRACTICAL SHOULD. BE
INTERRUPTED ADDITIONALLY ON IT
WORK THE SECURITY OFFICERS NOT
PERMITTED TO TAKE AN
UNINTERRUPTED REST BREAK. ABOUT
LEAST TEN MINUTES BEFORE OUR
WORKED IN THE SECURITY OF CHAU
EIGHT ONE A HOUR OKAY AT THE
RATE EARLY RATE. WE LIVED
THROUGH THE COLD AT NINETEEN
UNDER MY COMMERCIAL AND HIGH
RISE BUILDINGS THAT ARE MOSTLY
VACANT BECAUSE OF STAY AT HOME
ORDERS AS WELL AS HOSPITALS
THAT ARE OVER. WELL AND WITH.
POSITIVE. ASIANS ARE WITH THEY
WORK THROUGH. AN INTERRUPTER
BREAKS THIS BILL WILL PROVIDE
PERFECT FOR THE EMPLOYER. ON A
PROCESS SHOULD THEY NEED TO
ENTER. A SECURE GUARD BREAST.
HERE TO TESTIFY BY PHONE R.
KELLY WITH CALIFORNIA SAYS OF
WHY SECURE. EIGHT I AGENTS
GARDEN IF THOSE AND NEIGHBORED
BY OUT OF THE WITH A FEW CAL.
THIRTY THANK YOU FOR THAT AND
THE TWO WITNESSES WILL HAVE A
TOTAL OF A SPREE. MR CANCELING
YOUR ON THE LINE. THANK YOU CAN
HELP MEMBERS BY KELLY JENSEN
REPRESENT CAL THE SECURITY
GUARD IN AND STRONG OF AB
FIFTEEN TWELVE. THIS IS AN
LABOR MANAGE BILL TO FOR
PROTECTION FOR WORKERS AND KERR
OR IN. THE REST PERIODS
SECURITY GUARDS BEEN ON THE FOR
LINE OF COPE WITH NINETEEN.
RESPOND THIS ADDRESSES TO MAN
AND COMPENSATE WHEN A SECURITY
WHAT IS GOING ON. IN ALL EMERGE
SWITCH IT IS A VERY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE- FOR GOOD THE.
CALIFORNIA ONGOING SUPPORT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I THINK LAID
OUT THE ARGUMENTS FOR VERY
PERFECTLY- THIS WEEK WHICH IS
ASSOCIATED WITH A COMICAL I
WOULD JUST ADD THAT WE CAN
CONSULTED WITH OUR MEMBERS. AND
ATTEND TO MEDITATE AROUND THE
WITH THEY THEY THEM VERY MUCH
ASPERGER'S IN THE THAT PUBLIC
ARE YOU AND THEY WANT BE ABLE
TO HELP PEOPLE WHEN THEY'RE
NEED OF ABOUT THREE TO FOUR WE
SUPPORT. JUST POINT OUT A
COUPLE OF THE- IT'S ONLY FIVE
OR THERE'S A. MISTER B. R. WILL
NOW MOVE TO ANY ONE THE GALLRY
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB FIFTEEN TWELVE SEE NO ONE
LOOKING TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
THERE'S NO ONE THERE TO SHIP-
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB FIFTEEN TWELVE WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO THE WITNESSES WAITING
TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB. FIFTEEN
TWELVE. SURE AND MAYBE EVEN
GENTLEMEN. YOU SHOWS THE OF AB.
FIFTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THERE NOW AGAIN TO SHOW PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ALL NOW. WE
NEED TO HAVE A ONE IN YOU
GLOBAL TEL WHY FOR FIFTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NET INCOME
HAVE TO THE CALIFORNIA OF
COMMERCE AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. AS A- TO SHELVE THE
AT EIGHT. FIFTEEN TWELVE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN THEIR OWN
NOW AGAIN. THE PORT AB. FIFTY
TWELVE PLEASE. LEAD WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION TO AB FIFTEEN TWELVE
SO WE WILL GO TO THE GALLERY
AND I SEE NO ONE IN THE GALLERY
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO FIFTEEN TWELVE. LOOKING THE
ROOM TWELVE FORTY AND THERE IS
NO ONE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
SO WE WILL NOW. GO TO THE THOSE
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA TELECONFERENCE ARVEST.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO AB
FIFTEEN TWELVE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN TO UPHOLD AB FIFTEEN
TWELVE. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO NOW AGAIN TO A POLLS. AB
FIFTEEN QUELLE. ONE THAN THEIR
OWN NOW. DELETED OUT SHOW
ANYONE IN THE QUEUE THE OTHER
REMINDER TO UPHOLD AB FIFTEEN
TWELVE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO NOW. NOW WE DO NOT SHOW
ANYONE IN THE QUEUE THANK YOU
MODERATOR SO WE WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE- TO THE COMMITTEE-
FOR ANY COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
AFTER HEARING FROM OPPOSITION
AND SUPPORT GENE NINE. IN THE
COMMITTEE- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
BEFORE I DO LET ME TAKE A
MOMENT OF PRIVILEGED THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SERVICE I BELIEVE THIS
IS YOUR LAST LABOUR COMMITTEE
THAT YOU WILL BE CHAIRING AND
THE LAST ONE I MAY BE ABLE TO
PRESENT TO YOU SUCH AS- THANK
YOU FOR EVERYTHING YOU'VE DONE
FOR OUR STATE. FINE THANKS
THANK YOU AB FIFTEEN PROVIDES
MEMBERS ARE PROTECTIONS FOR
WORKERS AND CLARIFICATION FOR
THE EMPLOYER AND IT IS A
MIRACLE THAT I HAVE BOTH LABOR
AND THE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY.
REQUEST AND I BOTH. THE SENATOR
JACK. CHU I WE HAVE A QUESTION
FROM SENATOR JACKSON. AND THAT
IS OF. USUAL OCCURRENCE IN THIS
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THAT AND THANK YOU FOR
THAT NICE COMMENT FOR YOU HAVE
A- MOTION TO DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS ON. AB FIFTEEN
TWELVE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MEMBERS PLEASE TURN ON YOUR
MICROPHONE IN ORDER TO CAST A
VOTE SENATOR HILL HI. SENATOR
HILL HI SENATOR MORALE. HI
SENATOR MOREAU HI SENATOR
JACKSON JACKSON II CENTER
JACKSON HI SENATOR MITCHELL
MITCHELL AYE SENATOR MITCHELL
HI SENATOR PAN PAN AYE CENTER
PAN HI THE BILL ENJOYS FIVE
VOTES THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB. SEVENTEEN
THIRTY ONE. AFTER A LITTLE
HOUSEKEEPING. WE WILL MOVE ON.
JUST TO REMIND EVERYONE WE HAVE
A HARD STOP AT SEVEN PM. GIVES
US AN HOUR AND TWENTY MINUTES.
GOOD AFTERNOON WELCOME GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M GLAD STILL
AFTERNOON THESE DAYS- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY ONE SIX TO STREAMLINE
THE APPLICATION PROCESS FOR
ATVS WORK SHARE PROGRAM TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
EMPLOYERS. PARTICIPATING IN THE
PROGRAM ALLOWING THEM TO RETURN
RETAIN TRAIN STUFF AND AVOID
LAYOFFS THIS IS ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT DURING COVERT
NINETEEN WERE OPENING AND
CLOSING BUSINESSES WORK SHARING
IS A FORM OF UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE THAT GIVES EMPLOYERS
THE OPTION OF REUCING
EMPLOYEES HOURS INSTEAD OF
CUTTING THEIR WORK FOR STRING
ECONOMIC SLOWDOWN. FOR EXAMPLE
MAY THE BUSINESS MAY DETERMINE
IT NEEDS TO REDUCE PERSONNEL
COSTS BY LAYING OFF FIVE
EMPLOYEES UNTIL BUSINESS
IMPROVES UNDER WORK SHARING THE
EMPLOYER CAN INSTEAD REDUCE THE
HOURS OF TWENTY FIVE EMPLOYEES
BY 20% AND THOSE WORKERS WOULD
RECEIVE PRORATED YOU AYE
PAYMENTS. FOR THEIR ONE DAY PER
WEEK OF UNEMPLOYMENT OR
MAINTAINING EXISTING HEALTH AND
RETIREMENT BENEFITS. ABOUT
OPTING FOR WHAT SHARING THE
EMPLOYERS A TO ALL. DURING A
DOWNTURN. PLEASE IS BETTER
POSITIONED TO BACK UP WITH
ECONOMIC IMPROVE. HOWEVER
DESPITE THE MANY BENEFITS OF
WORK SHARING A PROVIDES FOR
EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES. THE
STATE'S PROGRAM IS CURRENTLY
UNDER UTILIZED BECAUSE IT CAN
BE ADMINISTRATIVELY BURDENSOME
FOR EMPLOYERS AND SOME
EMPLOYEES EMPLOYERS MAY NOT
EVEN OF THE PROGRAM. I
SPECIFICALLY AB SEVENTY ONE
WOULD CREATE A TEMPORARY
ALTERNATIVE PROCESS FOR THE
SUBMISSION AND APPROVAL OF
EMPLOYER WORK FAIR. PLAN
APPLICATIONS IT REQUIRES EIGHTY
TEACHER TEAM ALL WORK SHARING
APPLICATIONS APPROVED UPON
RECEIPT. FOR APPLICATION
SUBMITTED BY ELIGIBLE EMPLOYERS
BETWEEN SEPTEMBER FIFTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY AND SEPTEMBER
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY THREE. IT
REQUIRES EIGHTY TWO FORWARD
ELETTRONICA TO THE EMPLOYER
CLAIM PACKET FOR EACH
PARTICIPATING EMPLOYEES. WITHIN
FIVE BUSINESS DAYS FOLLOWING
THE APPROVAL APPLICATION. AND
I'M IN THE PROCESS OF REFINING
THE LANGUAGE IN THE BILL THAT
HAVE REACHED AN AVERAGE OF THE
DEPARTMENT. AN AGENCY FOR
TECHNICAL. WHEN THEY WORK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO KNOW IS
THAT WERE USING. BENEFITS THAT
WERE THE CARE ACT THE EXPAND
OUR THAT EXPAND WORK SURE YOU
LIVE BENEFITS UNTIL THE END OF
THIS YEAR WHICH IS WHY THIS
BILL HAS AN EMERGENCY CLAUSE.
I'LL BE SURE TO KEEP THE
COMMITTEE. MEMBERS AND
CONSULTANTS DEPRIVES OF ANY
CHANGES IN THE BILL AS THE BILL
MOVES THROUGH THE PROCESS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS ALL RIGHT THAT I WROTE ON
THIS IMPORTANT BILL THAT REALLY
HELPS EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT KARMIC
CALIFORNIA. I HAVE A WITNESS
12-1 VOTE IS A PROFESSOR OF
ECONOMICS AT UCLA'S. CALIFORNIA
TWO ONE. TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL HIS RESEARCH
FOCUSES ON THE ROLE OF
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
EMPLOYMENT TRANSITION OF THE
WORKERS AND THE IMPACT OF JOB
LOSS. SO MODERN THE CHAIR. THE
CALL WENT ABSOLUTE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF. PROFESSOR IS.
GEORGE. YOU LOOK. THANK YOU
EXCEPT TO HERE THANK WORKS UP
WITH PENDING CREAM OUTREACH
EMPLOYER AT THIS BILL SEEKS DO
I'M CLEAR ABOUT FOR EMPLOYERAND CALIFORNIA WHOLE. MARCHER
INCREASINGLY OF WORKERS THAT
ARE AND THEREBY REDUCES THE
COST OF LONG TERM UNEMPLOYMENT.
FORECHECKING MORE SHARING ALSO
HELPS TO MAINTAIN ATTACHMENT
BETWEEN WORKERS AND FIRMS. THIS
PREVENTS WORKERS FROM LOSING
ACCESS TO BETTER JOBS WHICH
HAVE BEEN FOUND TO BE A KEY
FACTOR IN THE COST OF
UNEMPLOYMENT. GLOBAL WORK
SHARING. PORTLAND A LUXURY KEEP
RECEIVING HEALTH INSURANCE
BENEFITS AND DISPERSE AND MUCH
BETTER POSITION THAN TEMPORARY
LAYOFFS FOR FARMS. WHAT SHARING
MEANS MAINTAINING ATTACHMENT TO
VALUABLE EMPLOYEES SAVING COSTS
OF HIRING THE RIGHT WORKERS.
WORK SHARING ALSO ALLOWS
EMPLOYERS TO FLEXIBLY MODIFY
OUR- ECONOMY RESPONSE TO
COMPETE NINETEEN AN
INTERSECTION WORKSHOP WE CAN
ALSO BE USED TO REHIRE LAID OFF
WORKERS PART TIME. PROVIDING
MUCH NEEDED FLEXIBILITY. I'M BY
KEEPING WORKERS PLACE WORK
SHARING ALLOWS THE- ECONOMY TO
BETTER ADJUST TO REPEATED
SHUTDOWNS AND TO RESTART FAST
ONE DAY AND THAT MAKE. IT AND
BY LIMITING ONGOING LAYOFFS
WERE TRYING ALSO ALLOWS FOR
FAST RECOVERY BY REDUCING
CROWDING IN THE LABOR MARKET.
HOWEVER OUR THERE ARE SOME WELL
KNOWN BEARS THE BIG FASHIONABLE
ARCHER APPLICATION PROCESS
PERCEIVED TO BE CUMBERSOME
LENGTHY. CURRENTLY WIDE INITIAL
APPLICATION HAVE BEEN AUTOMATED
EMPLOYEES AND FIRMS HAVE BEEN
MAILING PAPER FORMS TO RECEIVE
BENEFITS. AND MOREOVER IT THE
PROGRAM IS NOT WELL KNOWN AMONG
EMPLOYERS. YOU GO NEWS THERE
PAST RESEARCH HAS THAT THESE
PROBLEMS BE FIXED AND LYFT UP
THE PROCESSING OF WORK SHOWING
IN THE INCREASING OUTRAGE. AT
THE GRAVITY WHAT THE BILL DOES.
IN ONE OF THE WORST YEARS OF
THE GRAY RECESSION. 6% OF ALL
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE CLAIMS
IN CALIFORNIA WHERE FROM WORK.
IT CONTRACTED TO BEGINNING UP
TO DATE CRISIS IN MID MARCH
LESS THAN 1% OF ALL YOU LIKE
NAMES WERE FROM WORK SHARON IN
CALIFORNIA. OTHER STATES HAVE
DONE UCH BETTER. FOR EXAMPLE
IN MICHIGAN SEVEN POINT 4% OF
INITIAL PLANS DURING THE
CRISIS. WELCOME WORKSHOPS I
THINK CALIFORNIA COULD ALSO DO
BETTER BECAUSE THEY ARE IN THE
SAME. REGULATORY FRAMEWORK.
MORE WORK SHARING IS A PROGRAM
THAT HAS WIDE SUPPORT. AMONG
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS ALIKE.
THERE'S A PARTICULAR ADVANTAGE
FROM ACTING OUT MACINNES.
BECAUSE DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
SHARING AREN'T PAID FOR BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. SO BY
REFUSING TO DEATH BUT THE WHITE
TRUCK FUND EXPANDING THE WORK
SHARING PROGRAM TWENTY TWENTY
IS LIKELY TO LOWER FUTURE
PAYROLL TAX INCREASES. THAT
USING THE WIRING CHRISTIAN
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA POLICY
LAB HERE AT UCLA TO COME UP
PARKS IN THE CALCULATIONS THAT
SUGGEST THAT THE COULD GREAT
PARTICIPATION WORK SHARING
QUICKLY IT COULD BE SUBSTANTIAL.
SAVINGS TO TAXPAYERS DOWN THE
LINE. ANOTHER MAN OF FUND. SO
CALLED CHARGING EMPLOYERS NEED
A MAINLY CASH STRAPPED LOCAL
AND STATE GOVERNMENT EMPLOYERS.
CAN USE WORK SHARING TO REDUCE
THEIR BALL AND LAYOFFS. WITHOUT
BIRTH DATE LATER ON BUT ONLY
UNTIL DECEMBER. OVERALL
EXPEDITING WORK SHARING
APPLICATIONS AND INCREASING
OUTREACH TO EMPLOYERS AND
VISIBILITY COULD DO IS GOOD FOR
WORKERS IT'S GOOD FOR FARMS A
GOOD FOR CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
TESTIMONY PROFESSOR. WILL NOW
LOOK FOR THOSE IN SUPPORT IN
THE GALLERY TO SEE NO ONE IN
THE GALLERY SUPPORTING AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE WE WILL
LOOK TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY TO
SEE IF THERE'S NO ONE IN TWENTY
FORTY WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRD SEVENTEEN
THIRTY ONE. WE WILL NOW GO TO
THE- WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY V. THE TELECONFERENCE
ARVEST MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROP THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE
PLEASE. EVEN DOWN A MAN WHO
SHOWED PORT FOR AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY ONE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
BEEN THERE ON NOW. AGAIN TO
SHOW SUPPORT OF AB ONE SEVEN
THIRTY ONE CLEVELAND I AM PRESS
ONE THEN THEIR OWN NOW. WELL
FIRST CALLED THE LINE OF TWO
SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS SERRA
FLOCKS CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. MAXALT ONLINE TO
TWENTY PLEASE CALL I HAD.
GEORGE WARNER LEGALLY THAT WORK
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU THAT
COULD BE LOCAL CAROLINA. FOR
SEVENTY THREE PLEASE CALL I HAD.
HI THIS IS MARIE'S EMPLOYMENT
THE NATIONAL EMPLOYMENT LAW
PROJECT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MAXIMAL TRYING TO SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE CALL I HAD. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS AFTER OUT ON THE ACT
AND SACK AFTER IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. AND AS A
REMINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR AB
AND SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE
CLEVELAND HAD IMPRESSED ONE AND
THEN ZERO NOW AGAIN SUPPORT FOR
AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE. PLEASE
PRESS THE ONE THAN THEIR OWN
NOW. AND WE DO NOT SHOW ANYONE
IN QUEUE AT THE MOMENT VERY
GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO THE OPPOSITION
IS THERE THERE ARE NO LEAD
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION SO WE
WILL LOOK TO THE GALLERY.
THERE'S NO POINT IN THE GALLERY
WISHING TO SPEAK POSITION AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE LOOKING TO
TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NO ONE IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE SO WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO THE WITNESSES READY
TO TESTIFY THE TELLER PRINT
SERVICE PROVIDER. COULD PLEASE
PROMPT THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY UP. TO SEVEN
THIRTY ONE PLEASE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN TO A- AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO NOW. AGAIN TO UPHOLD
THE AB. SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NOW.
AND WE DO NOT SHOW ANY ON IN Q.
AS A REMINDER ONE BEEN VERRALL
TO UPHOLD THE AB. SEVENTEEN
THIRTY ONE. AMERICAN THE
LANDING GEAR VERY GOOD THANK
YOU MODERATOR WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
DISCUSSION YES SENATOR PAT. I
THANK YOU AND I WANT TO THANK
YOU- SO MEMBER- HER FOR
BRINGING THIS UP BILL FORD- I
A- BIG NOTE THAT CERTAINLY WITH
COVE IT AND- THE FLEXIBILITY
GIVEN BY AT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT BECAUSE OF COATED
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO. BE
OUT OF INTO OUR- AT THE IS
THAT'S GOING TO BE VERY
IMPORTANT I WOULD MAKE NOTE THE
ANALYSIS- INDICATOR MAY BE USED.
HELP OUR CONCERN ABOUT THE
ABUSE BUT SINCE BILL WE CAN. TO
OF A NARROW HI. THANK THAT AT
STREET FIGHTING THAT PART IS.
THE I. DIDN'T DID HAVE A- THAT
LIMITED ANY SUCH. OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THAT BUT I CERTAINLY WE
WILL TO. HOPEFULLY PASSED A
BILL GET AND THEN THE- THAT WE
NEED TO THAT HOPEFULLY. CAN AND
CRAFT SOMETHING AND I'M SURE
YOU'LL SEE A PRESS YOU WILL
CRAFT SOMETHING THAT WE COULD
THINK ABOUT HOW WE CAN EXPECT
TO BE A AND THE VEHICLE THAT
CRISIS. YOU MAY TAKE SOME
ACTION AS WELL BUT REALLY
APPRECIATE DAD BRING THIS UP
FORWARD AND I THINK THIS IS.
THE WAY IT'S CONSTRUCTED I
THINK THIS A GREAT OPPORTUNITY
FOR US TO LEARN A LOT MORE
ABOUT HOW WE CAN MAKE UP CHANGE
IN WITH THAT. MOVED BILL. THANK
YOU OTHER CALL. OR OR CONCERNS
I MEAN I. THAT CENTER OUT
THAT'S THAT WAS A- VERY GOOD
EXPLANATION OF THAT I MEAN
THINK THE ECONOMY IN THE WORK
FORCE ANY WHICH JUST DECIMATED
TODAY BECAUSE OF COVERT
NINETEEN IN THIS THIS. IS
IMPORTANT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
TO BE CREATIVE AND USE EVERY
TOOL POSSIBLE IN THIS IS ONE
THAT NEEDS TO BE. TUESDAY TO.
IT RELIES ON AGREEMENTS.
BETWEEN EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES
SO BUT- I KNOW THE BILL IS IN.
ITS FINAL FORM. YOUR BILL WORK
ON A BIG. OF THE COLD
BALLENGER'S. AND THEY HAD MORE
CIRCUMSTANCES IT'S BEEN THE
ONLY CHALLENGING CHAU- I JUST
WANT YOU TO. WANT TO ENCOURAGE
YOU TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE OTHER. STAKEHOLDERS AND
ESPECIALLY THE LABOR
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES BECAUSE AS
YOU KNOW- IF THIS. AS THIS
PROGRAM YOU KNOW IF FALLS UNDER
ET DE IT IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
THEY BE. ENGAGED IN THIS
CONVERSATION- AT THE END OF THE
DAY SO HOPEFULLY WE'LL DO THAT
AND I WILL. ENTER TWELVE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE FOR. YES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME COMMENTS. OR THAT. TIME A
WE DO NAY TO INNOVATE WE DO
NEED TO DO MORE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES AND- WORKERS WITH
BELT AS WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS TO MAKE
SURE THIS IMPORTANT MEASURES
IMPLEMENTED TO HELP THE
CALIFORNIA AND OUR ECONOMIC
RECOVERY. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR. THANK YOU VERY. THERE FOR
SUPPORT CENTER WE DO HAVE. FOR
MOVE. TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS- WITH THE
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CENTERS PLEASE TURN ON YOUR
MICROPHONES IN ORDER TO CAST A
VOTE SENATOR HILL HI. CINDER
HILL HI CENTER MORALE. AND
AROUND THE WORLD SENATOR MORALE
NO SENATOR JACKSON. JACKSON AYE
SENATOR JACKSON. HI SENATOR
MITCHELL MITCH LIVE CENTER
MITCH HI SENATOR PAN PAN HI
SENATOR PAN BY VOTERS FORTY ONE
THE BILL WITHOUT THINKING
GRADUATION ASSEMBLYMEMBERS YOU.
MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER NINE AB
NINETEEN NINETY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KAMLAGER AND I
BELIEVE SENATOR PAN WILL BE
PRESENTING THAT BILL. THANK YOU
I JUST DO IT FROM HERE OR DO
YOU WANT ME TO GO BACK WELL I
MEAN WE DO HAVE ICE ASSEMBLY
RODRIGUEZ WHO IS. AFTER THAT IT
WILL GO TO- WHAT SINCE YOU'RE
HERE ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND-
CENTER PAN'S NOT GOING ANYWHERE
WE KNOW THAT SO. THIS OF HAPPY
TO HEAR APPROVED ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE AB TWENTY NINETY TWO
THAT MAY BE THE BEST WAY SO
PLEASE PROCEED. AT YOUR
CONVENIENCE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND SENATOR FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY PRESENTS AB TWENTY
NINETY TWO IN CALIFORNIA NEARLY
80% OF EMTS AND PARAMEDICS ARE
EMPLOYED BY THE PRIVATE SECTOR
ALL OF FROM WORKING OR FILLED
WITH HIGH RATES. OF MORTALITY
INJURE TRONG. I'M FOR TOO MANY
OF THESE FOR FIRST FOR.
EXPERIENCE AND THE SOUL. FORMER
SPY TO EMERGENCY CALLS AT A
HIGHER RATE THAN MOST OTHER
OCCUPATIONS AND OFTEN BY THE
VERY PEOPLE THAT ARE TRYING TO
HELP. IT OCCURS SO OFTEN THE
NUMBER OF WORKERS CONSIDER
VARMINT THEMSELVES AS JUST PART
OF THE JOB. BIRTH AS A CAREER
IN FROM WHAT I HEAR FROM MY
CALL IN THE- PRIVATE SECTOR
ALBUMS WORKERS. BETTER
PROTECTING WORKING CONDITIONS
PART OF THAT IS ADEQUATE AND
PROPER PROTECTIVE GEAR. AB
TWENTY NINETY TWO IS A STEP IN
THAT DIRECTION IT WOULD REQUIRE
PRIVATE SECTOR. AMBLIN
SUPPORTERS TO ESTABLISH A
SUBSIDIZED PURCHASING PROGRAM
THAT WILL ALLOW WITH THEIR
EMPLOYERS EMPLOYEES TOOK A
VOLUNTARY PURCHASE PROTECTIVE
GEAR. WITH AN IMPORTANT FUNDED
STOCKTON. AB TWENTY NINETY TWO
WHAT HAPPENED- A SURF THEY SAY
FOR. PROVIDE A PROTECTIVE GEAR
TIRE WORK FIRST THAT CONNECTED
OVERLOOKED FAR TOO LONG. I'D
LIKE TO NOTE THAT ASTRI IS ALSO
PROVIDE A LETTER OF SUPPORT
WHICH MY STAFF ASSURED WITH
YOUR OFFICE I HAVE PRINCIPLE
SUB. THE MORNING ON THE PHONE
FROM RYAN WALTERS IN THE M. TEN
MEMBER REPRESENTING THE
INTERNATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
EMTS AND PARAMEDICS. FOR A
MISTER WALTERS OF IF YOU ARE ON
THE LINE THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
GOOD EVENING SHARE HEALTH
CENTERS OF THE COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
THAT THE MONEY FOR THIS VERY
IMPORTANT BILL TODAY. MY NAME
IS A LINE WALTERS AND I'M AT
AND T. YEARS. LOS ANGELES AND
ORANGE COUNTY AND A MEMBER OF
I. IGHTY LOCAL THREE SEVEN
ZERO. I'M HERE TO SUPPORT AB
TWO ZERO NINE TWO BECAUSE I
KNOW FIRST THE DANGERS AND WITH
THAT HANDLES WORKERS THREE
THOUSAND FIELD EVERY DAY. WHAT
THE MOST COMMON DANGERS WE FACE
ISN'T WIDELY SPOKEN OF. THE
FREQUENT OCCURRENCES. INVIOLATE
WE ENCOUNTER FIELD. WE KILEY.
PEOPLE WE ARE TRYING TO HELP.
FOR MANY WORKERS WE RECOGNIZE
THIS IS AN INHERENT PART OF THE
JOB. BUT WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE IS A NEED TO BE EVEN MORE
WORK TO BE DONE TO ENSURE OUR
I'LL- FIFTY ONE OR TWENTY TWO
EMERGENCY CALL. AB ZERO AB TWO
ZERO NINE TWO AND THE STEP IN
THAT DIRECTION. BY PROVIDING
PRIVATE AMBULANCE WORKERS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO OBTAIN
SUBSIDIZED SUBSIDIZES
PROTECTIVE GEAR TO OUR
EMPLOYERS. VERSUS FONG CAN
BETTER PROTECT OURSELVES WHILE
WE COME TO THE AID OF OTHERS.
THE WORK THAT. ARE MEDICALLY
DANGEROUS LOFTING THE
OCCUPATION WHERE ANYTHING CAN
HAPPEN. IN AN INSTANT. I WANT
ASSEMBLY LAND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ FOR INTERVIEW
THINKING PORTABLE AND BRINGING
ATTENTION TO THE LONGSTANDING
CONVERSATION. ALL FOR FAR TOO.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
OPPORTUNITY PRESENT TODAY
CONCLUDES MY TESTIMONY AND I BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU MR
REPORTERS AND NOW WE WILL LOOK
AT THOSE INTO SUPPORT OFFER
THEIR SUPPORT IN THE GAP THREE
FOUR. TWENTY NINETY TWO THERE
ANYWAY. ALREADY SEE NO ONE WILL
MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY. THERE'S NO
ONE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
WISHING TO SUPPORT AB TWENTY
NINETY TWO WE WILL NOW. MOVE ON
TO THE WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY BE THE CONFERENCE SIR.
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
NINETY TWO. SURE LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN HE SHOW SUPPORT FOR A
BI MONEY NINETY THANK YOU
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN THERE ARE
NOW AGAIN TO SHOW SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY NINETY TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN THERE NOW. AND WE NEED
TO HAVE ABOUT THE LINK HE'LL
IT'LL BE JUST A MOMENT AND JUST
AS A REMINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT
FOR AB TWENTY NINETY TWO. TO
ONE THEN THEY'RE ALL. WELL
FIRST GOLD TIMELINE OR SEVENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTER
THE MARKET MEDICAL RESPONSE
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST PROVIDER
OF NINE ONE ONE EMERGENCY
TRANSPORT MRIDIAN SUPPORTED AB
TWENTY NINETY TWO AND VERY
BRIEFLY THERE ARE BIG FEEL THAT
THE MOST RECENT NOT RIGHTFULLY
NOT OVER PERCENT YOU VERY MUCH
I'M SORRY WE'RE JUST LOOKING
FOR NAME AFFILIATION AND OF
YOUR OPINION ON THE BILL. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT MAX VOCAL
CAROLINE FOR ABQ PRESCHOOL I
HAD. YOU ARE HERE MEMBERS OF
THE AMY BROWN ON BEHALF OF THE
NINE ONE ONE AMBULANCE
PROVIDERS MEDICARE ALLIANCE OR
IN SUPPORT AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER-
WITH WORKING WITH THAT OF THE
PAST THANK YOU. AS A REMINDER
TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY
NINETY TWO PLEASE PRESS. ONE
THEN THEY'RE ON NOW AGAIN
LONDON ZERO TO SHOW SUPPORT.
AND WE DO NOT SHOW ANYONE ELSE
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME VERY
GOOD THANK YOU HAVING HEARD
EVERYONE IN SUPPORT WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO THE OPPOSITION IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE GALLERY WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY ANY CHOOSE PAIN NO ONE
IN ROOM TWENTY FOUR IS THERE
ANYONE WHAT WHICH- WHEN THEY'RE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
AB TWENTY NINETY TWO WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO THE WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE. URBIS MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROP THE
END OF WE TO. IN OPPOSITION TO
IT SB. TWENTY NINETY TWO. SURE
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OPPOSE
AB TWENTY NINETY CAN YOU.
PLEASE PRESS ONE BUTTON ZERO
NOW. AGAIN TO OPPOSED A NINE.
EIGHT TWENTY NINETY TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN THERE NOW. I DO
NOT SHOW ANYONE AND THEY Q. THE
BLACKBERRY MINDERS TO UPHOLD.
EIGHTEEN TWENTY NINETY TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN THEIR OWN
NOW. DELETED I SHOT ANYONE IN
THE QUEUE VERY GOOD THANK YOU
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
AFTER HEARING THOSE IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION- OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS TO SENATOR PAN I
THANK YOU THANK YOU SOME. SEVEN
RODRIGUEZ FOR THIS IS FOR THIS
BILL I DID HAVE A QUESTION IN
TERMS OF AND I NEED TO USE UP
THE PROTESTS OF RECAREY YES.
BUT YOU CERTAINLY MADE CASE FOR
HELP IS THE- THIS THIS. THEN A
VOLUNTARY FUND FOR THE- EMT TO
PURCHASE IT WHY NOT SUPPLIED AS
PART OF THE REGULAR PROTECTIVE
GEAR. SO WAS THAT DISCUSS-
EVERYTHING INSTEAD OF TELLING
US INTO DEBT TO GO FIND IT
TELLS. HERE'S THE MONEY FOR
THAT THAT SHOULD JUST BE
SUPPLIED SO. THE PRIVATE SECTOR
INDUSTRY RIGHT THE PART OF A
UNIFORM TYPE OF ALLOWANCES
BUTTON SO TO SPEAK- I KNOW WHEN
I WORKED THERE FOR YEARS WE
HAVE HAD A STIPEND FOR BOOT.
BOOT ALLOWANCE. YOU'RE THE
JOURNAL. BUT AS TIME INVOLVED
MORE AT NOW THIS IS JUST
SOMETHING ADDITIONAL TO TYPE OF
GEAR PROTECTIVE GEAR- AND IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE ANOTHER
FORM OF THIS. TO ALLOW
EMPLOYEES TO PURCHASE THAT IF
THEY WISH- AS FAR AS BEING PART
OF THE UNIFORM I THINK THAT
WOULD BE A TOTAL SEPARATE
CONVERSATION WITH THE- WE AT
THE PRIVATE SECTOR BUT I THINK
THIS IS THE FIRST TO. ACHIEVING
THAT. WELL CERTAINLY YOU KNOW
SUPPORTED OF- FIRST INITIAL
STEPS I THINK YOU ALSO MADE THE
CASE WILL HELP TOWARDS
EQUIPMENT IS SO THERE'S A PART
OF ME AND SAYS WELL WHY
SHOULDN'T WE BUT I GET WHERE
YOU ARE NOW AND- SO. DURING THE-
BILL THE PRO TIME. THANK YOU
OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS SEE
NONE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE OUR SPORT S.
RIVAL THANK YOU VERY GOOD THANK
YOU AND DO WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM SENATOR PAN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MOTION IS PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SO PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. MEMBERS PLEASE TURN
ON YOUR MICROPHONES IN ORDER
CAP TO VOTE SENATOR HILL HI.
SENATOR HILL BY SENATOR MORALE.
BROWNELL CENTER MORALE NO
SENATOR JACKSON. SEN SENATOR
JACKSON HI SENATOR MITCHELL
MITCHELL LIVE CENTER MITCHELL
HI CENTER PAN FAN I CENTER PAN
HI. THE BILL HAS FOUR VOTE IS
UP THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ADVOCATES
CREATED. WILL MOVE BACK TO ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN. AB TWENTY FORTY
THREE ASSEMBLY MEMBER RATE THIS.
GOOD EVENING. THANK RESEARCHER
HOW ARE YOU DOING GREAT THANK
YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN A LONG DAY
FOR YOU ALL THAT BEEN IN MY
OFFICE PAVE THE WAY TO BE
CALLED. I FEEL LIKE I'VE BEEN
HERE THE WHOLE TIME I THINK BUT
I REALLY APPRECIATED THE
OPPORTUNITY MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE. I WANT TO
STOP I THINK COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR ASSISTANCE ON THIS
BILL I'D ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE
MANY STAKEHOLDERS ADVOCATES WHO
HAVE. WORKED VERY CLOSELY WITH
OUR OFFICE FROM BOTH THE FARM
WORKER COMMUNITY- THE
AGRICULTURAL THREE TO IMPROVE
THE BILL OVER THE PAST FEW
MONTHS. I KNOW. THROUGH
ASSISTANCE AND EFFORTS- WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO MOVE ALL
OPPOSITION. ON OUR LEGISLATION.
I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THIS
BILL ASSEMBLY BILL TWO ZERO
FOUR THREE WHICH PROTECTS THE
OCCUPATIONAL. AND HEALTH OF OUR
STATE. AGRICULTURAL WORKERS.
AMID THE CALL THE NINETEEN
HEALTH CRISIS THAT WE FACE. HI
INCLUDING THE NEARLY HUNDRED
THOUSAND FARMERS IN THE
DISTRICT I REPRESENT. EVERY DAY
FARMWORKERS ACROSS OUR STATE
RISE EARLY. THEY LEAVE THEIR
FAMILIES. TO TRAVEL TO WORK IN
CAR POOLS AND IN CROWDED BUSES.
THEY WORK LONG DAYS SHOULDER TO
SHOULDER IN THE FIELDS AND
PACKING HOUSES. THEIR WORK IS
PHYSICALLY TOUGH AND DEMANDING
IT'S THE TYPE OF WORK THAT WILL
BREAK DOWN YOUR BODY OVER TIME.
AND I KNOW THIS BECAUSE MY
GRANDFATHER WAS A FARMER VERY
WAS A LIFELONG FARMWORKERS. AND
HE WAS THE MAN WHO HELPED RAISE
MY BROTHER NINE AND SO I SAW
HOW HOW HARD HE WORKED. DAY IN
AND DAY OUT WE WORKED OUTSIDE
THE WEATHER IS ALWAYS
UNPREDICTABLE. AND DEPENDING ON
THE TIME OF YEAR SOME WORK DAYS
WERE LONGER THAN OTHERS AND HE
NEVER MONEY. BUT AS WE ALL KNOW
MANY FARMWORKERS ARE
UNDOCUMENTED HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT THEY OFTEN LACK ACCESS TO
BASIC SERVICES CHRONIC HEALTH
CONDITIONS ARE COMMON. AND
LIVING CRITICALLY OVERCROWDED
CONDITIONS. HI AND AS WE HAVE
SEEN HAPPEN SINCE THE ONSET OF
THIS PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS AND
ACCORDING TO RECENT DATA
RELEASED JUST LAST WEEK. THE CO
NINETEEN VIRUS SPREAD IN THE
FACT IT HAS SPREAD VERY VERY
QUICKLY IN CONDITIONS SUCH AS
THESE AND CLEARLY AS LONG AS
THIS PANDEMIC CONTINUES. OUR
FARMWORKERS ARE AGRICULTURAL
WORKERS ARE AT HIGH RISK FOR
EXPOSURE TO THIS VIRUS. INDEED
RECENT REPORTS OF COVER
NINETEEN OUTBREAKS LINKED TO
FARMS AND PACKING SHEDS
MEATPACKING PLANTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA FROM SEPT ONE KEEP
THAT FROM THE SAN JOAQUIN IN
COACHELLA VALLEY. FEDERAL COAST
TO VENTURA AND IMPERIAL COUNTY.
MAKE ABSOLUTELY CLEAR THAT MORE
MUST BE DONE. IF THESE
OUTBREAKS PERSIST OR WORSEN OUR
FOOD SUPPLY WILL CERTAINLY BE
IMPACTED. AND WE NEED OUR AG
WORKERS TO STAY HEALTHY SO THEY
CAN STAY ON THE JOB THESE
WORKERS KEEP FOOD ON OUR TABLES
THEY KEEP OUR GROCERY STORE
SHELVES STOCKED. FARMERS AND
AGRICULTURE EMPLOYERS ARE OUR
PARTNERS IN THIS EFFORT. THEY
UNDERSTAND THE RISK THAT THE
ROAD WORKERS FACE THEY CARE
ABOUT THEIR EMPLOYEES AND WANT
TO KEEP THEM SAFE. AND THIS
BILL- HERE- IN YOUR COMMITTEE
MISTER CHAIR AS AN URGENCY BILL
AND ADDRESSES THE ISSUE OF
COVER NINETEEN OUTBREAKS TO
AGRICULTURE WORKSITES AND WASTE.
FOR IT IMPLEMENTED TOP IT OUT
WITH CAMPAIGN TO ALL
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS ON CAL
OSHA BEST PRACTICES ON HOW TO
STAY SAFE FROM COVER NINETEEN.
THE CAMPAIGN WOULD CONSIST OF
PUBLIC SERVICE ANNOUNCEMENTS
AND WORKPLACE SIGNS IN BOTH
ENGLISH AND SPANISH. MAKE IT
MORE SENSIBLE TO THIS-
WORKFORCE IS AVERAGE CAMPAIGN
WILL ALSO INCLUDE INFORMATION
ON PAID SICK LEAVE WORKERS
COMPENSATION ARE CRITICAL
NINETEEN. OINTMENT FITBIT THE
BENEFIT OF SORRY AND AS WE'VE
LEARNED AGRICULTURE WORKERS ARE
GOING TO WORK WELL STILL
TESTING POSITIVE FOR COVER
NINETY. AND AS LOW WAGE EARNERS
FARMERS CAN'T AFFORD TO LOSE A
DAY'S WORK AS A RESULT WE HAVE
TO MAKE THEM AWARE OF THE
BENEFITS THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO
THEM SO THEY FEEL COMFORTABLE
TAKING THE TIME AWAY FROM WORK
THAT THEY NEED TO FULLY RECOVER
SHOULD THEY BECOME. IN FACT. WE
ALSO HAVE TO EMPOWER THEM TO
REPORT UNSAFE WORKING
CONDITIONS THAT MAY HAVE CAUSED
THEM TO BECOME EFFECTIVE IN THE
FIRST PLACE AND AS PART OF THE
OUTREACH CAMPAIGN. WORKERS WILL
BE PROVIDED WITH CONTACT
INFORMATION FOR CALLOW SHOP-
THAT THEY CAN UTILIZE TO FILE
COMPLAINTS ONE SECOND THIS BILL
REQUIRES CAL OSHA TO POST ON
ITS WEBSITE. ROBUST IN. RELATED
TO INCIDENT GEISHAS OF
AGRICULTURAL WORKPLACES. WE
NEED GREATER TRANSPARENCY TO
IDENTIFY AND TO MITIGATE
AGAINST UNSAFE WORKING
CONDITIONS. MAKE NO MISTAKE WE
MISSED OF A PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY WITH NO IMMEDIATE END
IN SIGHT. HI THIS PANDEMIC HAS
SHOWN NO SIGNS OF ABATING WE
NEED TO ADDRESS. THE ISSUE NOW.
THE DRESS NOW. BEFORE ARRIVALS
WORKERS GETS AND FOOD SUPPLY WE
MAY BECOME THREATENED HERE WITH
ME TO TESTIFY OUR DOCTOR AND
LOPEZ FROM THE CENTER FOR FARM.
FAMILIES AND MARCO SAYS OUT.
LEASE OUR LEASE OUT I GOT UP
FROM THE FROM A LOCK
COOPERATIVA CAMPESINA THE
CALIFORNIA AND SO WITH THAT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAVIS AND
CERTAINLY RESPECT. RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I PUT THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND WE WILL-
ALLOW OTHERS WITNESSED IS A
TOTAL OF EIGHT MINUTES SO.
PLEASE REPEAT. ALTHOUGH I'M
DOCTOR OPEZ EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CENTER FOR FARMWORKER
FAMILIES. AND I'VE BEEN
RESEARCHING AND WORKING WITH
FARMWORKERS FOR THE PAST TWENTY
THREE YEARS. IN AN ATTEMPT TO
UNDERSTAND THE CONSTRAINTS THAT
THERE WILL. AND CREATE PUBLIC
AWARENESS AND IMPROVEMENT OF
THEIR DIFFICULT LIFE
CIRCUMSTANCES PROFESSOR REMINDS
THAT UC DAVIS SUMMARIZES THEIR
LIVES THE DUNKLEY. THE LONGER
FARMWORKERS ARE WORKING IN
CALIFORNIA THE THICKER THEY GET
A LIFE OF POVERTY INCLUDING
OVERCROWDED LIVING CONDITIONS
POOR NUTRITION REGULAR EXPOSURE
TO TOXIC PESTICIDES AND A LACK
OF HEALTH INSURANCE. TAKE THEIR
TOLL BRIDGE BUILDING AND AN
AVERAGE LIFE EXPECTANCY OF ONLY.
FORTY NINE YEARS OPENED IN
NINETEEN DE IN. ALL OF THESE
FACTORS ADDING YET ONE MORE
ISSUED TO THEIR ALREADY OVER
BURDENED. LIFE IT IS AB THE AND-
THAT WE TAKE ALL POSSIBLE STEPS
TO PROTECT THE CENTRAL WORKERS
WHO ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
SUPPLYING MUCH OF THE NATION.
BROUGH AND BENCH DOUBLE AND OUT
OF GOLDEN. IN THE FARMWORKER
COMMUNITY WHAT COMPROMISED THE
AGRICULTURAL ECONOMY AND RESULT
IN WIDESPREAD PAINFUL BUILDERS
AND POSSIBLY AND COMMUNITY.
CENTER FOR WORK FAN THE BOARD
AB TWO ZERO FOUR THREE THE
AGRICULTURAL WORKPLACE AND DAVE
ACT I IMPLORE YOU TO JOIN ME
AND THE POOR THE REASON BILL AB
TWENTY FOUR THREE THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THE NEXT
WITNESS. YES MY NAME IS MARCOS
PLEASE OUR- I AM THE EXECUTIVE
THE OF COMPANY WELCOME BACK TO
YOU KNOW THEY CAN. WE ARE STILL
WATER AND NOT SERVING
FARMWORKERS OF OUR STATE WE
HAVE FOLLOWED CONCERNS FOR OUR
PEOPLE WORKING ASCENTIAL
AGRICULTURAL JOBS ALL THE LUCKY
ONES WHO MAKE UP ABOUT 40% OF
THE POPULATION IN THIS. ALSO
REPORTED AS 53% OF THE POSITIVE
CASES A COVERT NINETEEN AFTER
THAT NEARLY 30% OF LATINOS
DON'T HAVE HEALTH INSURANCE AND
MANY OF THOSE WITHOUT INSURANCE
ARE AFRAID TO SEEK CARE.
WORKERS IN PARTICULAR. BOB
PERFORMING HIGH RATE ABOUT OUR
FILMS INCLUDING DIABETES AND-
PUTTING THEM AT AN EVEN GREATER
RISK OF COMPLICATIONS FROM
CORPORATE NINETY. WE NEED
GALHOTRA TO REPORTERS REGARDING
ISSUES. IN PREVENTION ANGER
CULTURAL PLACES OF WORK WE NEED
TO REQUIRE EDUCATION FOR
WORKERS SOME COLD EIGHT
NINETEEN AND RECOMMENDED
SANITATION PRACTICES AND MAKE
WORKERS AWARE OF THE PAID SICK
LEAVE AND WORKERS COMPENSATION
YES THEY CAN USE WE NEED TO
KNOW WHAT ACTIONS JELLO SHOT
EXPECTING TO ADDRESS COMPLAINTS
OF WORKPLACE HEALTH AND SAFETY
ISSUES. CORPORATE EVEN MEMBERS
STRONGLY SUPPORT ASSEMBLY MEANS
EVERYBODY AB. TWO ZERO FOUR
THREE A WE THANK THEM FOR IT.
HE ASKED HI MODE. REALLY THANK
YOU VERY GOOD THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE WILL NOW LOOK TO THE
GAL IF THE ANYONE THERE WHICH
TO SPEAK SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FORTY THREE SEE NO ONE WE WILL
GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY FOR
ANYONE SEEKING IN SUPPORT THERE
IS NO ONE THERE WE WILL NOW GO
TO TELECONFERENCE LINE AND FOR
THE THIS IS MADE IN THE BEST A-
GREATER. THE END OF THE- WITH.
TESTIFY IN. OF AB TWENTY FORTY
THREE PLEASE. SHARE AND MAYBE
EVEN DOWN A MAN TO SHOW SUPPORT
FOR AB TWENTY FORTY THREE
PLEASE. PRESS THE ONE THAN
THEIR OWN NOW. IF YOU ARE
ALREADY IN THE- AND YOU WISH TO
APPLY PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN TO
REMOVE YOURSELF. AGAIN THIS IS
FOR SUPPORT. FOR EIGHTEEN
TWENTY FORTY THREE. WE HAVE
ABOUT EIGHT AND LIKE YOU WILL
START WITH A LINE. E. EIGHTY
THIRTY THREE SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I REMEMBER THIS IS
DRIVING ME CRAZY THE LECTERN
STATE COUNCIL IN SUPPORT. YOUR
I ALSO HAVE A LIST THAT I ORGAN
THAT WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER
THEIR SUPPORT IF I CAN SHARE
YES VERY GOOD. GO AHEAD. BUT
ACTION NETWORK IF YOU'RE NOT
THAT THE PUBLIC POLICY
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIANS FOR PESTICIDE
REFORM LATINO COALITION FOR A
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL FOR. AND OF. HEALTH IN
FINDING THAT WORK AND LASTLY
CALIFORNIA AN AGRICULTURAL
NETWORK ALL IN SUPPORT YEAH
THANK YOU. HI NEXT TO CAROLINE
THREE SIXTY GOD. MITCH SNIDER
WITH- CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MAX OF ALL TIME FOR
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE CALL I HAD.
WE'RE BACK IN BALL NATIONALISTS
OF SOCIAL WORK HELLO CHECK IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT LEVEL
COMBINED FOR NINETY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU RENEE
BAYARDO WITH S. YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIA BOARD THANK YOU.
MADLA CAROLINA FOR SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU SHALL GALA
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT
POLICY CENTER IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. MAXILLA. THREE EIGHTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NO AT BOTTOM
ALL REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATIONAND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. MAXWELL CAROLINE FOR
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MAY GET A DRINK IN ON
BEHALF OF WORK EQUITY AND WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE STUFF.
THANK YOU. AN AXOLOTL LINE FOR
EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MICHAEL RAT AGAIN ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GEN AS A
REMINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR AB
TWENTY FORTY THREE PLEASE PRESS
THE ONE THAN THEIR OWN NOW
AGAIN TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR AB.
TWENTY FORTY THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THAN THEIR OWN NOW. AND WE
DID NOT SHOW ANYONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE. VERY GOOD THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE WILL NOW GO TO THOSE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY FORTY
THREE. THERE'S NO REGISTERED
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS SO WE
WILL LOOK TO THE GALLERY AND
THERE'S NO ONE HERE. TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY
FORTY THREE LOOKING TO TWENTY
FORTY THERE'S NO ONE IN TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY FORTY
THREE WILL. NOW MOVE TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
TELECONFERENCE. TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY FORTY
THREE PLEASE. SHARE AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN TO UPHOLD AB
TWENTY FORTY THREE PLEASE PRESS
APPLY AND THEN THEIR OWN NOW
AGAIN TO OPPOSE AB TWENTY FORTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THERE NOW. WE DO HAVE ABOUT
THREE IN THE QUEUE WILL SART
WHAT FOR EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE
WELL I HAD. GOOD AFTERNOON I
GUESS ACTUALLY GOOD EVENING HI
THIS IS MICHAEL MILLER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION WINE
GRAPE GROWERS- WE WERE OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL- AND- ME GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
WILLINGNESS TO. THANK YOU
MAXALT TO LINE FOR EIGHTY THREE
I HAD. FOUR EIGHTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN YOU MAY BE NEEDED.
ALL RIGHT NATURAL MOLD TIMELINE
FOR NINETY PLEASE CALL I HAD.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AT ONE
ON ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
CITRUS MUTUAL AND GROWER
SHIPPERS ASSOCIATION- WE'RE
ACTUALLY OPPOSE MCMAHON DID BUT
THANKS FOR THE HARD WORK AND-
THE AUTHOR HIS STAFF. YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF AND- THANK YOU
CAN ACCESSIBLE KLEIN. FOR
EIGHTY THREE PLEASE CALL I HAD.
I AGREE TRICHET GARINGER WITH
AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL ALSO
MOVING TO A NEUTRAL POSITION
WITH THE AMENDMENT AS OTHERS
HAVE STATED THANK YOU. AND
AGAIN I TO UPHOLD AB TWENTY
FORTY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO NOW AGAIN IT TO
UPHOLD AB TWENTY FORTY THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN THEIR
OWN NOW. GLOBAL TO ALIGN FOR
EIGHTY FIVE PEOPLE HAVE. FOUR
EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NEXT LEVEL TIMELINE FOR EIGHTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MATTHEW I'M WITH
WESTERN GROWERS ASSOCIATION WE
ARE LIMITED TO A NEUTRAL
POSITION ON THE BILL. THANK YOU.
AND AS A REMINDER TO OPPOSE AB
TWENTY FORTY THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN THEY'RE ON NOW AGAIN
TO OPPOSE AB TWENTY FORTY THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NOW.
AND WE DID NOT SHOW ANYONE ELSE
IN THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU WE'VE NOW HEARD FROM
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE SENATOR
JACKSON. HIS THANK YOU ABOUT.
IF I MAY ASK THE- AUTHOR WE
HAVE A FAIRLY SUBSTANTIAL
MISTAKEN POPULATION- IN
CALIFORNIA DOING FARM WORK AS
WELL SPEAKING A LANGUAGE THAT
IS- ONTO ITSELF AND I'M
WONDERING- IF THERE'S ANYTHING
IN THIS BILL TO ADDRESS SENT TO
TRY TO REACH OUT. TO THIS
COMMUNITY AND OTHERWISE WE'LL-
BE ABLE TO UNDERSTAND THE WILL
NOT GET THE- THEY NEED TO
UNDERSTAND THE SERIOUSNESS OF
THE SITUATION AND WHAT STEPS
SHOULD BE DOING TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES. THAT IS A GREAT
COMMENT- ADAM SENATOR- THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE
DISCUSSED IN OUR BILL
SPECIFICALLY STATES FOR ENGLISH
AND SPANISH. BUT CERTAINLY YOU
KNOW AND- THE DISTRICT I
REPRESENT WE HAVEA LARGE
OAXACAN POPULATION. THEN SO
TRYING TO REACH- AND OVERCOME
THESE LANGUAGE BARRIERS IS
SOMETHING THAT- WE'RE GOING TO
SEE THE TRY TO ADDRESS DO OUR
BEST TO ADDRESS OBVIOUSLY. WITH
THE COMMITTED TO HAVE REMAINED.
BUT CERTAINLY TRYING TO ADDRESS
THESE LANGUAGE. BARRIERS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE ENGAGED
CAL OSHA TO SEE. IT IS THAT
POSH BUT CERTAINLY IT'S A GREAT
POINT AND CERTAINLY NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED. I WOULD JUST URGE
THAT WHILE WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO
HELP SOME PEOPLE IF WE CAN'T
HELP ALL THE PEOPLE IN THE
FIELDS- DOESN'T. NECESSARILY
GET US WHERE WE NEED TO GO SO I
HOPE IT WILL CONTINUE WORKING
ON THAT AND WOULD CERTAINLY
ENCOURAGE YOU TO DO SO.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR JACKSON OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS- SENATOR GRAMM OF
VERY WE DO- BEFORE WE ENTERTAIN
THE MOTION I JUST WANT TO THANK
YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
WORKING SO CLOSELY WITH OUR
STAFF AND REALLY COME INTO IT
SOME GROUP TO. CONCLUSIONS AND-
AND RESOLVE WITH REMOVING THAT
OPPOSITION IS WONDERFUL IT'S A
GREAT BILL AND- AND I THINK
IT'S IT WE WONDERFUL WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. THIS AS FOR
NIVEAU REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY PRESENT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS
WE HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR
PAN- IN THAT IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. PLEASE
CONSULTING CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSES APPROACH
TO APPROPRIATIONS. CENTERS
PLEASE TURN ON YOUR MICROPHONE
IN ORDER TO CAST A VOTE.
SENATOR HILL- CENTER HILL HI
CENTER MORALE. NOT VOTING.
SENATOR MORALE NOT VOTING
SENATOR JACKSON JACKSON AYE
SENATOR JACKSON HI SENATOR
MITCHELL MITCHELL LIVE CENTER
JEWEL HI SENATE HAN. HI CENTER
PAN I THE BILL HAS FOUR VOTES
IT'S IS OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR LIKE TO DO AT THIS POINT IS
MOVED TO. THE BACK I REMEMBER
NINE AND I THINK SAID. AND IS
TO PRESENT BILL AB NINETY NINE
THREE FOUR SEVEN MEMBER COME UP
AND THE REASON FOR DOING THAT.
THIS IS HAVE BEEN EIGHTEEN AND
WE WANT TO. CONTINUE MOVED TO.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN FIFTH.
TWENTY TO THIRTY FOUR AND THEN
I SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR. THAT
TO WE WILL THEN TAKE UP HIS
BILL SO. PLEASE. THANK THANK
YOU VERY CHAIR SENATOR. YOUR OF
I AM BEHALF OF US AND COME A
LAGER HERE TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND VOTE ON AB NINETEEN
NINETY THREE THE FAMILY CARE
GIVER ECONOMIC SECURITY ACT. HI
JUSTICE A PROVIDERS WHO CARE
FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO AREN'T A
CHILD OR SPOUSE ARE ACTUALLY
ELIGIBLE FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE. HOWEVER CALIFORNIA
LAW EXCLUDES PARENT AND SPOUSE
ALL RIGHT IN HOME SUPPORT
SERVICES PROVIDERS FROM
RECEIVING UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE PAYMENTS. ABOUT 22%
OF HSS PROVIDERS ABOUT A
HUNDRED SIXTEEN THOUSAND MOSTLY
FEMALE FALL INTO THIS CATEGORY.
THESE PROVIDERS WHO MAY BECOME
UNEMPLOYED DUE TO THE DEATH OF
THEIR LOVED ONE ARE LEFT
WITHOUT A PAYCHECK OR ANY TYPE
OF FINANCIAL SUPPORT. EIGHT D.
NINETY THREE B. EXTENDS THE
PLAN INSURANCE ELIGIBILITY TO
PARENT AND SPOUSE I JUST AS
PROVIDERS. CARE GIVERS TO HELP
CLIENTS WITH MEALS PERSONAL
CARE NEEDS AND EVEN PARAMEDICAL
SERVICES LIKE MANAGING
MEDICATIONS BLOOD TESTING
CHARACTER USE AND IN MANY CASES
I JUST AS CARE GIVERS BECOME
THE CLIENTS ONLY LIFELINE.
ESPECIALLY DURING A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC WE MUST MAINTAIN
PHYSICAL DISTANCE AND STAY AT
HOME. THE COMMON NINETEEN
PANDEMIC TO SHAPE SHINING A
LIGHT ON THE PROBLEMS THAT
CALIFORNIA WORKERS FACE SUCH AS
LACKING PROTECTIVE GEAR CHILD
CARE OR ACCESS TO UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE. WE MUST ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S A PACE WHERE ALL
WORKERS INCLUDING SPOUSE AND
PARENT THIS IS PROVIDERS ARE
TREATED WITH DIGNITY AND
RESPECT. TIMES OF CRISIS AND IN
NORMAL TIMES. BECAUSE BY
CHURCHES ARE GIVERS MORE THAN
SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND SENIORS
AND PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
STATE WIDE RECEIVER CARE AT
HOME. INSTEAD OF IN A NURSING
HOME. BUT NEED FOR UNDER
STRAIGHT TRIPS TO HEALTH CARE
FACILITY HOW. TAX IS FULL
POPULAR. FROM OVER NINETY. AND
PER THIS FACILITY FOR OVER AND
WE CERTAINLY SEE AND USED ABOUT
CHALLENGES IN. OUR FACILITIES.
UNFORTUNATELY STAGNANT WAGES
AND INSUFFICIENT BENEFITS
CREATED DANGEROUS SHORTAGE OF
CAREGIVERS AS A RESULT MANY
CARE GIVERS ARE PARENTS AND
SPOUSES. WHO SACRIFICE THEIR
OWN CAREERS TO DO THE WORK
THEMSELVES PROVIDING THAT CARE.
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE AS A
BASELINE PROTECTION THAT MOST
WORKERS RELY UPON EVEN IN NON
CRISIS TIMES. SO WE NEED A
PERMANENT SOLUTION SO THAT
FAMILY CAREGIVERS CAN HAVE THE
BASIC EMPLOYMENT PROTECTIONS
ALL THE TIME. THE SPIRIT OF
MAINTAINING A HEALTHY SOCIETY
CARES OF ITS WORKERS AVERAGE MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE COMMITTEE TO
VOTE IN FAVOR OF EXTENDING
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE TO
PARENT AND SPOUSE I JUST OF
PROVIDERS. THAT PLEASED TO HAVE
TESTIFYING SUPPORT CRISTINA
BASE HAMILTON WHAT UT W. ASKED
ME LOCAL THIRTY NINE THIRTY AND
KATHLEEN WILL WILLIAMS WITH
BABIES SOSPECIAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR PAN
OF THIS HAMILTON OF IF YOU'RE
THERE PLEASE PROCEED. I AM HERE
SORRY I WAS JUST- GETTING UP
WITH YOU HI CHRISTINE ABOUT
CAMEL CAN REPRESENTING B. U. W.
UNITED DOMESTIC WORKERS WE ARE
THE PRIMARY SPONSORS OF THIS
BILL- THIS BILL IS THE- NUMBER
ONE PRIORITY LEGISLATION FOR
US. ABOUT 20% OF OUR WORKERS
ARE IN THE CATEGORY OF BEING
PARENTS HOUSE PROVIDERS. AND
THE TESTIMONY THAT WE'VE HEARD
FROM YOU THE BILL SO FAR IN
THIS COMMITTEE ALL REITERATE.
IMPORTANT ACCESS. TO ECONOMIC
PROGRAMS LIKE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE ARE AT THIS MOMENT OF
RECESSION AND CRATE THAT. AND
THE FACT THAT THESE WOMEN I
WILL IT IT IS 85% WOMEN. WERE
IN THAT CATEGORY DO NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO UNEMPLOYMENT IN CASE
GOD FORBID THE PART THEIR
SPOUSE OR CHILD. EITHER PASSES
AWAY OR HOSPITALIZED HE IS AN
ABSOLUTE- CRATED IN THE MAKING.
THEY DON'T WILL NOT HAVE ANY
INCOME SUPPORT AT ALL AND WE
ARE ASKING YOU TO PLEASE-
EXTEND THE SAME PROTECTIONS BUT
EVERY OTHER. WORKER HAS HE DID
VULNERABLE GROUP OF- PROVIDERS
IN CALIFORNIA AND I WANT TO.
SHARE THIS NOW KATHLEEN WHO'S
ALSO JOINING US ON THE PHONE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. I CAN HEAR
YOU YES WE CAN THANK YOU. HELLO
OKAY HELLO EVERYONE MY NAME IS
KATHLEEN WILLIAMS I'M ASKING
YOU PLEASE- SUPPORT AB NINETEEN
NINETY THREE. EXISTING PARENTS
AND SOUTH I JUST PROVIDERS FROM
UNEMPLOYMENT PROTECTIONS AFTER
THEIR LOVED ONE PASSED AWAY AT
SCHOOL IN THESE GRIEVING
FAMILIES FINANCIALLY DESOLATE
AND IN DANGER OF LOSING
EVERYTHING AT THE WORST TIME IN
THEIR LIVES. I KNOW THIS
FIRSTHAND BECAUSE I LIVE
STUDENTS WITH MY PRECIOUS TIME
CAMPUS. ON OCTOBER TWENTY FIRST
TWO THOUSAND AND SIX AND CALEB
WAS BORN WITH THE TERMINAL
HEART DEFECT. CALIBER. AROUND
THE CLOCK CARE. OUR THE FEEDING
TUBES. AND MANY. LIFE
SUSTAINING MY- TO KEEP ALIVE.
WELL I HAD LEAVE MY TWENTY
POSITION TO ENSURE CANNOT. THE
BEST QUALITY OF LIFE I HAVE NO
WONDER ALL. ALTERNATIVES TO
DEPEND I'D BECAUSE KEEP CALEB
HEALTH DON'T LIVE WITH MY FULL
TIME JOB. AFTER FIFTY THIRTY
THREE TEN OF WHICH WERE OPEN
HEART MARCH EIGHTEENTH TWO
THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN AT NINE
AND A HALF YEARS OLD MY SON'S
JOURNEY ON EARTH AND IT. JUST I
THOUGHT THINGS COULDN'T GET ANY
WORSE THEY DID I THOUGHT ABOUT
THE HORRIBLE REGULATION OF THE-
BANKING STOCKS FROM COLLECTING
UNEMPLOYMENT. AFTER THEIR LOVED
ONE PASSES AWAY. TO THE
HORRIFIC TIME THAT TOOK ME ON A
ROAD OF DESPERATION TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT MY NEW NORMAL
FIGHTING GRIEF SEARCHING FOR
EMPLOYMENT AND. TRYING TO PUT.
TRYING TO PULL THROUGH THE OF
MOMENT. BETWEEN WHATEVER HAVE
TO IN. I HAVE MANY BILL FUNDING
AND NO TO PAY THEIR- I'M IN
DANGER OF LOSING EVERYTHING.
OUT EVEN THOUGH FOUR YEARS HAVE
PASSED AND STILL HAVEN'T
RECOVERED FINANCIALLY I
STRUGGLING MOTIONS COMMERCIALLY
EVERYDAY. AND SUFFER WITH PTSD.
SIDE OF MY CIRCUMSTANCES I'VE
FOUND THAT I WOULD FIGHT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THIS DOESN'T
HAPPEN TO ONE MORE CARE GIVER.
I JUST SENT TO THE BLESSING
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU'RE CRYING
IN YOUR CHILD HOWEVER CARE
GIVING IS THE HARDEST JOB
YOU'LL EVER DO. BUT NO ONE WILL
EVER DO IT BETTER. NONETHELESS
WE- WHEN THE PROVIDING LIVE
THEIR LOCAL. THEY NEED SOME. AS
ALL THE OTHER ITEMS THAT'S
WORKERS. NEEDED NOW MORE THAN
EVER DO CAR ONE CURRENT. HASN'T
BEEN VERY CAN. ABOUT BECAUSE-
WHO LOSE THEIR LOVED DURING
THAT. TIMES OUR WORLD AND ONE
MOMENT THE WHOLE WILL BE TO
UPSIDE DOWN I'M WITH THE AND-
OF OUR- I KNOW. ECONOMIC HELP
WILL THEY DO HOW THEY SEEK
INPUT IN THE MIDST OF THAT. OF
OVERWHELMING GRIEF IN A WORLD
THAT IS AND ESSENTIALLY SHUT
DOWN HOW WILL THEY SURVIVE
WITHOUT ANY FINANCIAL
RESOURCES. I AM HERE TODAY
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT WHAT
HAPPENED TO ME. WHAT MORE CARE
GIVER PLEASE ENTER RIGHT BY
VOTING YES MAKE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE TO CREDIT. THANK YOU.
THE YOU MISS WILLIAMS AND THANK
YOU FOR SHARING YOUR STORY
TODAY WITH US WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO WITNESSES INSTEAD IN THE
GALLERY SEE NO ONE IN SUPPORT
OF AB NINETEEN NINETY THREE
THERE WERE LOOKING AT TWENTY
CALIFORNIA AND THERE'S NO ONE
THERE WERE WISHING TO TESTIFY
WE WILL NOW GO TO THE WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE ARVEST MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF A. B. NINETEEN
NINETY THREE PLEASE. SHARKS
EVENED OUT AYE MAN THE SHOW
SUPPORT OF AB IN NINETEEN
NINETY THREE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN THEY'RE ON NOW. AGAIN
TO SHOW SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN.
NINETY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN THEIR OWN NOW. WE DO HAVE
ABOUT TWO AND MAKE YOU LOCAL
COMBINED TO SIXTY FOUR PLEASE
CALL I HAD. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS SERRA FLOCKS CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NEXT LEVEL TIMELINE
FOR SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ANYWAY MORE DESI ARE YOU
CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF OUR
THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FIVE
ABOUT- HOME CARE PROVIDER
INSTRUCT THE PART THANK YOU
THANK YOU. AND AS A REMINDER TO
SHOW SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN
NINETY THREE PLEASE PRESS THE
ONE THAN THEIR OWN NOW AGAIN
THE COURT FOR EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN. NINETY THREE ONE THAN
THEIR OWN NOW. WE DO NOT SHOW
ANYONE ELSE AND YOU AT THAT
TIME VERY GOOD THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THOSE
IN OPPOSITION. CHINO LEAD
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION I WILL
LOOK TO THE- GALLERY THERE'S NO
ONE IN THE GALLERY WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO AB
NINETEEN NINETY THREE WILL NOW
GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY. HAND I
SEE NO ONE THEY'RE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO AB
NINETEEN NINETY THREE WILL NOW
GO TO THEM- TO THE WITNESSES
WERE WISHING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE OR VISUAL
MODERATOR. IF YOU'D PLEASE
PROMPTLY INDIVIDUAL MEETING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO AB
NINETEEN NINETY THREE PLEASE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN. WHO
OPPOSED THE EIGHT YEAR NINETEEN
NINETY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AGAIN TO UPHOLD AB.
NINETEEN NINETY THREE ONE THAN
THEIR OWN NOW. AND THERE'S NO
ONE IN Q. AS A REMINDER TO
LOCALS YEAR NINETEEN NINETY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE THAN
THEIR OWN NOW. WE DO NOT SHOW
ANYONE IN QUEUE AT THAT TIME
THANK YOU MODERATOR WE WILL NOW
BRING THAT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. WE DO HAVE A MOTION
FROM SENATOR JACKSON- WOULD YOU
BEFORE WE ENTERTAIN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE SENATOR PAN FOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KAMLAGER THANK
YOU ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COME A LONGER I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NAY VOTE
THANK YOU VERY GOOD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR JACKSON. TO A PATH PAST
DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
FOR THE CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. MEMBERS PLEASE TURN
ON YOUR MICROPHONES IN ORDER TO
CAST A VOTE. SENATOR HILL HI
SKINNER HILL HI SENATOR MORALE.
WERE ALLY CENTER MORALE BY
SENATOR JACKSON. JACKSON AYE
CENTER JACKSON HI SENATOR
MITCHELL MITCHELL AYE SENATOR
MITCHELL HI SENATOR PAN PAN HI
SENATOR PAN HI THE BILL HAS
FIVE VOTE IT IS OUT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHAU YOUR ONE OF YOUR
WITNESSES IS NOT. OF MOBILE AND
THE I DIDN'T KNOW IF THAT WOULD
BE GEORGE CHILDS WOULD YOU LIKE
TO GO. FORWARD WITHOUT THAT
WITNESS. OKAY VERY GOOD AND
THEN WE WILL- MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT BILL WE WERE NOW GOING TO
I DON'T FIFTY HONORED AB. TWO
THIRTY FOUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHILD PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN AND
SENATORS AT TWENTY TO THIRTY
FOUR WILL ALLOW THE PERSONNEL
COMMISSION'S OF SCHOOL AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS TO
SEEK. SEPARATE INDEPENDENT
LEGAL REPRESENTATION FROM THEIR
DISTRICTS ATTORNEY WANTED BUT
YOU ALREADY OF THE
COMMISSIONERS BELIEVED THE
ATTORNEYS ARE COMPROMISED BY A
CAR LIKE TO INTEREST. NO
COMMISSION SO SERVICE. THAT AND
JUST ARE TO THEIR OWN. FAIRLY
ONE OF THE MAIN FUNCTIONS OF
THE PERSONNEL COMMISSION IS TO
HEAR AND RENDER DECISIONS ON
THE DISTRICT'S DISCIPLINARY
ACTIONS IN OTHER WORDS IT
COMMISSION ACTS IN EQUITIES AYE
JUDICIAL CAPACITY REGARDING THE
DISTRICT'S ACTIONS. GENERALLY A
PERSONNEL COMMISSION RECEIVED
HER LEGAL ADVICE FROM THE SAME
LAWYERS THAT WORK FOR THE
DISTRICT. HOWEVER WHAT HAPPENS
OF THE COMMISSION WOULD RATHER
RECEIVE SEPARATE LEGAL ADVICE
FROM OUTSIDE COUNSEL. OR
THERE'S A CONFLICT OF INTEREST
WITH THE DISTRICT UNDER CURRENT
LAW- COMMISSIONERS LACKED THE
POWER TO DECIDE WHETHER THEY
MAY RECEIVE COUNSEL FROM ANYONE
OTHER THAN THE DISTRICT'S
LAWYERS. AS A RESULT THE PERSON
COMMISSION LACKS THE AUTHORITY
TO REFUSE COUNCIL OF THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY EVEN WHEN THE
COMMISSION FINDS IT
APPROPRIATE. AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTY FOUR WILL PROVIDE
PERSONAL COMMISSIONS THE RIGHT
TO RETAIN INDEPENDENT LEGAL
COUNSEL WHEN A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST EXISTS BETWEEN THE
GOVERNING BOARD AND THE
COMMISSION WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHAU I KNOW YOU TO HAVE A ONE
WITNESS THAT- UP. THE LINE I
BELIEVE- THE WITNESSES THE LARA
STILL RAIN FORESTS OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL ACTUALLY. S.
S. PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS BILL LAURA
pREPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION. WE ARE
THE MONSTERS. IN AB TWO TWO
THREE FOUR. ALL ALLOWED
PERSONNEL TO INVOKE THEIR LEAD
RIGHT AND- HOW WHEN THEY- IN
THAT BETWEEN THE MEASURE. AND
THE DISTRICT. RIGHT WAS GIVEN
THE PERSON COMMITTEE FIVE. WAY
DECADES AGO RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE WILLING TO ADMIT ECON
BETWEEN PERSONAL COMMISSION AND
DISTRICTS WE AGREE WHAT THE
COMMITTEES ANALYSIS BUT THIS
BILL IS AN EFFORT TO PRESERVE
SCHOOL PERSONNEL COMMISSION
INDEPENDENT. SCHOOL DISTRICT
COUNCIL IN THIS INTERPRETATION
IN CONTRAVENTION OF EXISTING
STATUTES AB PICTURE THREE COURT
REMEDY THAT PROBLEM. THE
DEFICIENCY IN THE LAW IS THAT
DISTRICT LAWYERS ALONG DECIDE
IF A CONFLICT EXISTS NOT QUITE
NOT THE PERSONAL. CONNECTION IN
EQUITY HAS PREVENTED AND
CONTINUE TO GROW SOME
COMMISSION FROM HIGH THEIR OWN
LAWYERS CALLING QUESTION. THE
PERSONAL ONLY ENDED. ONE
EXAMPLE DISTRICTS SUPPORTED THE
ELIMINATION OF THE MEDICAID.
THERE WAS EIGHT FIFTEEN BETWEEN
DISTRICT AND COMMISSION ABOUT
THE PROCESS. CLEAR CONFLICT THE
COMMISSION FOR INDEPENDENT TO
FIGHT THEM IT'S BEEN BILL LYING
ON THE TABLE BECAUSE AFTER.
MISTER FLOYD RECEIVED PROVIDING
THE COMMISSION FROM HIGH THEIR
OWN HEALTH. BODY WHAT CAN I GET
WRITE ON LAW IT WAS NOT ABLE TO
PROTECT THEMSELVES WITH
INDEPENDENT LEGAL ADVICE IN
ANOTHER IS WITH YOU TO STATE A
PERSONNEL WHO WOULD THINK.
SELECT BY BEING THE PERSON
COOLEY AND WE I WAS REQUIRED IN
THE LAW. THE DISTRICT A LEAD
THAT THE COMMISSIONER WITH THE
ALLEN BAY ON THE DID. PLAN
CHECKS THE CANDIDATES HAVE TO
DEAL WITH WENT TO COURT IT
FEATURED IN CLEARING NAME THE
DISTRICT HILL WITH YOU DEFEAT.
THE COMMISSION ASKED FOR IN THE
LEGAL COUNSEL ADVISE THE
COMMISSION AND THE DISTRICT
LEGAL COUNSEL WITH YOU AGAIN
THE NINETEEN INDEPENDENT BODY
THERE RIGHT UNDER EXISTING LAW.
PERSONNEL COMMISSION ARE
INDEPENDENT BODY FITTING SURE
DISTRICT ARE HIRING QUALIFIED.
EMPLOYEES UNLAWFUL PATH. THEY
ALSO THIRTY THE NEW DECISION
MAKER ON IN IT. TO CLASSIFY
EMPLOYEES ARE. MISSION ARE
DENIED THEIR WHITE IN LEGAL
POWER. FRANKLY OUR JOB HANG IN
ABOUT. AND IT IS MORE FORGET
LEGAL. BURKE OF WHETHER CAN AN
BE TURNED THEIR CAL. FOR
UNAWARE OF ANY OTHER LOGGED IN
WILD BOY. THE TERM WHO THE
QUIET AND NOT THE OTHER WAY OF.
AB TWO TWO THREE FOUR WENDY THE
PROBLEM BY ALLOWING COMMISSION
TO DECIDE BECAUSE EXISTS NEARLY.
VOTE OF THE COMMISSION THANK.
YOU HAVE DISTRICTS HAVE A POINT
OF A COMMISSIONER CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEES HAVE A APPOINTMENT OF
THE COMMISSION. AND THEN A
NEUTRAL THE TO AGREE TO ANOTHER
WHICH IS A NEUTRAL SO THAT
PEOPLE READY CHECK ON THE- TO
GET YOUR HAS WE CAN BROUGHT
THAT WE SEE THIS AS A REQUEST
AND FAIR. DOES NOT SUPPORT THE
MANY THE BILL TO THE STATE
BAR'S WILL BUT- CONDUCT. THE
BILL COVERED TO BE OF WHERE.
AND NOT RIGHT THE RIGHT.
THERE'S A LADY THERE AND BIG US
BANK COMMISSION ARE INDEPENDENT
BODIES NOT MORE. ALREADY HAVE
THE DOCTOR RIGHT. INDEPENDENT
LEGAL COUNSEL INCOME AB TWO TO
THREE ALLOWED TO INVOKE THE
RIGHT THE LEGISLATURE THEM
DECADES AGO AND NOT TO HAVE
RIGHT BY GET YOUR- YES EIGHT.
THREE RIGHT UP. VERY GOOD THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL NOW TO.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT IN THE
GALLERY I SEE NO ONE IN THE
GALLERY WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF- AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTY FOUR LOOKING TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NO ONE
THERE FOR TOOK- IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY FOUR. AND
NOW WE WILL LOOK TO WITNESSES
WHAT WAITING TO TESTIFY ON THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB.
TWENTY TWO THIRTY FOUR. CHECK
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY TWO.
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO NOW. AGAIN TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTY FOUR. PLEASE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NOW MEDIA
OF ABOUT THIRTY IN THE QUEUE
WILL START WHAT LINE TO TAKE
BEFORE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS TERAFLOPS
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MAXALT TO
LINE SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS DAVID NEVIN ON BEHALF
OF THE LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT WE MAINTAIN A
SUPPORT COMMANDED POSITION- THE
ISSUE BE CONFLICT IS NOT. THANK
YOU. FOR VOLATILE LINE SEVENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE
SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOU MAY BE
NEEDED. SORRY AGAIN HE SHOWED
SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS THE
ONE BUTTON ZERO NOW AGAIN TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE ONE AND THEN
THEY'RE ON NOW GLOBAL TEL LINE.
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE CALL I HAD.
NINE SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. OKAY LEARN LET ME PULL MY
NAME IS GEORGE COLE ARE PART
THE DEPUTY DIRECTLY FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL PERSONNEL
COMMISSION BECAUSE SHE- I
STRUGGLING TO FIVE YEAR IN THAT.
YOU KNOW READ OUT HERE UP
PLEASE YOUR POSITION. I AM AS A
REMINDER FOR SUPPORT. FOR
EIGHTEEN TWENTY TO THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE PRESS APPLY AND THEN
THEY'RE ON NOW. AND WE NOT SHOW
ANYONE IN CUBA TIME. THANK YOU
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO OPPOSITION
SINCE REFER TO FIRST SUPPORT
ANYWAY IN THE WE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY
FOUR NOT SEEN ANYONE. GOING TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NO
ONE IN TWENTY FORTY WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO THE WITNESSES WAITING
TO TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
ARVEST. THOSE WISHING TO UP TO
PLEASE PROMPT MODERATOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF AB. TWENTY TWO
THIRTY FOUR. CHECK AND TO
OPPOSE AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY
FOUR PLEASE PRACTICAL ONE THAN
THEIR OWN NOW. AGAIN TO UPHOLD
AB. TWENTY TWO THIRTY FOUR
CLEAVED PRESS ONE AND THEN
THEIR OWN NOW. AND WE DID NOT
SHOW ANYONE IN THE QUEUE AT THE
REMINDER TO OPPOSE AB. TWENTY
TWO THIRTY FOUR PLEASE. ONE OF
THEM THEIR OWN NOW. AND THERE
IS NO ONE IN A KIA THANK YOU
MODERATOR THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
THE GREAT JOB THIS AFTERNOON OR
THIS EVENING- WILL NOW TAKE
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE-
AFTER HEARING THE SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION SENATOR MITCHELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND- SO EVEN BUT CHAO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR.
UNDERSTANDING THAT IT WAS NOT A
HOSTILE ACT THAT I AFTER TO BE
REMOVED FROM CONSENT I JUST
NEEDED TO ASK A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS I ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THE INQUIRE EASE I GOT
WERE RECEIVED VERY LATE. ON BUT
THEY WERE FOR TWO MAJOR
INSTITUTIONS OF MY DISTRICT LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT- I COMMITTEE COLLEGE
DISTRICT I THINK WE HEARD THE
WITNESS GOT CUT OFF A BIT AND
IT REALLY IS THIS QUESTION OF
THE FOR THE- TERM CONFLICT- I
HEARD YOUR- PRIMARY- PROPONENT
WITNESS STATE THAT ATTEMPTING
TO USE THE CALIFORNIA BAR'S
RULES OF PROFESSIONAL CONDUCT.
WAS NOT APPROPRIATE- BUT BUT I
DO HAVE A CONCERN IF THERE IS A
DISTRICTS LARA L. A. C. E. B.
D. THAT'S CONCERNED. NOT HAVING
TO DEFINITE. TERM OF YOU. KIND
OF RESPONDING. RESPECT ON THAT.
THANK YOU FOR MUCH OF SENATOR
PER YOUR QUESTION IN I THINK
THE WITNESS SAW TO EXPLAIN
SITUATION TO SOME EXTENT I
THINK THE SHORT ANSWER IS IT IS
NOT NECESSARY TO FURTHER DEFINE
THE TERM THE TERM CONFLICT OF
INTEREST ESSENTIALLY IS A TERM
THAT HAS BEEN COMMONLY USED.
AND OUT AND THE ARE YOU KNOW
MOST OF THE COMMISSIONERS ARE
NOT TRAINED IN THE LAW AND DOG
YOU KNOW THE DAILY OF PEOPLE
ESSENTIALLY AND ADDING A LAYER
OF DEFINITION TO THE TERM
ITSELF COULD. CONFUSE PEOPLE
NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO IS THE
WORST TESTIFIED- HOW WE'RE
ASKING NON LAWYERS TO IT
BASICALLY INTERPRET WHAT IS THE
RULE OF PROFESSIONAL CONDUCT
WHICH ACTUALLY TAKES A SOMEWHAT
OF A YOU KNOW LEAGUE LEGAL
EXPERTISE SO I THINK THAT
BASICALLY CONFUSES IN A
COMPLICATED MATTER AND ON TOP
OF THAT- UNDER CURRENT LAW. ON
THE LAWYER FOR THE DISTRICT ARE
ALREADY UNDER THE OBLIGATION TO
RECUSE IF THEIR POTENTIAL IT
PARTICULAR SITUATION SO THIS
BILL ESSENTIALLY WOULD PROVIDE
THAT MECHANISM FOR THE COURSE
NOW COMMISSION TO BASICALLY I
DO SOME KIND OF A CHECK AND
BALANCE IN. SURE THAT BODY TO
SEPARATE. THAT IT DOES THERE'S
A CAR. TO ITS YOU KNOW THE GOAL
IS PLEASE THE- ALLOW. IN OF YOU
KNOW BY ONE BUT FROM THE- THANK
YOU IT DOES I THINK A THE EXAM
HERE FOR GAY YOU KNOW I OF
INTEREST IT IT'S SOMETHING THAT
WOULD LEGALLY PREVENT ME FROM
WAYNE IN IN A DELIBERATION
BECAUSE I HAVE SOME POTENTIAL
PERSONAL GAIN. THE EXAMPLES
THEY GAVE FELT TO ME LIKE IT
WAS A DIFFERENCE OF OPINION
THAT LEGAL COUNSEL DIDN'T HONOR
THE REQUEST. OF THE BODY- TO
MAKE A DECISION- SO. HE HELPED
ME UNDERSTAND WHICH WHICH ISSUE
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO SOLVE WITH
THE WITH THE BILL. BUT B. E. OR
THE BILL TRY TO RESOLVE THIS
SITUATION WHERE THERE IS A-
POTENTIAL CONFLICT OF INTEREST
BETWEEN THE PERSONNEL
COMMISSION AND THE BOARD ITSELF
EITHER THE YOU THE BOARD IS
COMMITTEE COLLEGE BOARD OR K.
TWELVE BOARD HOUSE WHENEVER
THERE IS AN ISSUE THAT MAY
PRESENT SOME KIND OF- POTENTIAL
CONFLICT. ALL USING THE SAME
LAWYER THEN DOT SO WHEN THIS
LAW IS INVOKED K. ONE MORE
QUESTION IF I MAY MISTER CHAIR
AND THIS WAS THE QUESTION POSED
BY L. A. U. S. D. BECAUSE THE
BILL IS IN KEY FISCAL. THAT'S
ALSO I REALIZE THAT THE BILL
WOULD GO FROM HERE DIRECTLY TO
THE FLOOR WE WOULD HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY- AND APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE THAT TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE. IT'S NOT KEEP FISCAL
BUT- THERE'S CONCERNS THAT IT
HAS FISCAL IMPLICATIONS ON
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND K<c.cyan></c>
FOURTEEN SCHOOL DISTRICTS- IN
THAT THEY WOULD BE. RESPONSIBLE
FOR PAYING FOR OUTSIDE COUNSEL
THAT SOMEONE ARGUE COULD BE AT
A HIGHER COST SO COULD YOU
RESPOND- TO THE FACT THAT IT'S
NOT KEEP FISCAL OF THIS A
UNFUNDED MANDATE THAT WE'RE-
PUTTING ON DISTRICTS WELL LIKE
YOU SAID. THE BILL IS
ESSENTIALLY TACKED. ON
NONPHYSICAL AND D. A. R. D.
EXPECTATION IS THAT THE LAW IS
NOT GOING TO BE INVOKED OFTEN
TELL THAT FREQUENTLY BECAUSE
THERE ARE TWO MAIN. REASONS WHY
IS THAT I THINK GOD FOR
CONFLICT BETWEEN BODIES. CLUB
SO YOU KNOW I FEEL LIKE I ALSO
THE IDEA TO THE WITNESS SPONSOR.
WILL HAVE FIRST HAND OF DOUBTS
THE PLEASURE THE DUTCH. YES I'M
SORRY WAS THE QUESTION SHOULD
IF COULD DOT THE FOR TO THE-
WHO HELP FOR HAND KNOWLEDGE
ABOUT THIS. OF THE CALL YES. WE
CERTAIN COULD. IS THE WITNESS
ON THE- HELLO. YES THANK YOU
YEAH FEDERAL. MISTER DOLORES-
WITH THE CFDA AND WE DON'T SEE
THIS AS A FISCAL MATTER BECAUSE
AGAIN BILL. THIS LAW HAS BEEN
IN EFFECT FOR DECADES I THINK
IN THE EIGHTIES WHEN IT WAS PUT
INTO LAW WHICH ALLOWED. WHICH
ACTUALLY GAVE PERSONNEL
COMMISSION. NOT WHITE. THAT
LEGAL COUNSEL. IF THERE'S A CAR.
IN IT IF THE LAW. IN THE
DISTRICT WHERE NEIL OR SHE HAVE
KNOWN. I AM WE DON'T WE THAT
THAT IT. AND WE DON'T THINK IT
A FISCAL ISSUE BECAUSE THE
TOPIC WHEN INITIAL WHEN IT
EFFECT. THEY WOULD HAVE ALREADY
VALUE WHAT THE COSTS ARE IN IT
IN AN ALSO A FINANCIALLY. THAT
DISTRICT LAWYER THE
REPRESENTING COMMISSION NOW IN
BAD EXPENSES BEING COVERED SO
WE DON'T THINK THERE'S A COFFEE
IF THEY'RE IF THEY'RE JUST
MINIMAL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
A IN A PRE YOU A WOMAN FROM ME
TO ASK MY- QUESTIONS I RECORD
YOU MISTER. THANK VERY MUCH
SENATOR MITCHELL- OTHER KEPT
QUESTIONS YES SENATOR JACKSON.
YES HI OF. I THINK I UNDERSTAND
THE DISTINCTION HERE WE'RE NOT
LOOKING AT A TECHNICAL CONFLICT
OF INTEREST OF INTEREST SO AN
ATTORNEY WOULD HAVE A CONFLICT
OF INTEREST IF FOR EXAMPLE HERE
SHE WAS REPRESENTING A CLIENT
ON ONE SIDE AND IT REPRESENTED
A CLIENT WHO WAS OR HAD BEEN ON
THE OTHER SIDE- SO THOSE ARE
LEGAL CONFLICTS- WHAT I
UNDERSTAND AND I'D LIKE TO ASK
THE AUTHOR IF YOU COULD VERIFY
THIS. IS THIS IS A COMPLEX IF
THE TOURNEY SEES THE ISSUE
DIFFERENTLY THAN THE
ORGANIZATION SO IN OTHER WORDS
THEY THE INTERNSHIPS I DON'T
AGREE WITH YOUR ANALYSIS AND
I'M NOT GOING TO PRESENT THIS
ISSUE THE WAY YOU WISH BECAUSE
I THINK IT SHOULD BE X. YOU IT
SHOULD Y. SO. THAT'S WHAT I DO
KNOW IF THAT ISN'T FOR THE CASE
BUT THAT'S AS I SEE IT THERE.
THERE WASN'T A WHOLE LOT OF
EXPOSITION IN OUR ANALYSIS
BECAUSE I THINK THERE WAS A- NO
THE OBJECTION AND NO OPPOSITION
ADDED REGISTER BUT- IF I AM
CORRECT WOULD YOU. A IN THAT IF
I'M NOT CORRECT JUST IGNORE
THAT THAT IS CORRECT I THINK-
YET WHENEVER THERE IS A
DIFFERENCE IN OPINION BETWEEN
TWO LAWYERS I THINK THAT'S
WHERE THE CONFLICT- POTENTIAL
CONFLICT MAY ARISE CORRECT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
CLARIFICATION. OKAY THANK YOU
THE BILL HELP OKAY THANK YOU
SENATOR MITCHELL WOULD YOU HAVE
A MOTION TO MOVE TO PASS OF DRY
CLOTHES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL VERY VERY MUCH OF THE
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THE MOTION IS TO PASS. CENTER-HILL HI SENATOR HILL HI CENTER
MORALE. BERLEI CENTER MORALE BY
CENTER JACKSON. JACKSON AYE
CENTER JACKSON BY CENTER
MITCHELL MITCHELL IICENTER
MITCHELL HI CENTER PAN. CENTER
PAN I. ACCORDING TO THE HOUSE
FIVE OCEAN AND IT IS OUT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PRECIADO SO WE WILL WE HAVE A
COUPLE OF PROBLEM ONE- THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA IS IT
HEAD IN THE ORDER THE FILE
ORDER. AND SO HE SHOULD BE
GOING TO WE DO HAVE A HARD STOP
AT SEVEN PM IS OUR OTHER
PROBLEMS. I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
PROCEDURE. IS IF WE ARE HALFWAY
THROUGH. A BILL IN TO FINISH IT
THE- WHAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA
IS NEXT IN THE FILE. MY
APOLOGIES FOR YOUR PATIENCE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER BUT-
FILE ORDERS THE FILE ORDER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
PROBLEMS IN AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTY ONE WHICH DEFINES WHEN
THE PUBLIC SUBSIDY IS DE
MINIMIS FOR THE PURPOSE OF
DETERMINING IF THE PREVAILING
WAGE APPLIES TO PRIVATE
PROJECTS USING PUBLIC FUNDS THE
BILL PROVIDES THAT A PUBLIC
SUBSIDY ON A PRIVATE PROJECT IS
DE MINIMUS SO LONG AS IT IS
LESS THAN FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO LESS THAN 2% OF THE
TOTAL PROJECT COST. THIS BILL
PRESENTS FROM THE FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND OR THRESHOLD
CONSTRUCTION SINGLE FAMILY
HOUSING UNITS UNDER CURRENT LAW
A PROJECT IS NOT SUBJECT TO
PREVAILING WAGE LAW EVEN IF IT
RECEIVES A PUBLIC SUBSIDY IT
THAT SUBSIDY IS DE MINIMUS IN
THE CONTEXT OF THE PROJECT ALSO
IF THE PROJECT IS FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS EXEMPT
UNDER LATE BECAUSE SECTION
SEVENTEEN TWENTY AND THAT'S
ALSO THE CASE IN THIS. AS WELL.
THE TO MINIMIZE. DEFINED IN
START. THERE IS NO GO. AS TO
THEIR PER LEVEL PUBLIC SUBSIDY.
THAT SHOULD BE CONSIDERED
MINIMIS. THIS IS WHAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF. RELATIONS TO
MAKE THINK IT'S- RULES. AS TO
WHAT IS. LEADING TO CONVEY. AND
COST OF THAT ADDITIONAL WHAT
THE TERM ACTUALLY MEANS. FOR
EXAMPLE IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN.
THE DEPARTMENT APPROVED AS DE
MINIMIS A ONE POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLAR. PUBLIC SUBSIDY TO A
NINETY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR NOT
PROCESSING FACILITY PROJECT
SINCE IT WAS ONLY. ONE POINT
SEVEN FIVE PERCENT. THE TOTAL
PROJECT COST. A PUBLIC SUBSIDY
FOR A PROJECT BY PROJECT THAT
IS MORE THAN FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS OR TWO
PERCENT. THE TOTAL PROJECT
COSTS AS A NOTABLE. TAXPAYER
INVESTMENT. BUT IT IS
REASONABLE TO REQUIRE
PREVAILINGWAGES OF THE
DEVELOPER WANTS PUBLIC SUBSIDY.
OF THAT AMOUNT. THE COMPANY
NINETEEN PANDEMICS BUT
SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL STRAIN OR
WORKFORCE. MANY WORKERS HAVE
BEEN LAID OFF AFTER HOURS
REDUCE OF TAKING UNPAID LEAVE.
TO CARE FOR THEIR FAMILIES MORE
CRITICAL THAN EVER. THE
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS FOR A
LIVABLE. WAGES PRIOR PROJECTS
ARE SUBSIDIZED BY TAXPAYERS.
WORKERS ARE PAID THE BILL AND
WAGES. ARE MORE LIKELY TO
WHETHER THIS CRISIS.
SUCCESSFULLY SUPPORT THEIR
FAMILIES A BUT NECESSARY
DOLLARS. BACK INTO A DECIMATED
LOCAL ECONOMIES. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR MY BOAT AND HAVE ONE
WITNESS JEREMY SMITH. STATE
BUILDING CONSTRUCTORS COUNCIL
THANK YOU MISTER. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WITH US. OVER YOU DO
HAVE TO THE WITNESS TWO
WITNESSES ONE WITNESS IN
SUPPORT- JEREMY SMITH STATE
BUILDING TRADES COUNCIL- YES
VERY GOOD THANK YOU. IN THE-
THANK YOU GOOD EVENING MISTER
THANK YOU MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS GERRY
SMITH. HERE BE HAPPY STATE BILL
AGAINST TRADES. OR THE SPOTS OF
AB. TWENTY THIRTY ONE. WHAT ARE
CURRENTLY OUR GUIDE IN
DEVELOPER TO ACCEPT SUCH TOTAL
LESS THAN 2% THE TOTAL OF THE
PROJECT AND NOT HAVE TO PAY THE
PREVAILING WAGE SUBSIDY IS DE
MINIMUS. IN THE CONTEXT OF THE
OVERALL PROJECT. THIS EXCEPTION
ENACTED IN TWO THOUSAND ONE WAS
MEANT TO ENSURE THAT PRIVATE
DEVELOPMENTS DID NOT GET
MANDATED TO PAY THE PREVAILING
WAGE. FOR SOME INSIGNIFICANT
COSTS OF DEVELOPER THAT WERE
BORN BY TAXPAYERS LIKE. FEES TO
FILE PLANS WITH THE PLANNING
COMMISSION FOR EXAMPLE OR FOR
PUBLIC AT THE GIFTED SOMETHING
LIKE PUBLICLY FINANCED PART. TO
A PROJECT. DOES NOT MEANT TO
ALLOW. AMOUNTS OF TAXPAYER
DOLLARS TO BE USED BY
DEVELOPERS WITHOUT PAYMENT OF
THE PREVAILING WAGE.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT IS HAPPENING.
THIS IS BECAUSE SEVERAL YEARS
AFTER THE DIMINISH THE
MINIMIZATION WAS ADOPTED THEN.
THE THEN THE I. R. DIRECTOR
ISSUED GUIDANCE SAYING HE
BELIEVED THAT PARTICULAR PUBLIC
SUBSIDY OF SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS WAS THE MINIMUS BECAUSE
IT WAS ONLY. ONE POINT 64% OF
THE TOTAL PROJECT COST. AFTER
THAT THE I. R. SIMPLY ASSUMED
IN THE ABSENCE OF ANY
LEGISLATIVE GUIDANCE FOR COURT
DECISION. THAT ANY SUBSIDY OF
LESS THAN 2% OF TOTAL PROJECT
COST IS ALWAYS TO MINIMIZE EVEN
IF THE SUBSIDY IS FOR MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS. NO COURT HAS
ADDRESSED THIS NOR HAS THE AYE
ARE EVER CITED ANY LEGAL
AUTHORITY FOR ITS 2%
INTERPRETATION. BEYOND ITS
ORIGINAL ORIGINAL LETTER. THIS
BILL WOULD PROVIDE CERTAINTY
REGARDING THE NEED TO MINIMIZE
ACCORDING TO SEVERAL D. I. R.
DETERMINATIONS AS THE POLL HAS
A LOT OF OTHER PERSON RECEIVE
PUBLIC SUBSIDIES RANGING FROM
SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS AS
MENTIONED. TO FOUR POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS AND NOT BE
REQUIRED TO PAY DEPENDING WHICH-
A AB TWENTY THREE ONE. PAUL AND
WILL ENSURE THE DEVELOPED PAPER
LANGUAGE WHEN THEY CHOOSE TO
ACCEPT THE PUBLIC SUBSIDY OVER
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND AND OVER
2% OF TOTAL PROJECT COST. A
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS LOWER
CEILING WOULD HAVE NO IMPACT ON
PROJECTS UNDER TWENTY FIVE
MILLION. FURTHERMORE AND THEN
THAT'S TAKEN LAST YEAR AND PUT
IN THIS BILL THIS YEAR.
INSURERS OF THE BILL DOES NOT
APPLY TO SINGLE FAMILY HOME
CONSTRUCTION. WE TOOK AN
AMENDMENT AT THE REQUEST OF THE
OPPONENTS LAST YEAR EXISTING
ISN'T EXEMPTIONS ALREADY EXEMPT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AS WELL IN
THE IN THE LABOR CODE. THESE
PUBLIC SUBSIDIES HAVE ALWAYS
BEEN AND STILL WILL BE
VOLUNTARILY ACCEPTED ON THE
PART OF DEVELOPER. THIS IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THE
PREVAILING WHICH PROVIDES
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES FOR
HIGHLY SKILLED LOCAL WORKERS
AND APPRENTICES RECEIVING
TRAINING AND STATE APPROVED
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS. AND
PROVIDES THEM WITH HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE AND BENEFITS THAT WE
ALL TAKE GRANTED. YOUR ANALYSIS
CORRECTLY POINTS OUT THAT FOR
REALLY WAIT BUT THERE IS NO
COURT BETWEEN LOWER WAGES AND
LOWER COSTS. WE WOULD CONTEND
THAT DEVELOPER SAVE MONEY BY
PROJECTS FINISHING ON TIME AT
OR BELOW BUDGET AND BUILD A
HIGHER QUALITY WHEN PULLING
WORKERS EARNING THE PREVAILING
WAGE. FINALLY DURING THIS BEEN
RECEPTION RECESSION WE NEED TO
ENSURE THAT SCARCE TAXPAYER
DOLLARS WERE PROVIDED TO
PRIVATE FOLDERS ON A VOLUNTARY
BASIS GO TO PROVIDE LIVING.
WAGES TO CONSTRUCTION. IT IS.
THAT WORKERS ARE NOT LEFT. WHAT
PUBLIC ARE UTILIZED IT IS FOR
THESE THAT WE ARE YOU TO VOTE
ON AB. TWENTY THREE ONE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER WE WILL
NOW LOOK FOR OTHERS IN THE
GALLERY WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY
ONE SEEN NO FAULT IT'S- MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS COMMITTEE
CHRISTY VALVE HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD
OF BOILERMAKERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MISS BALA
NOW LOOKING FOR ANYONE ELSE IN
THE GALLERY FOR SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY TWO THIRTY ONE THERE IS
NO ONE LOOKING TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. THERE IS NO ONE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WISHING TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT WILL NOW GO TO. THE
THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK AND
WITNESSES REPORT WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY ONE
PLEASE. CHERRY LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR
AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NOW. AGAIN
TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY
TWO THIRTY ONE. PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO NOW. AND WE
HAVE YOU AND MAKE YOU WILL
START AT LINE FORTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MR SURE NUMBERS CAN
BE DONE YOU DROWNED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL
LEADERS CALLED. THE PORT. THANK
YOU. WE HAVE ONE MORE AND MAKE
YOUR TO BE JUST A MOMENT BUT AS
A REMINDER TO SHOW SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NOW
WELL MEXICO TO LINE FOR NINETY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
SEARCH CARE MEMBERS MIKE MONICA
TO BE HAVE TO CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS THE CALIFORNIA STATE.
COUNCIL THE WESTERN STATES
COUNCIL SHEET METAL WORKERS IN
THE INTERNATIONAL UNION OF
ELEVATOR CONSTRUCTORS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND AS A REMINDER TO SHOW-SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTY ONE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
NOW. WE DO NOT SHOW ANYONE IN
QUEUE AT THIS MOMENT. THANK YOU
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THOSE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTY ONE AND I UNDERSTAND
STEVE CRUZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IS ON THE LINE. MR
CRUZ YES THAT'S CORRECT- THIS
CHAIR MEMBERS I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ALL GET THROUGH THIS AS
QUICKLY A POSSIBLE SPEAKERS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTY ONE AS A STUDENT KALRA
BECAUSE STASHED DEFINITION OF
THE TERM. THAT DETERMINES HOW
THE LEVEL OF PUBLIC SUBSIDY-
THE TRIGGERS OF ANYWAYS
REQUIREMENTS AND OTHERWISE
PRIVATE DEVELOP PROJECTS- THE
DAILY OVERTURN. THE ESTABLISHED
PRACTICE DID YOU PUBLIC FUNDS
IN THE CONTEXT OF THE PROJECT
AND YOU 22% OF THE GENERAL
THRESHOLD FOR DIMINISH. THE
TERMINATIONS AND WE'RE NOT
OPPOSED TO INCLUDING A 2%
STATUTE WHICH THE- WE BELIEVE
IT AN ARBITRARY FIVE REBELS
DOLLAR. CAP IT WOULD LEAD TO
SIGNIFICANT COSTS OF NEW
HOUSING- I JUST A QUICK EXAMPLE
PUBLISHED AT THE WOULD BE
TRIGGERED BY- YEAH OF COURSE.
OF ENERGY AND WATER CONTRA
MEASURES TO INCLUDE. THE HOME
HOME PARTICIPATION AND USE OF
THE HOME PROGRAM. FINALLY ARE
NEARLY IDENTICAL MEASURES WOULD
REACH OUT IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN BY GOVERNOR BROWN IN
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN BY NEW
SUBMIT. ABSTRACT IN THE
IDENTICAL DETAILED MESSAGES
THAT. NOTHING TO SUGGEST THAT
THE LONGSTANDING PRACTICE OF
CONSIDERING THE PUBLIC SUBSIDY
WAS INSUFFICIENT. REASONS WE
MUST CLOSE AB TWENTY THIRTY ONE
THANK YOU. FOR THE GOOD THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CRUISE THAT WE
WILL NOW LOOK FOR ANYONE IT'S
IN OPPOSITION TO. AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTY ONE IN THE GALLERY SCENE
NO ONE THEY'RE GOING TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION. THERE'S NO ONE
THERE AS WELL WILL NOW GO TO
THOSE WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
URBIS MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING. TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF AB. TWENTY TWO
THIRTY ONE PLEASE. SHARE LADIES
AND- WHO OPPOSE AB. TWENTY TO
THIRTY ONE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
NOW. AGAIN TO UPHOLD AB TWENTY
TWO THIRTY ONE. RIGHT THE ONE
AND THEN ZERO NOW. AND IT LOOKS
LIKE WE DO HAVE ABOUT FOUR IN
THE KEEL WILL START WITH FOUR
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU. TIME IF YOU CAME OUT
OF TOWN ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF
ASSOCIATED BUILDERS AND
CONTRACTORS OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MR OWN.
NEXT TO A LITTLE TOO FOR
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GLAD. BUT
HAVING COME TO HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK
YOU. HELLO TWO FOUR NINETY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN HILDA DEEP IT WENT
THIS CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATED GENERAL CONTRACTORS
OF CALIFORNIA REGRETTABLY WERE
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
AGAIN THANK YOU GERMAN HELP.
THANK YOU MISTER FOR WENT THIS.
CONNECT HELLO TWO FOUR NINETY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING SACRAMENTO THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
COURTEOUS IN THE SPECIALTY
CONTRACTORS IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU THANK YOU HERNANDEZ.
MAGDALO Q. FOUR NINETY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. JUST FOR LIKE
WELL PRESENTING THE
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF PAINTERS
AND ALLIED TRADES AND I'M
ACTUALLY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. AS A REMINDER TO
UPHOLD AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY ONE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NOW AGAIN
WHO OPPOSED AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTY ONE. AND THEN ZERO NOW.
AND WE DO NOT SHOW ANYONE IN
THE QUEUE. THANK YOU MODERATOR
APPRECIATE THE GOOD WORK WE
WILL NOW BRING THAT AFTER
HEARING THE SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR A DISCUSSION OR
QUESTIONS. SEEING NO QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALL OVER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. MOST RESPECTED US
RELIABLE THANK YOU PATRICIA
GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR
MITCHELL DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. MOTIONS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
MEMBERS PLEASE TURN ON YOUR
MICROPHONES IN ORDER TO CAST A
VOTE SENATOR HILL HI SENATOR
HILL HI CENTER MORALE. WELL NO
CENTER MORALE NO. SENATOR
JACKSON JACKSON AYE SENATOR
JACKSON HI SENATOR MITCHELL
MITCHELL LIVE SENATOR MITCHELL
HI SENATOR PAN CAN I SENATOR
PAN HI THE BILL HAS FOUR VOTES
AND IT IS OUT. THANK YOU MR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA THAT- CONCLUDES
THE BUSINESS TODAY OF THE LABOR
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND
RETIREMENT COMMITTEE ALL OF
THOSE BILLS THAT- WE
UNFORTUNATELY DID NOT GET TO
TODAY AND I APOLOGIZE TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER WHO FOR
HIS PATIENCE AND HE WAS HERE
FOR QUITE AWHILE. BUT
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE THAT HARD
STOP TONIGHT I END UP TO ALL OF
THOSE BILLS WILL BE TAKEN UP AT
OUR SECOND HERE IN OUR NEXT
HEARING WHICH WILL BE NEXT
TUESDAY THE ELEVENTH AT ONE
THIRTY PM AND- EVERY BILL WILL
BE HEARD THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THIS TO ME. A HEARING IS
ADJOURNED.